Previously on Movamex mit der Bahn.
Also Urlaub heißt für mich, ich möchte einen anderen Ort.
Aber ich möchte ja nicht was anderes machen. Ich will einfach nur einen anderen Ort.
Meine Damen und Herren, jetzt erreichen wir meinen Heim aufs Bahnhof.
Sie können hier nicht halten, das ist Edsland.
Digitales Sehwieso, da kannst du irgendwie nicht so...
Wir möchten uns vor der Anfahrt, die aus Steigen verabschieden, auf Wiedersehen.
Wenn es da kein Netz gibt, dann ist es einfach nicht bewohnbar.
Das ist Edsland.
Und dann warst du mit dem Urlaub, dann kannst du dann wieder nach Hause fahren.
...mit der Bimmelbahn ins Ding. Aussteigen, hier gibt es Internet.
Muss irgendwo im Ausland sein.
Ich bin ja neulich wieder viele ICE gefahren, von Berlin weg und das Bedrückende ist, man weiß, es gibt jetzt die Internetinfrastruktur auf dieser Strecke, also so Richtung Westen, aber gefühlt nur 5% aller Züge, die man so erwischen kann, also so eine 1 zu 20 Chance, bietet dir dann auch das W-Laden mit der entsprechenden Technik, das dann auch mal so in diesen Zug rein zu pumpen. Und es ist einfach unfassbar, wie viel Kreativität da irgendwie verloren geht. Ja, ist doch schlimm, oder?
Ja, aber da geht die Fahrt doch schneller rum. Da rennt man die ganze Zeit hinterher und ist beschäftigt. Geht's jetzt, geht's nicht. Geht's jetzt, geht's nicht.
Ja, genau, das ist dann auch wirklich alles, was man macht.
Man kann auch nicht darüber twittern, ob's geht oder nicht.
Ja, ja, ja, wenn man den könnte.
Wenn's geht.
Wenn's mal geht, ja.
Genau, immer wenn's geht, twittert man darüber, dass es gerade nicht ging. Großartig. Wie auch immer, willkommen zu Movamex Nummer 111. Eint kein Ende, genau. Sollte sich irgendjemand die Hoffnung gemacht haben, die Sendung sei jetzt binnen zwei Wochen komplett abgesetzt worden? So leicht kommt ihr uns nicht davon.
Wieso abgesetzt?
Na, weiß ich nicht, wegen Nachrichtenflotte.
Seit wann können wir denn nicht quatschen, wenn's keine Nachrichten gibt? Machen wir doch heute schon seit fünf Jahren, oder?
Na ja, gefühlt gibt's ja schon seit, ich weiß nicht, seit wann gibt's irgendwie nichts Neues?
Mindestens seit dem letzten iPhone, oder? Oder kam danach noch was?
Na dann war...
Was haben uns die Römer eigentlich gebracht?
Was hat Apple jemals für uns getan? So lange wir noch überlegen, worüber wir überhaupt reden können, kurze Vorstellung, sind eigentlich fast alle da, außer Hucke, Dennis, Clemens? Roddy? Ich bin auch da. Und außerdem haben wir dann Huckes Platz gleich passend besetzt. Und zwar begrüßen wir als Gast Michael Göbel. Hallo. Bekannt auch als Moab.
Moab.
Wenn ich das nicht sag, den Ollrum kennt glaub ich jeder.
Den Ollrum?
Den Ollrum.
Das musst du mal auflösen.
Ich nicht. Okay, keiner kennt den Ollrum. Ollrum ist die beste, tollste Katze der Welt.
Ah, bist du so ein Katzenblogger?
Ja, ich brauche die Bildrechte meiner Katze.
Und was, also ich meine, was kommt da so, was kommt da so bei raus?
Der tägliche Ollrum zum Beispiel.
Der tägliche Ollrum?
Der tägliche Ollrum.
Aber du bloggst auch ganz fleißig unter, jetzt hab ich das grad schon wieder verdrängt. Wie heißt noch gleich das Blog?
Auf Deutsch, Apfelplus, apfelplusz.de.
Apfelplusz, was möchtest du da rückgängig machen?
Bei Apfelplusz rückgängig machen, dass ich zwischendurch mal drei Jahre lang aufgehört hab. Da war es richtig, also für ein deutsches Blog gar nicht mal so schlecht. Und da hab ich dann gedacht, tötest du es mal. Und irgendwann hab ich dann festgestellt, das war nicht so gut. Nee, auch Apfelplusz. Und dann hab ich es einfach getötet, dann hab ich irgendwie andere Dinge gemacht, die dann so vor sich hin dubbelten, paar sind hinterhergezogen, aber nicht wirklich viele. Und irgendwann hab ich, das ist ja selbst Therapie und Langeweile-Beschäftigung, man müsste was Sinnvolles tun und dann blockt man halt. Oder man hat gerade was, worüber man, man hat gerade nichts, worüber man erzählen könnte und dann blockt man das halt. Dann war mir mal wieder langweilig und dann hab ich halt wieder damit angefangen, aber jetzt dümbelt es irgendwie mehr so. Aber eigentlich bist du Coder?
Möchte gern.
Ich tue nur so.
Ja, aber das ist schon so dein primäres...
Ich klöppel Apps, ja nennen wir es so.
Klöppelst Apps. Aber es ist aber, wie sagt man so schön, for a living.
Ja.
Also du versuchst es zumindest.
Ja, der Kühlschrank ist voll.
Der Kühlschrank ist voll.
Prost.
Welcher Programmierer kann das schon von sich behaupten?
Leider nicht mehr so viele, erschreckenderweise. Ist das dein Eindruck? Naja, wenn du dir die Zahlen so anguckst, gehen wir jetzt mal nur mal von den, weil mittlerweile, ich bin Mac-Entwickler mehr als iOS-Entwickler. Und wenn du jetzt die iOS-Entwickler anguckst, was sind die Zahlen? Man möge mich erschlagen, wenn ich da jetzt um eine 0,3% Stelle falsch liege, aber ich glaube nur 2% aller, die im App-Store sind, können auch wirklich davon leben.
Ja, aber wo kommt die Zahl her?
Die Einnahmen umgerechnet auf die Person, die das Geld bekommt, umgerechnet auf wieviele Apps es gibt, umgerechnet auf Mathematik, nicht mal den.
Aber es war schon letztes oder vorletztes Jahr, wo wir geschrieben haben, dass man eigentlich gut Geld verdient, wenn man halt nicht selber Apps hat, sondern für Firmen arbeitet, die irgendwas im Store haben wollen, da verdient man sein Geld. Ob die dann Geld verdienen, ist mir dann eigentlich Schnuppe oder vielleicht wollen die auch gar nichts verdienen, sind so Werbedinger oder for free, weil es einfach halt so Marketing-Dings und so.
Dann werden wir gleich mal philosophisch. Warum ist das nicht so? Warum meinst du, dass das so ist?
Naja, also noch mal kurz, Parf. Ich hoffe, ich gebe sie richtig wieder. Wenn nicht, möge man das da reintackern in diesen Chat oder was immer das da ist, wenn ich daneben liege.
chat.fribo.node.net/mobile-max. Da könnt ihr auch mit chatten.
Das ist unser Korrektiv, wenn wir Unsinn erzählen.
Aber nur, wenn ihr live hört, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie gerade das runtergeladen habt, dann...
Ja, dann habt ihr Pech gehabt, dann dürft ihr E-Mail schreiben.
Ihr könnt auch was reinschreiben, aber geht nicht darauf an.
Dann können sie die Kommentarfunktion benutzen. E-Mail nicht.
Genau. Also von diesen sechs oder mittlerweile fast sieben Milliarden, die ausgezahlt wurden, sind 5,2, 5,3 Milliarden an 15 Firmen ausgezahlt worden. Und der Rest hat sich dann verteilt auf die anderen, was sind es, 300.000, 400.000 Entwicklungen.
Aber wo kommen denn die Zahlen her?
Die hat Apple veröffentlicht, die Zahlen, wieviel sie ausgezahlt hat.
Aber nicht an wieviel Firmen?
Nein.
Auf jeden Fall nicht an welche, dürfen sie ja nicht.
Nein, aber... Es fragt mich jetzt nicht, wo und eine dieser vielen News-Seiten, die man da täglich so durchblättert. Und dann forscht man halt noch mal ein bisschen nach, bevor man das dann so auf seinem Blog oder wo auch immer oder jetzt hier halt rausposaunt. Wie investigativ, ja. Es gibt da ja auch so Reports, über wie man mit Mobile Geld macht. Da gibt es ja so ganz tolle Firmen, die ihr Geld damit wahrscheinlich genug mehr Geld verdienen, als die meisten Entwickler, die das dann aufdröseln, wie was, wie viel gemacht hat, EA, Games und so weiter und so fort.
Ja gut, das überrascht mich nicht, aber die beschäftigen ja auch viel.
Aber die beantwortet meine Frage nicht, woran das liegt. Woran glaubst du, dass das liegt? Liegt das daran, dass die Ups zu billig sind, dass so viele davon geklaut werden, dass zu wenig davon ursichtlich gefallen sind?
Also wie immer sind glaube ich einfach alle schuld. Apple, wir, die Nutzer, die Entwickler und der Rest heute auch. Also wir haben es damit angefangen, um in den Top 12 aufzutauchen, sind alle billiger geworden und billiger geworden und billiger geworden. Der Benutzer erwartet es mittlerweile, dass es billiger, billiger, billiger und billiger ist. Und dann ist einfach die schiere Masse. Was waren es, 1800 Taschenlampenmaps? Die nichts machen, außer das Licht an dem iPhone anschalten. Dann hatten wir Sinks.
Da kann man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt davon erwarten, dass davon wirklich auch alle 1800 ein ewiges Dasein fristen können.
Die tauchen aber in diese 1 Milliarde oder wie viel es mittlerweile sind, tauchen sie ja auf.
Okay, also das Problem ist das Auffinden, meinst du?
Nicht nur das Auffinden. Es gibt ja eine dieser 99 oder 100 Regeln von Apple. Wir lehnen angeblich eine App ab, wenn es eine Funktion oder eine App ist. 1800 Taschenlampen-Apps.
Die machen ja auch vielleicht alle was anderes.
Nein, die stellen die Taschenlampe an.
Die haben ja auch eine Lichtmuster und so. Also ich hab noch keine gefunden, die wirklich gut ist. Also von daher hätte ich echt noch Bedarf. Also falls jemand wirklich mal den Tipp hat für die ultimative Taschenlampen-App, ich hab noch keine gefunden, die gut ist.
Licht an, Licht aus?
Das ist ja nicht alles. Du willst erstmal leicht die Helligkeit regulieren, du willst die Helligkeit aber auch leicht locken, damit du nicht mal eben...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das technisch möglich ist. Wie technisch möglich? Das ist der Blitz hinten, Licht an oder Licht aus. Die sind doch eh alle kacke.
Nein, nein.
Davon gibt es auch 2000.
Die App sind kacke, aber sie müssten es ja nicht unbedingt sein.
Ja vorne, das ist ja keine Helligkeit, mein Gott. Mittlerweile, was ist das, ab dem Vierer oder Vierer, das kannst du ja hinten die Blitzfunktion benutzen. Und das wird richtig schön hell. Aber da geht nur an und aus.
Also Taschenlampe heißt ja nicht nur maximale Helligkeit. Das ist klar, da macht man es nur an. Aber ich benutze zum Beispiel das iPhone einfach als Buchleselampe. Und, na klar, ich meine, eine bessere Buchleselampe kriegst du nicht. Schön breit gestreut, aber trotzdem in der Helligkeit gut anpassbar.
Marktlücke, du verkaufst das nicht mehr als Taschenlappen-App, sondern als Buchleser-App. Vielleicht werde ich doch noch reichen.
Siehst du mal, das ist alles eine Frage der Kreativität. Ich frage mich immer so bei dieser ganzen Debatte, ob das nicht so ein bisschen so glashalbleer, halb voll ist manchmal.
Ich pack das mal in den Chat, die, die ich benutze. Da kann man auch tatsächlich die Helligkeit regulieren.
absfromouterspace.com Und die regulieren die Helligkeit hinten von dem Blitz?
Aber den Blitz kann man auch damit anschalten.
Den kann man auch damit anschalten. Den kann man auch damit anschalten.
Ach, die benutze ich. Das ist ja die, mit der ich nicht so glücklich bin. Da kommst du immer irgendwie gegen und dann kommt irgendwie dieser Settings-Screen.
Ja, aber da werden wir doch schon bei dem Thema der Wunsch-Dinge für iOS 7, so wie wir später noch kommen, den Touch-Log.
Ja, das können wir noch machen. Machen wir noch ein bisschen Wunsch. Also die, die abkenn ich hier, so viel scheint es doch nicht zu geben. Da kommt man dann irgendwie immer so ein bisschen dagegen, ja, mit dem Finger. Und dann geht es immer gleich in diese komische Settings-Seite oder irgendwelche blöde Werbung poppt auf.
Ich benutze sie eigentlich nur, um eine Taschenlampe zu finden.
Ach so, ist das gemeint.
Flashlight, die ab zum Wiederfinden eurer Taschenlampe.
Dann kann man doch auch so machen, dass man sowieso...
Dann gibt es da auch die Pro-Version von, wo man sich da eine Notiz machen kann, wo man die Ersatzbatterien hat?
Nee, das ist ein In-App-Version.
Flashlight-Finder.
Na gut, aber lass uns noch mal kurz ein bisschen, vielleicht auch noch mal kurz von der Metadiskussion weg, dass wir dich noch mal kurz vollständig vorgestellt haben. Also du machst Abs, der sagt dann noch mal, was du machst.
Und warum dein Leben scheiße ist deswegen.
Nein, mein Leben ist toll. Ich kann in Pajama arbeiten, hab eine Katze auf den Schoßen, wenn ich gerade nicht arbeiten will, dann mach ich was anderes. Okay, das heißt natürlich auch, dass man auch zum Nackt-Podcaster fortbilden lässt.
Das ist ja schon mal ganz gutes Praktikum hier.
Wie kriegt ihr das jetzt aus dem Hirn?
Du hast noch eine Chance, aber der Gäste nicht. Irgendjemand hat jetzt neulich auf die Idee gekommen, Indie-Developer daran zu messen, wie lange sie ohne Unterhose auskommen.
Also ich weiß mit Sicherheit, dass wir hier Damen haben, die hier zuhören, also benehmt euch ein bisschen.
Gut, wir benehm uns ein bisschen, aber nur ein bisschen.
Wie viele Minuten haben wir jetzt gebraucht?
Nicht heute.
Stimmt, heute nicht.
Ihr könnt ja gehen, wir überziehen dann.
Hier gehen Leute vom Bahnhof abholen, oder?
Du schreibst echt ne Menge, das fand ich immer sehr bemerkenswert. Ich wollte dich auch mal fragen, ob das sozusagen ernst gemeint ist und ob du immer nur scheitern als Chance. Und irgendwie, ja, die ist nichts geworden, mach ich die nächste.
Du kennst dich ja mit den Podcasts. Du kennst da jemanden, der macht nämlich ziemlich viele Podcasts.
Wirklich?
Das kenne ich auch mal voll. Solchen Leuten würde ich nicht zugehören.
Aber erzähl doch mal ein bisschen.
Also es hat eigentlich damit angefangen, dass ich früher, ganz früher, da hat Word und alle komischen Textverarbeitungsprogramme, die es gegeben hat, die haben sich immer, was ist das, links oben geöffnet. Das war, als man noch so kleine Bildschirme hatte, kein Problem. Ich hatte dann irgendwann einen größeren Bildschirm. Lange für gespart und ich hatte einen größeren Bildschirm.
Und immerhin links oben.
Und da dachte ich, ja scheiße, du willst doch mal... Entschuldigung, scheiße.
Hier darf man auch Scheiße sagen.
Hier darf man Scheiße sagen.
Hier darfst du noch ganz andere Sachen sagen.
Ich heb's mir auch für später. Hab mir gedacht, kann doch nicht so schwer sein, sich ein Programm zu schreiben, da wo ein Text, ein kleines, süßes Textverarbeitungsprogramm zu schreiben, das einfach immer in der Mitte öffnet. Ich hab mir dann ein schlaues Buch gekauft, hab dieses Buch aufgemacht und hab's nach zwei Minuten wieder zugemacht.
Welches Buch? Aaron Hillegas?
Bekannte Abgründe, ja?
Nee, ist ein gutes Buch.
Das ist so das Buch, was man liest.
Ja, nur da, wo andere ihre Logik und ihr Verständnis haben, da hab ich so die Humas Affen, die sich die Banane über den Kopf sehen. Ich hab's dann wieder zugemacht, es hat mir keine Ruhe gelassen, ich hab's dann wieder aufgemacht und wieder zugemacht. Ich glaub, zwei, drei Jahre später oder so, hatte ich dann das erste süße, kleine Textverarbeitungsprogramm, das sich in der Mitte öffnete. Es war scheiße, aber es öffnete sich in der Mitte. Und so ging das. Ja, der Vorgängerschreiben. War man sogar auch nur auf Deutsch. Ja, und so ging das dann.
Das durfte man auch nur auf Deutsch schreiben sozusagen.
Und irgendwie sonst ein bisschen in dem Ding rumzuhacken und einfach dazu andere Textverarbeitungsprogramme, die nicht so scheiße sind, dazu zu bringen, sich woanders zu öffnen, das war dir nichts?
Nee, auf die Idee bin ich gar nicht gekommen. Also es hat Ewigkeiten gebraucht, bis ich mich an mein erstes Symbolplugin gewagt hab. Das war denke ich immer noch das Beste, was ich jemals geschrieben hab. Aber es ging dann irgendwann weiter. Damals hab ich nebenbei auch noch Webdesign, das Übliche, was man so macht, um ein paar Brötchen zu verdienen, für die Kundenverwaltung gebraucht. Dann hab ich mir das nächste Kleine zusammengesetzt und es hat sich dann immer weiterentwickelt. Also die Apps, die jetzt noch da sind, ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich mittlerweile geschrieben habe im Laufe der Zeit und auch mit Nachfolgern oder so, die sind schon ernst gemeint, also die verdienen auch. Zwei, drei Euro am Tag. Also was wirklich die Miete zahlt, ist Umsatz. Ihr habt euch irgendwann mal drüber totgelacht über die Anleitung, die ich dazu geschrieben hab.
Ja, die war großartig. Also Umsatz hatte ich hier mal erwähnt.
Bist du der mit dem Buch? Ja, ich bin der mit dem Buch.
Ja genau, er ist der mit dem Buch.
Das ist auch schön.
Sehr unterhaltsam, also das war jede Erwähnung wert. Mittlerweile ist es ja auch fertig, also ich hatte das glaube ich mal erwähnt, da war es noch so in so einer wilden Beta und jetzt hast du es irgendwie zu Ende geschrieben. Ja und Umsatz ist so eine Software zum Reinklöppeln von Umsatz. Also für Selbstständige sozusagen der eigene, ja ich muss jetzt glaube ich mal das, kurz mal mein iPhone bendigen, sonst wird Dennis ganz wahnsinnig. Aber die Umsatz-Sofer ist sozusagen dazu da, um mit seinem Steuerberater kompatibel kommunizieren zu können, ohne jetzt gleich komplette Buchhaltung zu machen.
Da hast du uns kein Testexemplar mitgebracht heute.
Ja wie bei allem einfacher, wie bei all meinen Programmen. Ich schreib nur was für mich und damit, dann wird der Kühlschrank damit voll. Ich hab mir die Dinge angeguckt, die es auf dem Markt gab.
Du schreibst Programme für deine eigenen, was du brauchst, deswegen sozusagen... Genau und dann machst du noch ein bisschen oder stellst es ins Store und wenn dann noch Leute kommen, mach mal hier noch ein bisschen, mach mal da noch ein bisschen und dann wachsen die halt so langsam.
Sag ich erstmal nein. Grundsätzlich. Echt? Nein, so nicht, aber das Wichtigste mittlerweile, was ich lernen musste, ist Nein sagen zu können. Einfach Nein sagen zu können. Ich verstehe deinen Wunsch, aber nein. Sonst hat man irgendwann Word. So ein Rippending oben dran.
Du willst kleine easy Apps haben und davon aber ganz viele?
Nö, ich will einfach kleine süße Apps haben und wenn ich irgendjemanden damit leben, ein kleines bisschen und wenn es nur für zwei Minuten erleichtern konnte, dann war es doch schon okay.
Halt dich eigentlich für einen ganz interessanten und auch sehr netten Art und Weise Apps zu entwickeln, wenn man sie erstmal für sich selber macht.
Ja, sonst wenn es keiner kauft, kann man es immer noch selber gebrauchen.
Du hast aber auch keine andere Chance, weil du musst dir eine App machen, die überhaupt erstmal was Sinnvolles tut. Und wenn du nicht der eigene Anwender der App bist, dann wird sie nie etwas Sinnvolles tun.
Du hättest mal den Millionen von Codern da draußen, denen iTunes mit Dreck zu kögeln.
Das Problem ist, da sind ja ganz, ganz, ganz viele dazwischen, die ganz tolle Ideen haben und die auch nur aus der Not heraus oder aus einer grenzgenialen Idee heraus angefangen haben und die jetzt halt zugemüllt werden unter den ganzen vielen Clones.
Na gut, aber so ein bisschen scheint es ja noch zu funktionieren. Und wenn es nur die Methode ist, so viele Programme wie möglich zu schreiben, auf deiner aktuellen Ups-Liste zähle ich was war das jetzt? 13, 14, 15, irgendwie so in der Größenordnung? Update ist du dir denn alle?
Ja, klar. Also da sind schon viele mittlerweile wieder rausgefallen. Natürlich geht es nach, also Umsatz wird richtig ordentlich gepflegt. Einfach da hängen wichtige Dinge für Menschen dran, die ihre Buchhaltung drin haben. Es bezahlt meine Miete und dann geht es einfach noch darum, wo gerade was sinnig ist. Ich muss nicht noch irgendein Button oder sonst was in eine simple, einfache Textverarbeitung reinschreiben, nur um nochmal eine Aktualisierung auszubringen. Ja und dann geht es halt einfach nach, eigentlich geht es auch ein bisschen nach, auf welcher Position ich gerade im App-Store bin.
Du könntest ja uns ja noch mehr. Wie kann man so viel Programme schreiben?
Ich mach's ja auch schon ein paar Jahre.
Und er hat offensichtlich nichts Besseres zu tun. Und auch nichts Besseres gelernt.
Wie viele von uns, die sich in diesem...
Dann hab ich in deinem Blog so ein bisschen verfolgt, dass du aber auch so deine Auseinandersetzung mit Apple beziehungsweise dem App Store hattest. Das ging schon recht lange.
Als es noch keinen App Store gab, und da gab's immer noch so die Download-Section auf der Apple-Webseite. Kennt ihr noch jemand?
Ja, da war ich auch drin.
Oder so der Vorgänger.
Da war ich auch drin.
Also da hab ich's geschafft. Also ich hab mal überlegt, du müsstest eigentlich ins Guinness-Buch der Rekorde kommen oder so der häufigsten Feature Downloads. Das hast du richtig gemerkt. Da warst du dann für einen Monat direkt auf der Startseite. Die haben eine Million Besucher, das war's am Tag gehabt. Und dann kamen die App-Stores, dann hatten die andere Auswahlkriterien und dann setzte dich ja permanent mit den Reviews in einem Review-Team auseinander. Ich glaub, wenn bei mir irgendwo eine App aufkommt, geht da mittlerweile schon die rote Flagge an. Ich bin auch mittlerweile nicht mehr höflich und freundlich, wenn da mal wieder irgendeine komische Ablehnung kam.
Ja, warum denn? Also ich meine, du machst ja nichts böses. Ich meine, hier kann man so Text eingeben und so, das sieht ja nicht gerade systemkritisch aus.
Die haben eine Hand. Ich hab vielleicht die völlig falsche Vorstellung, aber ich stell mir das vor wie so ein Callcenter. Die werden dann zwei Tage lang geschult, haben dann da ihr Handbuch, nachdem sie sich richten müssen. Und hinten an der Wand hängt dann auch so ein großes Plakat, Belohnung für die dümmste Ablehnung von heute oder so was. Wir sind die besten Mitarbeiter des Monats. Natürlich bau ich auch Bockmiss, aber das sind so Kleinigkeiten, da wird dein App abgelehnt, das weil, wenn du ein Sheet eröffnest, also was weiß ich, so ein Open- oder Safe-Dialog, dann funktioniert dieser Fullscreen-Button da oben nicht mehr. Das funktioniert im Keim-App so, das ist nun mal so. Du kriegst dein App deswegen abgelehnt. Und dann diskutierst du da drei Runden lang genug. Und irgendwann schreibst du da nur noch rein, bitte such jemanden, der das schon zwei Tage länger macht. Natürlich hast du auch mal was verbockt. Kommt vor, aber was ich mittlerweile schon für Ablehnungen hatte, liegt auch an der Zahl der Programme, die ich da so hoch lade. Ich hab's aufgegeben.
Und mit iCloud hast du ja auch so nochmal deinen Spezial...
Also liebe Zuhörer, die es nicht mehr hören könnten, ich verstehe euch, ich fühle mit euch. Zwei Dinge zu iCloud. Erstens, die Idee von iCloud ist gut. Ich halte sie besser als die Dropbox. Das hat ja auch einen Grund, warum Dropbox das jetzt mehr oder weniger geklaut hat.
Was meinst du jetzt als Idee, die Idee nicht Files zu haben, sondern...
Die, die wir hier sitzen, die ihr zuhört, wir sind nicht die Zielgruppe von Apple. Apple geht uns andersrum. Wir gehen Apple am Arsch vorbei. Um das mal so zu formulieren, mehr oder minder. Auch nicht aus böser Absicht, sondern es ist einfach so. Wenn ich mich so umgucke, meine Frau, meine Eltern, Bekannte, die tolle Musiker sind, die tolle Grafiker sind oder sonst was. Aber jetzt von Computer oder von ihrem iPad nicht wirklich Ahnung haben. Für die ist die iCloud toll. Oh guck mal, es ist ja auch auf meinem iPad jetzt. Funktioniert bei den iPhone-Handys auch.
Vielleicht könnte die iCloud auch toll sein, wenn sie funktionieren würde. Dann könnte man schon mal drüber nachdenken.
Ich hab halt ein Problem mit der Umsetzung. Und der Politik, der hinten dran, oder der Kommunikationspolitik hinten dran. Wir alle wissen, dass Dinge nicht funktionieren können und zynk ist nach dem Drucken mit der schwierigste, was du machen kannst. Oder gescheit drucken oder so.
Nach dem Drucken?
Nach dem Drucken.
Hast du mal versucht, etwas zu drucken?
Unglaublich.
Ich hab sehr gute Erfahrungen mit dem Drucken gesammelt in meinem Leben.
Ja, aber die Technologie existiert ja schon 40 Jahre. Wenn Zynk erst mal 40 Jahre existiert, geht's vielleicht auch.
Bei mir hat das auch vor 20 Jahren schon ein Problem.
Du lügst.
Nein.
Du verklärst die Zeit.
Nein. Ich hab mit 92 einen Macintosh, zwei CI und einen Laser weitergekauft und das hat, ich habe Apple Pay Return gesagt und es hat genauso gedruckt wie heute. Ich würde sogar sagen, es war damals noch ein bisschen besser. Bisschen.
Ja, und Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Ja, mir ging es auch mehr um das Schreiben, was da hinten dran steckt.
Ich glaube, so geht es gerade iCloud so ein bisschen. Es funktioniert eigentlich irgendwie so, aber ab und zu verdirrt es mal den Faden.
Genau das ist das Problem. Und dann ist die Kacke am Dampfen, weil das ist ein riesengroßes, schwarzes Loch für alle Beteiligten. Und dann geht nichts mehr. Man hätte vielleicht einfach noch mal ein halbes Jahr warten sollen, hätte ein bisschen mehr ausprobieren sollen, hätte es mal langsam rausrollen sollen.
Eine No-New-Features-Work.
Also das halbe Jahr ist da auch schon rum und ich mein, das ist besser geworden. Also es ist so richtig besser geworden.
Ich hab da so ein Gerücht gemacht.
Also jetzt lass mal Core Data außen vor. Ja, das ist ja das, wo wir...
Der Rest funktioniert, glaub ich, in etwa.
Also auch die Kalenderprobleme und die ganzen Dinge werden von Mal zu Mal besser. Die Dokumente funktionieren, 98% aller Fälle funktioniert das einmal frei, nur wenn es da nicht funktioniert, dann...
98% ist aber ein bisschen...
Oder welche andere richtigen Sachen.
98% Bumps sinken über mehrere Geräte, finde ich ja schon grenzgenial. Nee, ich nicht. Also ein einwandfreies Sinken ist genauso wie ein Einhorn und darauf warten...
Sinken ist nochmal eine andere Problematik, aber iCloud ist ja mehr als nur Sinken. iCloud ist ja auch so dieser Key-Value-Store, der funktioniert an sich ganz zuverlässig. Da weiß ich jetzt nicht so viel, was da falsch läuft. Soweit ich weiß, ist das auch mit dem Document-Store eigentlich gar nicht so das Problem.
Also den Key-Value-Store, da hab ich wenig Probleme mit gehabt. Den Document-Store hab ich von Leuten gehört, dass sie Probleme damit hatten. Hab's selber aber nicht benutzt, also da kann ich nicht so viel zu sagen. Aber der Key-Value-Store, der ist eben noch das robusteste da dran. Okay, der kann auch maximal irgendwie im 2-stelligen Kilobit-Bereich groß sein. Also da ist es irgendwie schwer, das kaputt zu machen.
Also ich hab ja ein Gerücht gehört.
So richtig Vögelchen oder wie?
Bisschen, ja.
Bisschen richtig Vögelchen, okay.
Naja, noch nicht so richtig Vögelchen, dass ich wüsste, dass das Vögelchen selber First-Hand-Knowledge hat. Es könnte 2 oder 3 Indirektionen haben, insgesamt.
Mich eingeschlossen.
Aber ich hörte, dass wohl bei Apple sie mehrere Teams an iCloud, an der Lösung der Probleme, mit unterschiedlichen Lösungsansätzen arbeiten lassen.
Die spielen jetzt Wettrennen, oder was?
Und der, wer es hinkriegt, bleibt und die anderen werden gefeuert?
Ja, weiß nicht, ob sie gefeuert werden, aber sagen wir mal, the best system wins. Ist eigentlich ein sehr sportlicher Ansatz und man könnte jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass sie die Ressourcen dafür nicht haben, sowas zu tun, außer vielleicht die Personal-Ressourcen, weil Programmierer kannst du nicht so einkaufen wie Alufräsen.
Naja, das ist ja dieser Irrglaube, je mehr Entwickler, umso besser wird. Das ist eigentlich der Gegenteil.
Ja, das ist ja bei Apple auch nicht so verbreitet, sondern normalerweise arbeiten sie ja immer mit sehr kleinen Teams, nur diesmal haben sie glaube ich echt ein Problem und sie wissen auch, dass wenn jetzt das eine Team keinen Erfolg hat, dass ihnen wirklich die Zeit davonläuft. Sie können sich da nichts mehr erlauben. Sie sind da am Anschlag, weil ja auch so viele andere Sachen davon abhängen, auch ihre eigenen zukünftigen Pfade. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es 10 Teams sind oder so, ich vermute mal, es ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas im Bereich von zwei bis drei, keine Ahnung. Mich überrascht es auf jeden Fall, nicht so was zu hören.
Das war schon alles an News, was du hattest, dass sie zwei Teams haben an dem Problem.
Das ist nicht alles, was ich an News habe, aber das ist alles, was ich an News über diesen Fall habe, ja. Naja, die wohnen ja nicht in Kalifornien, ne? Wir brauchen mehr kalifornische Hörer da in Kalifornien.
Ich glaube, das Grundproblem von iCloud ist, dass sie halt nicht nur den Usern versprechen Just Works, sondern auch den Entwicklern. Dass es Just Works ist und wenn es halt nicht funktioniert, hast du halt überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, es zu debuggen oder irgendwas zu tun oder überhaupt einfach nur auch einen Fehlerfall zu diagnostizieren. Weil du hast halt so ein paar APIs und wenn die nicht tun, dann tun die halt nicht. Fertig.
Also ich sehe das größere Problem, ich hab mich da etwas länger darüber ausgelassen. Der User hat davon keine Ahnung. Ist ja auch okay so. Deswegen hat ja Tim, guck, das gestern auch noch mal so richtig schön herausgehoben ist. Er geht davon aus, dass Menschen ihnen, da hat er eine Pause gemacht, wahrscheinlich wollte er ein Arschwollgeld sagen und hat es dann wieder runtergeschluckt, ihnen eine Menge Geld dafür zahlen, dass sie die Entscheidung treffen. Und dem muss ich zustimmen.
Er hat sich ausgedrückt mit, sie erwarten von uns, dass wir die Entscheidung für sie fällen, was weggelassen wird oder so was.
Und da hat er ja auch recht. Eigentlich mögen wir das ja auch. Bis wir es dann gerade mal nicht mögen. Die haben davon keine Ahnung. Die müssen davon ausgehen, es funktioniert. Wenn es dann nicht funktioniert, dann muss ja der doofe Entwickler schuld sein.
In deinem Fall dann sozusagen du als Entwickler meinst du jetzt.
Bei den anderen Apps geht es ja.
Aber war es nicht so, dass bei dir diverse Apps wegen Syncing überhaupt ewig auch nur in der Warteschleife hingen oder so?
Nein, als die Appstores dann kamen, war die Überlegung, gehe ich überhaupt in die Mac App Store? Gehe ich überhaupt da rein? Gehe ich nicht rein? Weil die Erfahrung aus dem iOS-Store war, ja sorry. Wie viele Legejobs musst du denn noch haben, um das finanzieren zu gönnen? Dann sind die Verkäufe um 80-90% von der Webseite eingebrochen. Na gut, dann hast du deine Apps halt in die App Store gebracht und dann weißt du, ok, du wirst nur gefeatured, wenn du dann auch die Dinge von Apple da mit einbaust, Calleater, iCloud, schieß mich tot. Und wenn du Dinge hast, die auf Mac, iPhone und iPad funktionieren.
Sonst wird man nicht gefeatured.
Also da musst du viel Glück haben. Ja, aus Apple und aus dem Sinne der Nutzer ist es ja richtig. Also hab ich die in den App Store gebracht und hab gedacht, ok, gut, dann fängst du halt nochmal wieder an und machst was für iPad und iPhone. Und machst das gleich richtig mit iCloud. Und dann ging's nicht, und dann ging's nicht, und dann ging's nicht. Dann hab ich das beim ersten App probiert und dann kamen die Beschwerden, und die Beschwerden, und Beschwerden, weil die Daten sind auf einmal von jetzt auf gleich weg. Sie sind wirklich weg. Also ich hab jetzt in dem anderthalb, nee nicht anderthalb, näher, ja was sind sie jetzt? Ein Jahr.
Konzeptmanagement.
Mein iCloud-Code drei-, viermal umgeschrieben, alles Mögliche ausprobiert, und im Moment hab ich's dann jetzt erst nochmal wieder sein gelassen.
Du machst so unglaublich viel mehr auf dem Mac als unter iOS. Das find ich irgendwie interessant, weil so ein Rush gegeben hat auf iOS, es gab diverse Mac-Entwickler, die auch das komplett zurückgelassen haben. Also ich hier so die Truppe, die man diesen Übercaster da zusammengeschnippelt hat, die sind irgendwie komplett ins Golfland.
Ja, wo weißt du, sind die noch da?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Aber sie sind auf jeden Fall auch nicht wieder im Mac-Land. Also wohin auch immer sie gegangen sind, das ist jetzt auch nur so ein Sample da draus, aber das haben wir mal jetzt nicht so häufig anzutreffen, dass Leute sich auf den Mac spezialisieren.
Also erstens, ich mag das lieber als Mac, zweitens ist auch das ein zweites Ding für mich ist dieses iPhone und dieses iPad. Ich kann auf dem Ding nicht produktiv arbeiten. Heute ist mein neuer Blackberry gekommen für unterwegs, weil ich auf dem iPhone nicht tippen kann. Da sind die Prioritäten.
Hier so mit dem Xer-System irgendwie, mit dem neuen OS.
Mit Hardware-Tastatur, ja. Ja, das ist wieder so.
Bluetooth-Tastatur.
Unterwegs, so beim Autofahren.
Was sollst du ja beim Autofahren nicht tippen?
Aber du musst ja wenigstens mal eine Nummer oder so, ne? Kinders macht das nicht zu Hause. Wenn ich alles auf iOS umgestellt hätte und nur noch bei iOS geklöppelt hätte, wäre ich jetzt wahrscheinlich pleite.
Naja, und auf dem Mac hat man auch das Gefühl, die Grillen fingen schon wieder an zu zirpen und man konnte sich da auch gleich schon wieder einen Namen machen, weil sich irgendwie alle so sehr auf iOS konzentriert haben, dass da richtig was weggebrochen ist. Und ich finde auch, es fehlt einfach auch noch so viel gute Software auf dem Mac. Also es ist erstaunlich. Vielleicht liegt das, ich weiß nicht, ist das ja auch so ein API-Problem, weil viele ja sagen, der iOS und die APIs sind viel moderner und lalala.
Auf dem Mac fängt man auch noch 3-4 Jahre zurück.
Also das wären meine, oder nicht Gerüchte, aber meine Wünsche, wie wir die sehen, wären, dass manche der Dinge, die es jetzt für iOS gibt, doch bitte jetzt auch nochmal zurückportiert werden.
Also man merkt schon, dass sie das was, also du hast ja dieses Coco, ist ja quasi in zwei Hälften unterteilt, gewesen, immer klassisch. Das eine nennt sich Foundation. Das ist alles, was du brauchst, um eine Kommando-Zahlen-App zu machen. Und darüber gibt es AppKit. Das ist alles, was du brauchst, um eine GUI-App zu machen. Und das, was AppKit ist, haben sie dann genommen und haben einmal komplett durchmodernisiert und das UIKit genannt. Und das ist das, was die obere Hälfte auf dem iOS ist. Also unten Foundation ist das Gleiche, so ziemlich das Gleiche. Und oben drauf UIKit ist halt so die modernisierte Version von AppKit. Sie sind jetzt langsam dabei, all die schönen Neuerungen wieder zurückzuholen. Table View zum Beispiel.
Und die Foundation auf dem iPhone auch vollständiger zu machen. Also ganz früh hatten wir eine ganze Menge nicht. Und inzwischen kommt es aber alles.
Ja, manche Dinge haben sie nicht mehr drüber genommen. Das ist auch gut so. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es schon so, du merkst, dass das AppKit, also die Mac-Version, halt wirklich auch noch konsequent aus der Next-Welt kommt. Also so ohne größere Kompatibilitätssprünge halt noch Next-Step ist, während UI-Kit wirklich ganze Kompatibilitätssprünge hat. Also so Sachen wie zum Beispiel ein NS-Image kann mehrere Darstellungen haben. Bis hin zu einem schwarz-weiß-Bild oder einem Bild mit nur acht festen Farben oder so. Vielleicht haben sie es schon rausgebaut. Ein UI-Image zum Beispiel ist nur ein Bild. Das hat nicht mehrere Versionen, mehrere Repräsentationen von dem einen Bild, sondern es ist nur ein Bild. Ein NS-Image ist ein Bild mit mehreren Repräsentationen, den du auf verschiedenen Geräten ausgeben kannst. Also solche Dinge. Ich denke, sie werden auch noch einiges zurückholen. Dieses ganze Layer-Zeug. Ich hab Animationen und das dreht sich und bewegt usw. Bei UI-Kit ist das viel natürlicher eingebaut. Das beruht da drauf quasi. Und bei AppKit haben sie angefangen, das so seitlich dran zu flanschen. Und wenn du nicht genau weißt, was du tust, kannst du dir da in den Fuß schießen.
Das fällt schon ein bisschen alt, AppKit.
AppKit ist, wie ich es bereits sagte, eigentlich aus einer Kompatibilitätslinie aus Next-Step.
Was hält sie denn davon ab, einfach UI-Kit jetzt irgendwie auch auf den Mac zu werfen?
Na ja gut, UI-Kit hat natürlich so Sachen. Also zum Beispiel die UI-Table-View ist das Ding, das du auf dem iPhone verwendest, was auch dafür optimiert ist, dass du es mit Touch benutzt. Also so eine NS-Table-View, die hat halt mehrere Spalten. Eine UI-Table-View hat nicht mehrere Spalten, hat halt nur eine Spalte, zum Beispiel.
Das ist, glaube ich, noch gar nicht, behaupte ich jetzt mal. Ich möge falschlegen, da gar nicht Grund, aber Bindings gibt es auf dem iPhone einfach nicht.
Bindings gibt es nicht, vielleicht weil sie eingesehen haben, dass die Idee auch nur so mitteltoll war. Obwohl ich mir immer noch...
Kurz zur Erklärung, Bindings.
Bindings ist... Ohje, jetzt wird's schwierig. Du hast üblicherweise bei so einer UI-Applikation ein Datenmodell, also Klassen, die irgendwelche Daten halten. Und du hast dann Views, die anzeigen, was passiert, und du hast einen Controller, der beides miteinander verbindet. Und üblicherweise musst du in dem Controller sogenannten Glue-Code schreiben, also Code, der aus dem Datenmodell Zeug holt, um es an den View weiterzureichen. Und wenn im View jemand an den Schieberegler zieht, dann entstehen Events und Actions, die du durch deinen Controller wieder zurück ins Datenmodell füttern musst. Und Bindings ist der eigentlich auch ganz gelungene Versuch, diesen Glue-Code wegzumachen. Ich finde Bindings großartig. Indem man die View direkt ans Datenmodell binden kann. Das ist eine großartige Technologie, ja, auf der einen Seite, aber sie ist nicht ohne Probleme.
Vor allen Dingen ist sie ressourcerungrig. Das kann sie auf einem kleinen iPhone mit der Batterie einfach nicht bringen.
Aber das heißt für dich als Programmierer, du änderst deine Daten und deine Darstellung ändert sich. Oder du erlaubst, dass sich die Darstellung ändert und deine Daten ändern sich?
Ja, bzw. du hast eine View, wo du jetzt mal blöd gesprochen als Beispiel, du hast drei Schieberegler und ein Feld, was eine Zahl anzeigt. Und du bindest die alle an den gleichen Daten. Und wenn der User an einem Regler zieht, dann regen sich die anderen Regler mit. Und das Feld, wo die Zahl drin steht, bewegt sich auch, ohne dass du nur eine Zeile Code schreiben musst.
Ja, aber dafür muss man im Interface-Bild, auch wenn das nicht mehr so heißt, weil das alles integriert in Xcode, muss man irgendwelche Connections ziehen oder die Einträge da machen. Und wenn man das dann wieder in sein GIT eincheckt, hast du alles in komischen irgendwie P-List-Files und blickst später nicht mehr durch. Also das hat auch wieder Nachteile, weil du nämlich ganz viele Bindings hast, blickst du irgendwann nicht mehr durch.
Ich sag ja auch nicht, das ist das beste seit geschnitten Brot.
Es ist auch nicht wirklich neu. Also das hab ich schon vor über zehn Jahren in Peltika gehabt, diese Funktion.
Es ist auch in Mac OS nicht neu. Das ist, glaub ich, mit 10.3 gekommen oder so.
Auch circa zehn Jahre alt, oder?
Es hat halt so seine Edge-Cases. Also bindings zusammen mit Table-Views oder mit Outline-Views, dann wird's dann in der Regel unangenehm, sehr unangenehm.
Also kurz gesagt, es gibt noch auch genug Unterschiede zwischen den Plattformen, die sich auch eben in den Untiefen der API-Gestaltung niederschlagen. Und so eine Unification ist jetzt mal nicht so eben mit einem Schnipser geboren.
Ja, ist nicht so schlimm wie Windows NT und Windows 95, aber...
Ich hab auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck, es gibt nicht so eine vorherrschende Meinung, ja genau darauf muss es jetzt hinauslaufen und wann ist Apple denn endlich genau damit fertig? Sondern es ist eigentlich nur ein bisschen offen, welche konkrete Mischung es geben wird.
Die viel entscheidende Frage ist ja, ich glaube, die sind ja von ihrem iPad selber überrannt worden.
Zumindest sind sie gut damit beschäftigt, den zu handeln.
Und dann ist jetzt die Frage, was passiert denn jetzt mit diesen komischen alten, buddischen Dingen, mit Tastatur und schwer und groß, auf die man nicht rumtatschen kann, die immer noch kein Internet drin haben.
Wo die immer noch irgendwelche Software drauf installieren.
Vielleicht kann man ja demnächst drauf rumtatschen.
Das glaube ich nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall noch cash cow genug, als dass es sich für sie lohnt.
Sie wachsen ja noch im Markt.
Die denken ja nicht von hier bis jetzt, sondern von hier bis in die nächsten 5-10 Jahre. Das musst du auch erst mal abschätzen können.
Also zwei Sachen dafür. Das eine, was ich ja schon lange gesagt habe, ist Mausen und Touchen verträgt sich nicht. Und wer versucht, das ins gleiche Betriebssystem einzubauen, der scheitert. Siehe Windows 8, siehe Ubuntu.
Ach, Ubuntu hat das auch probiert?
Naja, dieser Unity Desktop, was ist denn das?
Da kann man touchen?
Da sollte man touchen können.
Ja, im Prinzip ist es, weil es die Hardware nicht gibt. Beziehungsweise wenn es sie gibt, dann benutzt du sie nicht unter Ubuntu oder so. Aber im Großen und Ganzen lebt das Ganze davon, dass es eigentlich die Idee hat, ich will das jetzt vereinheitlich.
Sie wollten einfach ein bisschen mehr Gefühl in ihr Betriebssystem bringen, ist doch auch schon mal was.
Vielleicht auch das, schaut ihr diesen Jimmy, wie hieß er an? Na egal, wir haben doch dieses Video gesehen, wo er dieses Ubuntu-Phone darstellt, das war doch auch mit viel Gefühl. Ne, Jimmy, wie heißt er? Mark Shuttelworth, genau. Was war das zweite? Ach so. Auf der Mia. Also ich denke, sie werden das halt auch schrittweise vereinheitlichen. Also diese super Sache mit 10.8, dass das Apple mal eben das Kalender-Framework rausgeworfen hat. Und das Event-Framework von iOS da eingebaut hat, was im Prinzip das Gleiche tut. Die Objekte und Klassen sind irgendwie zu 90% die gleichen. Aber das kannst du halt nicht einfach mal so eben umändern. Du darfst halt deine App dann doch so ein bisschen neu schreiben. Ja, es zeigt, sie sind dabei das zu vereinheitlichen.
Wird jetzt alles besser?
Bestimmt. Jetzt sind wir im Prinzip schon, wenn wir jetzt sozusagen smooth weitermachen wollen. In zwei Wochen ist WWDC. Hier ein neues Kapitel, die Beschonung. In zwei Wochen ist World Wide Developers Konferenz. Wir haben den glücklichen Umstand, dass wir in zwei Wochen dann halt wieder senden. Und da ist dann die Keynote gerade gelaufen. Das war auch schon mal anders. Wobei, ob das so ein Vorteil ist, das weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau. Manchmal hilft es ja auch, noch eine Woche darüber nachdenken zu können.
Zumindest gibt es da mal was Neues, ne? Aber machen wir diesmal die Jubelschwaben und die Münchner können dann...
Es ist ja so, dass jetzt seit der letzten Personalumstellung sich gerade in diesem Bereich ja was Signifikantes ergeben hat, nämlich dass der Craig Federighi dir vorher für US 10 zuständig war, jetzt auch der Head of iOS ist.
Weil Scott Forster nicht mehr da ist.
Weil Scott Forster gekickt wurde und das ganze Zuständigkeitsgedöns halt einmal da um Quark geschoben wurde. Und Mr. Ive ist halt für die Optik und den Feel wahrscheinlich auch zuständig. Ich schätze mal, das dürften sehr weitreichende Kompetenzen sein, so nach dem Motto, was der nicht... Ich hab so den Eindruck, Johnny Ive ist jetzt so ein bisschen... Gott. Er hat jetzt die Rolle von Steve Jobs übernommen im Sinne von, an ihm geht kein Produkt vorbei.
Lass uns mal darüber spekulieren, was das für die Funktionen ausmacht. Glaubst du, dass er jemand ist, der Funktionen opfert?
Wenn es schick aussieht. Bevor wir dazu kommen, lass uns erst noch mal kurz bei diesem OS X iOS-Verhältnis bleiben. Also denkt ihr, dass das jetzt sozusagen unter einer Person steht? Dass es hilfreich ist für diese Zusammenführung? Und ist die Zusammenführung hilfreich? Haben wir da jetzt eigentlich mehr Angst davor, dass das passiert?
Ja, kann nur besser werden.
Weil wenn du dir anguckst, wenn zu viele Köche in diesem Brei rumrühren, dann kommt halt Microsoft bei raus. Ich meine, ich bin ganz, ja, aber das ist wieder so immer, denn wenn du sozusagen jemanden hast, der das in die Hand nimmt, dann gefällt es hinterher nicht jedem. Das polarisiert dann auch. Aber den Leuten, denen es gefällt, gefällt es dann auch richtig gut. Das ist halt wie immer so. Das ist dann nicht so diese Mischie-Maschi, wo jeder irgendwie meint, naja, es ist ein Kompromiss, es ist eigentlich nicht schön, aber naja, gut. Es werden diverse Leute hassen. Die Leute werden ihr künstliches Leder vermissen. Da gibt es auch Leute, die Jonathan Ive zum Mond wünschen werden. Aber es gibt auch andere Leute, die einfach sagen, nee, jetzt hattet Hand und Fuß, jetzt passt es zueinander. Also es wird ganz deutlich polarisieren. More haters, more lovers. Aber die Leute, die es lieben, werden es dann auch richtig mögen. Nicht so diesen Mischie-Maschi, ja, wir versuchen es allen Leuten recht zu machen.
Also ich glaube, rein technisch ist das auf jeden Fall ein No. Keine Frage. Beide Betriebssysteme haben was davon, vom anderen die guten Sachen zu übernehmen. So vom Usability-Standpunkt. Ich glaube, dass Tim Cook auch ganz froh ist, dass er so jemanden hat wie Johnny Ive, dem er zutraut zu sagen, das ist richtig und das ist falsch. Und er macht das dann schon. Weil ich glaube, dass Tim Cook überhaupt nicht in der Lage wäre zu sagen, Leute, das ist doch Dreck, mach das anders.
Es gibt wieder überhaupt mal eine Figur, an der man es aufhängen kann. Das war ja früher mit Steve auch so. Da hat man eben gesagt, okay, das ist jetzt nicht meine Sicht, aber das hat Steve jetzt entschieden. Und das hat auch innerhalb von Apple, war das dann auch so gesetzt. Und ich glaube, wenn jemand da eine Chance hat, in dem Laden wieder so eine Stellung zu erzielen, was Design-Fragen oder was Fragen angeht, irgendwas zu machen, ist das Johnny Ive.
Ja, aber mein Problem bei dem Ganzen ist, das ist jetzt nur von dem, was man jetzt so ein bisschen aus YouTube und den Werbevideos und den Interviews und den Dingen kennt, ist überhaupt nicht seine Persönlichkeit. Der will ja nur tolle Dinge abliefern. Der will doch gar nicht entscheiden. Also zumindest nicht auf der Ebene.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen.
Das würde ich auch nicht so sagen.
Also ich meine, er ist schon entscheidungsfreudig.
Sonst wären die Produkte ja nicht so.
Die ganze Hardware ist ja nun wirklich legendär. Ich meine, das ist ja...
Ja, aber er hat es nicht entschieden. Er hat die Dinge auf 100 verschiedene Dinge gebaut. Und dann hat gut Steve gesagt, jo, nö, das ist anders.
Das glaub ich nämlich gar nicht mal.
Das wäre schön für uns alle.
Das kann ich nicht belegen, aber ich glaube, die beiden waren schon so ein bisschen so... so eine kleine Räuberbande. Und die haben da irgendwie in etwa denselben Ansatz gehabt. Oder zumindest haben sie irgendwie so einen Film gehabt. Aber das ist alles Spekulation. Tatsache ist, dass er jetzt den Hut auf hat. Und ich frage mich halt, was ist. Das ist übrigens das zweite Gerücht, was ich gehört habe. Dass die Änderungen in iOS 7 signifikant sind. Und zwar nicht nur, was so die Verscheinungsform betrifft, sondern auch andere Hut.
Oh, sie bringen ihren Networking-Stack in Ordnung?
Das...
Entschuldigung, ich jetzt gerade noch mal so ein bisschen aufwache.
Ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet. Nur, dass es im Multitasking-Bereich auf jeden Fall Auswirkungen hat. Das sind nur so Brotkrummen, die mir hier zugeworfen werden. Ja, und das mit dem Fullscreen-Modus bei US-10 soll ja auch besser werden.
Ja, so schlechter kann es nicht werden.
Mit 10,9 dann, ja?
Man kann im Fullscreen auch mal so noch ein extra Fenster aufnehmen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was kommt. Ich weiß nur, dass da was ist.
Also meine Meinung zum Fullscreen-Modus ist ja inzwischen, es ist sowieso ein MacBook Air Feature.
Ja, derzeit, aber es ist halt irgendwie alle Leute, die halt einen zweiten Bildschirm angeschlossen haben.
Ja, schon, aber dafür ist es das nicht. Ja, aber dafür ist es das nicht, das Feature.
Ich hab hier drei Bildschirme angeschlossen.
Dafür hast du den grünen Button.
Also ich glaub nicht an diese These, dass Apple kein Interesse mehr an Pro-Usern hat. Das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist meine Hoffnung für das Ganze. Ist mir egal, ob da jetzt alles in schwarz-weiß ist oder keine Schatten oder weniger Schatten oder noch mehr Schatten. Ich hoffe, dass die da jetzt gerade mal innehalten und in sich gehen und feststellen, dass sie doch nicht nur Spielzeuge verkaufen, sondern Hardware und gescheite Dinge, um kreativ zu sein.
Die wissen auch, dass diese Zielgruppe für sie wichtig ist. Und zwar nicht zahlenmäßig im Sinne von Geld, aber das ist das, womit sie diesen ganzen Scheiß aufgebaut haben, der immer noch da ist. Und wenn die sich von ihnen abkehrt, dann redet keiner an, Mel Göbel. Dann haben sie dann ein Problem, was sie nicht haben wollen. So. Abgesehen davon, dass es auch durchaus ein Markt ist, wo Geld verdient wird. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht iPhone-Geld, aber es ist immer noch genug Geld, um eine der größeren Unternehmen auf diesem Planeten zu sein.
Dann sollen sie mal die Z-Chall als Standard-Chall machen. Dann nehmen sie die Projuse wieder ernst.
Kannst du selber setzen. Wir wünschen uns nur ein Follower zu deinem Kommentar mit dem grünen Knopf. Das ist aber der, den ich nie anklicke, weil ich immer keinen Bock habe, mich jedes Matierstelle aufzuregen, dass er nicht das tut, was man erwartet.
Was erwartest du denn?
Ich erwarte, dass das Fenster so groß macht, wie es irgendeinem geht. Und das ist einfach nicht der Fall.
Dann hast du den grünen Knopf nicht verstanden.
Ja, ich gebe frei mit dir zu. Vor 10 Jahren hab ich Windows benutzt. So ist es aber auch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Da gibt's ein Scheiß Ding, was das Fenster groß macht.
Weil die Leute nicht wussten wofür der da ist.
Wann hat denn der letzte Mal funktioniert? Das ist das Option-Grüne Knopf, was du meinst.
Ach, Option-Grüne Knopf macht das Fenster so richtig?
Sollte. Das Ding ist, dass Apple selber irgendwie mit Mac OS 10, das ist so eine der Sachen, die sie dann nicht innerhalb von ein paar Releases gefixt bekommen haben, als Mac OS noch Mac OS war.
Option-Grüne Knopf macht das Ding bloß wieder lang. Oder breit, aber nicht lang und breit.
Ja, weil die App oder das Framework oder beide zusammen in Konspiration nicht mehr das Richtige tun, TM, aber so war es mal.
Und so sollte es auch sein. Aber ich finde...
Wann war noch der lila Button?
Der lila Button war Single Window. Es gab mal bei 10.0, also in dieser Prä-Beta-VC-Developer-Privio DP1 oder so.
DP2 war es glaube ich.
DP2, da gab es so einen lila Button. Den haben sie dann ganz schnell wieder kassiert, weil alle so huuuuh. Ich fand die Idee an sich ganz gut und im Prinzip, was sie da gezeigt haben, ist IOS. Ja, wir wollen nur noch eine ab auf dem Bildschirm haben im Prinzip. Aber sie haben dann irgendwie auch eingesehen, dass es ein bisschen zu früh war.
War das nicht so, dass das dann alle anderen Fans da irgendwie ins Dock versackt sind? Irgendwie so, dass das war für sie.
Ja, genau, weil sie das so geil fanden, diesen Effekt und immer schön Shift drücken und langsam. Grüner Button, also Grüner Button, gerade bei Webseiten finde ich den grünen Button mit dieser Definition, mach es so groß, wie es maximal so groß wie er sein muss. Genau richtig. Weil eine Webseite hat eine berechenbare Breite.
Ja, da kann ich noch mit leben.
Und es gibt aber auch viele andere Apps, wo das so ist. Es gibt einfach einen Content und der hat einfach eine Boundary. Und warum soll das Fenster unnötig größer sein als der Content? Es ist gut, dass es so einen Knopf gibt.
Und wenn da so floating text ist, der ewig breit werden würde?
Dann ist es halt dann so groß, wie der Bildschirm es hergibt in dem Moment, dann ist das eben so. Aber es muss halt nicht unbedingt immer so sein. Und der Fullscreen-Modus, der ist dann halt auch wirklich Fullscreen, aber dann eben nicht so Windows Fullscreenen macht das Fenster groß, sondern take the fucking Fullscreen.
Wenn im Fullscreen-Modus, dann behalte doch bitte die Breite bei, die ich vorher da hatte. Also man kann das umschalten, aber gerade bei so einem Schreibprogramm will ich doch nicht so ein Ding, oder ich will da im Browser nicht so ein Ding haben.
Manchmal...
Auf so einem 27er Bildschirm?
Nicht im Browser, nee.
Deswegen sag ich ja, es ist ein MacBook Air Feature. Ja. Sie können es auf allen anderen Rechnern einfach ausblenden.
Also ich hab nicht generell... Ich finde generell den Fullscreen-Modus eine gute Idee. Da sind schon ein paar wirklich gute Sachen drin. Allein schon dadurch, dass dadurch so ein weiterer Screen entsteht und du schnell dann hin und her schalten kannst. Du guckst einen Film, den willst du natürlich Fullscreen haben, und dann machst du mal eben hier so Control-Cursor links und buff bist irgendwie in deinem Browser, sonst wie alle anderen Programme Kontext, zack, Control rechts und schwuppst bist du wieder in deinem Fullscreen-Modus, ohne dass sich da irgendwas beendet, sondern es liegt dann einfach daneben. Das ist schon nicht falsch gedacht, aber es ist natürlich bekloppt, alles andere auszudimmen, wenn du noch mehr Bildschirme hast und so weiter.
Das ist ein Chat-Grün, das Shift-Grüner-Knopf hab ich probiert, ein Shift-Grüner-Knopf macht großes Fenster.
Was sagte ich, Option?
Das täten wir ohne unseren Chat.
Ah, Shift war das.
Shift-Grüner-Knopf.
In Colloquy geht es auch mit Option. Ich hatte immer Option im Kopf. Vielleicht machen es manche Programme falsch.
Irgendwelche Tasten mit Grün-Knopf.
Modifier are doing it.
Kann man einfach mal gucken, was passiert, wenn man alle gleichzeitig drückt.
Worldwide Developers-Konferenz findet statt. Und zwei neue Betriebszimmer werden vorgestellt.
Was kommt noch? Wissen wir schon irgendwas über 10.9? Das wird noch nicht vorgestellt.
Wissen wir, dass es vorgestellt wird?
Das ist nach hinten gepusht. Im Moment arbeiten wieder alle.
Ich dachte, er hat nur gesagt, dass es ein Keynote geben wird.
Nein, er hat auch gesagt, dass sie einen Ausblick geben werden auf die beiden neuen UO-Buskifzimmer. Also es ist viel. Explizit.
Wer hält die Keynote er selber?
Na, er wird kurz Guten Tag sagen und yeah.
Und dann treiben sie sich wieder die Fernbedienungen in die Hand.
Dann sagt er die Talk-Butter-Can.
Und die blonden Berliner wollten nicht jubeln.
Er erzählt erst, dass der neue Berliner Apple Store aufgemacht wird. Dann sagt er die Quartalszahlen.
Amazing.
Und dann holt er irgendjemand auf die Bühne für das interessante Zeug.
Meinst du, dass sie ein Video zeigen von diesem scheiß Apple Store Eröffnung?
Ja natürlich, wenn sie es ansprechen, werden sie ein Video zeigen.
Mit den ganzen eingeschlaftenen Fressen davor? Die haben das wahrscheinlich einen Tag vorher noch mal mit Jubelpersern gedreht.
Wenn sie in der Lage waren, das irgendwie aus einem guten Blickwinkel so zu filmen, dass wirklich das nach Jubelage aussieht, dann würde ich sagen...
Ist denn der Apple Store besonders groß, auch international verglichen?
Das ist halt nicht so ein Gammel-Store in irgendeiner dusseligen Mall.
Vom Verkaufsraum her gibt es auch andere und bestimmt auch welche, die mehr Verkaufsfläche haben, aber so genau kann ich es dir nicht sagen. Aber die gesamte Installation, weil da sind ja noch viele Schulungsbereiche und so weiter, Workshop und Eventraum, also ich kenne überhaupt nur einen einzigen Apple Store, der was Vergleichbares hatte und das war der in der Regent Street in London. Und keine Ahnung, wie es in den USA aussieht, ob es da einen großen Store gibt, der sowas hat. Also wo richtig so eine Bühne und sowas ist, das ist schon außergewöhnlich.
Ja, ich finde, es geht ja mehr um Prestige oder wie das immer das richtige Wort ist. Da spielt er ja schon mit London auf einer Regent Street. Nicht mit Paris, aber mit London spielt er ja.
Ich finde den Londoner schon noch mal fett. Der Hamburger ist ähnlich, wie der in London. Da ist halt so ein britisches Londoner Haushalt. Mit dem ganzen royalen Trara und Treppen in der Mitte. Der hat ja keine Glastreppe, die haben wir ja kaputt gemacht.
Ich finde den Berliner Store jetzt auch noch nicht so spannend. Außer diesem Minilogus da und kaum zu erkennen, der große Apfel oben fehlt irgendwie. Das finde ich aber gerade ziemlich unscheinbar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es nicht durften oder nicht wollten.
Wahrscheinlich durften sie nicht.
Ich glaube, sie wollten auch nicht.
Ich hätte da ein Durchsichtding hingemacht aus Glas.
Die halten sich bei anderen denkmal geschützten Häusern auch sehr zurück.
Ich finde das gerade stilvoll, dass sie nur so zwei kleine Äpfel hingemacht haben. Ansonsten steht das Haus für sich. Und es steht verdammt gut für sich, finde ich. Also sie haben es ja wahrscheinlich die Fassade auch irgendwie geleckt und geschleckt und nochmal gebleicht. Und das ist ja, weiß ich nicht...
Ich bin ja kudamlang gebrettet mit meinem Motorrad, und ich habe echt guten Blick und so, aber ich bin vorbeigefahren.
Versuch es mal nicht im fünften, sondern nur im vierten Gang.
Und in der richtigen Richtung.
Ja, sonst noch irgendwelche Hoffnung und Einschätzungen?
Da habe ich gerade irgendwo was gelesen, was ich unterstütze. C9 könnte mal Airplay auf App-Basis einführen.
Oh ja, die könnten so viel.
Ja, das ist das AV-Framework, was das ja eigentlich kann. Wo man ja, also zumindest unter iOS, muss ja nicht viel machen und dann tut das einfach.
Wie lange machen sie jetzt diese Spiele mit diesem Airplay schon? Das ist ja schon ein paar Jahre her. Die könnten endlich mal ihre scheiß Matrix voll machen, dass man alles auf allem darstellen kann.
Du willst Airplay rechts unten?
Nein. Ich will einfach nur in jeden Rechner hinein streamen. In jeden Rechner hinein, aus jedem Rechner hinaus, auf jedes iPad rein und wieder raus, auf jedes iPhone rein und raus und auf jedes Apple TV rein und raus.
Global als auch von jeder ab.
Und zwar ohne die DRM-Kack. Ich bin oft dort, wo du mit deinen Kids mal drauf reingefallen hast, bin ich am Wochenende auch reingefallen.
Mit Ausleihen und dann hier falscher Beamer und geht auch weg.
Genau.
Ja, aber ich kenne auch, das ist das Problem. Das war das erste, was ich auch gedacht habe. Das hat einen Grund. Nicht, dass sie das nicht machen wollen, sondern das sind scheißrechtliche Gründe.
Ja, dann sollen sie die überwinden. Die sind Apple.
Na gut, ich meine...
Sie haben keine Teile oder Schirme.
Hollywood ist vor allem deshalb nicht so freundlich, weil sie mittlerweile gelernt...
Hollywood gehört Apple.
Nein, nein, nein, sie gehören denen noch gar nicht. Die wollen auch nicht Apple gehören, sondern die wollen ihren eigenen Scheiß machen. Sie haben mittlerweile gelernt, dass Apple der Laden ist, der sie richtig gefickt bekommt, wenn sie nicht aufpassen.
Ja, die haben Ringe. Sorry, die haben aber Recht.
Ja, natürlich haben sie Recht. Die werden sie auch irgendwann ficken. Es ist halt nur eine Frage der Zeit. Und sie versuchen halt noch irgendwie die Sache rauszuzögern.
Du meinst, Apple mag gerne Vorspiel?
Ja, weiß ich auch nicht, ob das unbedingt an Apple liegt. Aber das ist halt, ich bin mir sicher, die glauben, dass sie irgendwie noch davonkommen könnten. Aber so wie Apple da Schritt für Schritt voranmarschiert, die pirschen sich einfach, dass Apple vorbeigeht.
Die denken, sie wären noch die großen Platzhirsche und dieses Apple hört irgendwann mal auf, ihnen ans Bein zu pinkeln.
Sie sind die Platzhirsche. Und Apple, das ist so die große Herde von Löwen und Koyoten, die sich so langsam um sie herum anschleift.
der eine Schäferhund, der die ganze Schafherde da im Griff hat.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Wobei die Schafe halt immer wissen, dass der Schäferhund da ist. Aber so diese Raubkatzen, die halten sich halt dann doch eher diskret zurück und versuchen auch nicht so sehr aufzufallen. Ihr habt wahrscheinlich dieses Interview noch nicht gesehen mit Tim Cook, wo sie versucht haben, so ein bisschen zu reden zu stellen. Es war natürlich klar, dass er keine Antwort gibt, aber es war auch bezeichnend, was er so für Pausen gemacht hat. Ja, die Pausen waren. Ja, so mit und dann auch explizit gesagt hat, ihr wisst, dass ich da jetzt nicht drauf antworten möchte. Und ich möchte auch hier niemanden irgendwelche Ideen geben und so weiter. Gerade als es um dieses Fernsehding ging, hat er so richtig nochmal nachgedacht. Weil sie wollten natürlich wissen, so was ist dann die Strategie. Und das Maximum, was sie aus dem rausbekommen hat, war halt so was wie, dass halt irgendein Bereich für sie interessant wäre oder besonders interessant oder incredible interesting oder keine Ahnung oder awesome oder was auch immer. Grad mal wieder der Übertreibungsbegriff des Tages war. Und natürlich haben sie da was am Kochen. Natürlich ist das alles der Versuch. Und natürlich hassen sie auch dieses DRM, weil das bringt ihnen gar nichts. Aber sie müssen halt, ne?
Ja, aber Apple hat auch kein Interesse daran, das glaube ich ihnen sogar, hat kein Interesse daran, diese 40, 50 Jahre alte Spiel, was diese Fernsehindustrie da hat, mitzuspielen oder da einfach nur als neuester Player mit auf den Plan zu treten. Wenn, dann machen sie das doch irgendwie anders.
Das ist ja doch eigentlich seit 10 Jahren überholt. Oder mindestens 20 Jahre.
Ja, klar ist es das, aber es befindet sich eben noch in ihrem Clown und die Fernsehindustrie findet es an sich ganz toll, noch den Chef machen zu können.
Ja, du weißt doch, wie der Spruch geht. It's hard to understand something, if the not understanding depends on your paycheck. Beziehungsweise andersrum, your paycheck depends on not understanding it.
Aber jetzt nur mal zur deren Verteidigung, ich kann sie verstehen.
Wenn jetzt? Ja, ja, verstehen tu ich dich auch, aber ich bin trotzdem nicht auf ihrer Seite.
Das muss man aber auch erstmal können.
Ja, aber irgendwie, also ich setz da eher so auf den Gepard, der so aus dem Busch rausschießt und mit 113 Stundenkilometern dann sich irgendwie so auf seinen Kopf verschloss.
Und dann das Trankentier mal erledigt.
Aber der Gepard weiß auch, er kann nicht schnell laufen. Wenn er nämlich zu lange läuft, dann ist er erschöpft.
Er kann schnell laufen, aber nicht lange.
Dann ist es halt schlecht und die Herde läuft dann erstmal weg und dann dauert es wieder eine Weile.
Und keine Angst, dass da irgendjemand, mit dem wir jetzt noch gar nicht gerechnet haben oder andersrum. Meine Befürchtung ist ja, also von den vielen üblen Dingen, die Hollywood zustoßen könnte, fände ich ja, auch wenn ich verstehe, dass sie es nicht wollen, Apple doch die beste, aus meiner Sicht. Ich habe ja die Befürchtung, dass die doof wie sie sind, um eben nicht von Apple gerissen zu werden, um aber in dem Bild zu bleiben, irgendjemand anders in die Arme laufen.
Naja, aber bestimmt nicht Microsoft, das haben wir ja schon hinter sich.
Die kaufen es glatt aus versehen.
Hat Google schon mal irgendein Medienangebot hinbekommen, was von Kunden akzeptiert wurde in den letzten fünf Jahren?
Darum geht es ja gar nicht. Das ist genau mein Problem.
Aber ich meinte jetzt Medienangebot im Sinne von mit klassischen Medien.
Mir geht es gar nicht doch mal, was die hinbekommen haben, sondern dass die Deppen halt denken, hauptsache nicht Apple.
Also schmeißen wir uns irgendeinem anderen Idioten an den Hals.
Genau.
Am besten Microsoft. Wie der Chat auch schon sagt, TV, Television, Kinect, Content on the Man und Fernsehen.
Das Video war großartig.
Das muss man dann noch mal raussuchen.
Das Video war wirklich großartig.
Habt ihr dieses Video gerade mal zur Hand?
Ich muss mal gucken, ich hab's selber getwittert.
Nee, ich hab's nicht getwittert, ich hab's verabdottnettet.
Ich weiß.
Überhaupt da nimmst du noch hin.
Oh, da haben wir ja lange nichts von gehört.
Ja, aber ich hab einen guten Vorwand.
Ich hab auch jedes Mal guten Vorwand.
Ah, hier ist das Video.
Da passiert innerhalb von 14 Tagen jedenfalls deutlich mehr als bei fucking Apple.
Mach mal eine Stufe größer. TV experience.
Das hat ja schon einen gewissen Raum.
Der wiederholt sich häufiger als ich.
Sports, sports, sports.
Television, television.
Entirely new Call of Duty for the next generation.
Ja, David, da musst du jetzt was draus machen.
Xbox Go Home.
Echt? Der ist ja nicht Xbox One.
Was meinen sie denn damit mit Xbox Go Home?
Ja, schmeißt eure Xboxen weg, kauft euch Xbox One.
Ja, sowas schafft auch nur Microsoft.
Xbox ist old and busted.
Die Meister der verpeilten Kino, das ist wirklich echt unfassbar. Aber das geht irgendwie.
Aber die Dinger von außen sind doch wie Blöde.
Aber so Konsolen sind doch immer noch voll der Renner, oder nicht?
Ja, Microsoft macht mit jeder Konsole weniger Verlust.
Und nicht in 50 Stunden in der Gewinnzone?
Ach, Xbox Go Home ist die Sprachsteuerung, wenn man hier gerade korrigiert. Ah, was für ein scheiß Name. Oh man, das heißt, das ist Siri, ja? Na super. Wieder ein Gerät, mit dem man reden kann. Roman um ihr und Domo's.
Xbox um ihn und Domo.
Na gut, wir waren aber eigentlich bei der www.dubdc. Und was wir alles für Geschenke kriegen nächste Woche. Ich hol noch mal ein Bierchen. Will noch jemand ein Getränk?
Ja, ich hätte gerne auch ein Bierchen.
Hast du sowas, was der Roddy haben will?
Ja, nur das.
Dann hätte ich gerne auch noch sowas.
Viermal, alles klar.
Wo wir gerade bei solchen Sachen sind, gibt's denn hier Geschenke? Ihr hattet letzte Woche Geschenke. Habt ihr mir aber davon was übrig gelassen? Kollegen Schweine. Ich lese mal vor.
Pack mal aus und lese mal vor.
Mobile-Macs Tim Prittlauf. Da ist eine Diskette drin. Nein. Das fühlt sich fast so an. Könnte auch ein Tennisschläger sein.
Oh, ich umschlege für jeden Einzelnen. Gib mal meinen bitte.
Anleitung für Tim. Dies ist nicht unterstrichen für NSFW. Nicht dem Holgi in die Hand drücken. Schön ordentlich für die nächste Mobile-Macs Sendung bereitlegen. Nicht verschlampen.
Hat er schon mal geschafft.
Also, haben wir das gehört, Herr Prittlauf?
Hat er ja geschafft.
Also wenn es nicht schon drei Sendungen liegt, dann hat er es geschafft.
Andy Bumzack, Return Crew, vielen lieben Dank für euer immerwährendes Engagement, mir immer wieder einen auf meine persönlichen Interessen zugeschnittenen Podcast zu produzieren. Ich hoffe, ich kann euch mit dem Inhalt der Umschläge eine Freude bereiten. Falls einer von euch damit nichts anfangen kann, könnt ihr ja untereinander tauschen. Mit diesem Smiling mit dem P am Ende. Wir haben hier Umschläge, die sind gelabelt mit meinem Namen, mit dem Namen von Roddy, mit dem Namen von Huckel und dem Namen von Dennis. Und der Tim hat keinen. Oder er hat den schon aufgemacht.
Kann ich nichts mit anfangen.
So, liebe Grüße aus Witzhelden. Wartet nicht alle. Von Peer und seiner besseren Hälfte, die auf längeren Autofahrten immer mithören muss. Und seinem Bruder, der mittlerweile auch mit dem Metaebene Virus angesteckt wurde und netterweise die Präsente für euch aus den USA organisiert hat. Ja, es gibt nur vier Umschläge. Tim hat ja eh keine Zeit, um irgendetwas Sinnvolles damit anzufangen.
Naja, das könnte ja...
Wie untereinander tauschen.
Naja, andere Farben.
Ich hab blau.
Ich hab einen mit 50 und du? Dann will ich nicht tauschen.
Na gut, so viel zu den Geschenken.
Wir können ja auch sagen, was es ist.
Das sind iTunes-Gutscheine.
Und zwar in Dolaris.
Wobei ich wahrscheinlich in meinem ganzen iTunes-Leben noch keine 25 Dollar im Store gelassen habe. Was? Ich bin cheapskate, ich bin voll geizig. Das Telefon war so teuer, ich zahl das heute noch ab. Mein erstes.
Ich hab den jetzt auch nochmal installiert. Was? Den 500er, mit Background-Scanning und so.
Jetzt tummeln wir wirklich ein bisschen durch das Weed. Durch die Themen.
Dann musst du ja die Cricket-Taste drücken.
Wir fahren jetzt auch nur die Tim-Holt-Bier-Überbrückungs-Kamera.
Wir sind ja immer noch beim...
So, wieder zurück zur Dub-Dub.
Genau, wir wollen immer noch unsere Wunschliste...
Ich will jetzt 10.9. Was erwarten wir? Ich fände ja mal so eine No-New-Features-Version auch okay. Aber so ein paar Sachen, wo sie mal das Networking in Ordnung bringen, hatte ich das schon mal erwähnt.
Was ist denn da kaputt?
Vieles. Zum Beispiel, was du selber auch schon entdeckt hast, dass V6 nicht über das VPN geht. Und das ist nur so eine Kleinigkeit, die schleppen sie jetzt seit 10.6 oder so, oder 10.5 schon vor sich her. Wann patch ich das im Binär selber? Ich geb mir echt auf den Sack. Das kann echt nicht besonders schwierig sein.
Man soll die auf seinem Bildschirm schauen, aber ich hab mir gerade so einen schönen Tweet vor die Nase bekommen. Wie wir gestern bereits im ZDF hörten, ist die Hauptfunktion von Google Class im Swingern. Die Realität ist immer am lustesten.
Mal endlich ganz entspannt filmen.
Also, WWDC, 10 neuen Jahre, ich weiß auch nicht so ganz genau. Ich hab so ein bisschen aufgehört, von der Zukunft zu träumen. Das hat mir 10.8. irgendwie abgewöhnt.
Ich weiß nicht, was ihr alle von Problemen mit 10.8. habt. Ich höre immer wieder. Ich mag 10.8. Das sind einige Bugs drin, die mal endlich gefixt werden können.
Ich hab 75 Tage abzutreiben.
Ja, das ist ein Bug-Fix für 10.7.
Aber ein guter.
Ja, aber ein guter. Da haben wir doch vor zwei Sendungen schon drüber geredet. Wie war das Feature des Ante Portas? Ich meine, du hast jetzt entweder die Möglichkeit, dass 10.9. nochmal ein besserer Bug-Fix wird. No new Features. Dann bist du aber traurig, dass du keine neuen Features hast. Oder du kriegst neue Features und dann kriegst du neue Probleme. Kannst du jetzt aussuchen.
Nee, kann ich nicht aussuchen.
Was wollt ihr denn noch für Features haben? Wir machen seit 30 oder 40 Jahren ungefähr dasselbe mit unserem Rechner. Die Eigens ändern sich, es wird alles hübscher, die Schatten ändern sich. Aber das Grundding machen wir doch seit 30 Jahren dasselbe. Das wird jetzt noch ein bisschen verfeinert.
Wie gesagt, so Fullscreen-Modus, wo man mehr als eine Glotze benutzen kann.
Das wäre schön. Nee, aber ernsthaft, was wollt ihr denn noch für Features? Was macht ihr denn im Ernsthaft? 90 Prozent am Tag mit eurem Rechner?
Tippen.
Klicken. Reading Mails.
Also suchen zum Beispiel, finde ich, könnte noch eklatant verbessert werden. Also das ganze Such-Framework ist deutlich zu verbessern. Das ganze Dateisystem ist ein totales, volles Mega-Drama. Backup inzuverlässig. Verteilung von Dateien im Netzwerk. Syncing, Sharing.
Aber er hat recht. An der Oberfläche tut sich da nicht viel.
Das steht ja auch.
Aber das ist der Punkt.
Es geht ums Verbessern. Es geht nicht um was Neues.
Es geht ums Besseres. Es muss doch ruhig was Neues dabei sein, wenn es das andere nicht mehr schlimm bessert, dann ist ja völlig in Ordnung. Nehmen wir zum Beispiel mal dieses Document Store Handling. Also dieses Prinzip, einen persistenten Desktop zu haben, das habe ich selber auch immer gefordert. Ich finde das grundsätzlich auch eine gute Idee. Ich finde das geil, wenn ich meine Büchse boote und ich komme danach wieder mit demselben Setup von Dokumenten hoch. Super. Aber es gibt halt so Detailprobleme. Also erstmal, dass mir permanent dieses iCloud per Default einfach ins Gesicht gedrückt wird. Da fehlt ja einfach der Große ja wo.
Das haben sie mir schon erzählt.
Ja gut, aber Einzeiler im Terminal und irgendwie die große Option im General Settings ist schon nochmal ein Unterschied.
Aber das ist ein Politikum.
Was mich mehr stört ist, dass dieses iCloud mir angeboten wird und es mich stört, weil dieses iCloud mir nicht das bietet. Ich will nicht so einen Store haben, wo jedes Programm seine eigenen Dokumente hat und ich bin nicht in der Lage, mit Programm 2 die Datei zu öffnen, die Programm 1 aufgemacht hat, obwohl es sich bei beiden um Text editiert hat.
Ja, aber du bist doch so ein komischer Couch, der so komische Dinge tun will, die 90% bis 98% nicht tun wollen.
Nein, Bilder mit mehreren Programmen öffnen und Texte mit mehreren Programmen öffnen tun die wenigsten. Machen alle seit 50 Jahren mit diesen Rechnungen.
Hey Tim, die Zivilisten draußen öffnen grundsätzlich jedes Bild mit einem gekrägten Photoshop. Aber ein Computer mit Tastatur ist nicht für Zivilisten.
Für Zivilisten ist iPad super, das gibt es jetzt. Deswegen möchte ich hier auch einen richtigen Military-Grade-Rechner auf meinem Tisch haben.
Ah, da läuft das Design hin.
Nee, ich finde das immer, wenn man alle beklagt, so iPad und so weiter, jetzt wird alles so, hm, für Dummies und so weiter, super. Dann wird einfach hier meine Maschine einfach noch ein bisschen zackiger. Gerne können Sie mir den Mac Pro auch einen Kamuflage-Optik da hinstellen, habe ich überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Ich hätte ihn gerne lautlos, sobald du dran lecken kannst. Ich hätte ihn gerne lautlos.
Ja, gut, braucht man auch im Militär, ne? Da gibt es sogar lautlose Hubschrauber. Ich meine, da sollte man ja so bei einem Desktop-Rechner nochmal hinkriegen.
Das ist ja fast so wie ein Hubschrauber. Zumindest muten sich manche von denen so an.
Genau, manchmal hilft halt nur noch Hubschrauber-Einsatz.
Ja, manche Leute wollen da lenken, aber das macht man an einem Hubschrauber nicht.
Ich hab noch nicht mal einen Switch angemacht und dachte ich fall hinten über, weil die mir ja einen Düsenjager starten. Und dann fiel man auf, oh das war ein 48-Ball-Fail-Switch.
Ja, wenn das Ding aufmacht, soll es halt nicht blumm machen, sondern so...
Und das geht bestimmt. Jetzt kommt gleich die Dinger, wie du den Startsound austauschst.
Ja, aber das Grund, das geht nicht um neue Feature, sondern du willst arbeiten können. Das ist ja für mich dasselbe. Achso, für mich nicht.
Neues Dateisystem heißt, ich kann besser arbeiten. Das heißt, es performt besser, ich kann es besser back-upen, ich kann es besser sinken. Es geht nicht kaputt. Ich kann Snapshotten. Oh ja. Das sind einfach Sachen, die will man schon seit 10 Jahren haben, weil die anderen sie auch haben. Ich hab das schon immer gesagt. Für mich kommt nur ein einziger Computer in Frage, nämlich der beste. Und wenn die anderen was Tolles haben, dann will ich das auch. Da bin ich wie so ein kleines Kind.
Ja, vollkommen. Dann haben wir von verschiedenen Dingen geredet. Ich verstehe unter Feature was anderes.
Irgendetwas, was es noch nie gab.
Wo wir nicht wussten, wie wir die letzten 30 Jahre leben konnten. Ich glaube nicht, dass es das noch mal kommen wird. Momentan fällt mir dazu auch nichts ein.
Was waren denn so die letzten Sachen, die wir bekommen haben? Da gab es nicht so Retina-Bildschirme.
Touch ist doch schon eine komplett neue Geschichte, oder nicht?
Eine Touch gibt es ja nicht.
Wir reden jetzt hier nicht. Wir reden jetzt hier von Military-Grade-Desktop-Rechnern.
Fragen wir doch mal den jüngsten Recruiten hier im Apple-Universum. Roddy, du hast doch gerade einen neuen Computer bekommen.
Man hat mir ein neues Gerät zur Verfügung gestellt. Ach, das ist dein neuer Dell-Limptop.
Den Dell habe ich wieder zurückgegeben.
Persistent Desktop und Dell. Ich hatte unter diesem Windows 7 ein einziges Ding gemacht, mal einen Screenshot. Und hatte dieses Screenshot-Programm noch auf.
Welche App hast du dafür genommen?
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe bei Google geguckt, was man so nennt. Und dann habe ich dann das Screenshot gemacht. War also dieser Screenshot in dieser App drin und ich so, ja beenden, zack, bumm. Mach das Ding wieder an und denk mir, wo ist denn der Screenshot? Persistent Desktop, man gewöhnt sich so unglaublich schnell daran. Windows 7 hat ihn halt nicht.
Oder auch SSDs, das ist auch gar nicht so lange her. Da haben wir noch irgendwie so Geräte in unseren Computern gehabt, die haben so Geräusche gemacht.
Spinning Rust.
Ja, also das war einfach... Mit so Metall-Splittern und so.
Ja, aber das ändert dir an dem eigentlichen nichts dringend, auf den Ding Daten abzulegen und wieder runterzurufen.
Ist ja nicht neu.
Aber ein neues Dateilsystem würde schon eine Menge bringen. Also wenn da jetzt so ein ZFS-Grade-Filesystem am Start wäre, das sieht ein User in dem Moment, wo er seinen Backup halt nicht nur jede Stunde hat, sondern alle 10 Sekunden, sieht ein User in dem Moment, wo sein Backups auch funktionieren, und einem nicht diese blöde Time-Capsule alle drei Monate erzählt, ach übrigens, das ist da alles korrupt, aber kein Problem. Ich kann einfach alles löschen und ich mach ein neues.
Nur alle drei Monate?
Deswegen hab ich, weißt du, ich mein, deswegen stelle ich mir ein Backup hin. Damit er mir alle drei Monate erzählt, das ist ja eh alt.
Ich sagte aber, man möchte es auch gar nicht warten, bis das Backup voll ist, weil das ist noch viel schlimmer.
Ne, vorher ist die Time-Kapsule kaputt.
Wenn er anfängt.
Ein Freund von mir, der hat mich auch neulich wieder angerufen. Ja, also diese Time-Kapsule, die leuchtet wieder gelb vorne und ich weiß gar nicht, ich hab nix gemacht und so. Naja, also ich glaube, das Thema Time-Kapsule ist auch so ein bisschen...
Okay, there is room for improvement.
Nein, aber was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte...
Das ist immer noch kein neues Feature. Da hat Michael vollkommen recht.
Nein, nein, aber...
Das ist jetzt einfach nur Bug-Fixing.
Ja, nein, nein, nein, es ist insofern ein neues Feature, als dass es natürlich ganz neue Features überhaupt erst ermöglicht, die derzeit einfach nur sehr schwer zu gebären sind. Wenn man sich abanschaut, was sie da für sich für einen Krampf ausliefern, da neue Features reinzukriegen...
Ja, aber dein Problem ist, dass du gerade rückwärts in der Zeit gehst. Das Ziel ist ja, das Dateisystem komplett abzuschaffen. Nein, nein.
Dateisysteme haben sich bewährt.
Aber nur für dich?
Nein, für die gesamte... Ich meine, alles, was wir heute haben, ist mit Dateisystemen entstanden.
Ja, aber du kommst nicht mehr ran. Das wird irgendwie auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad.
Genau, das gibt jetzt nur noch Dokumente.
Ja, aber dann bin ich raus. Du bist eh raus.
Dann gibt es jetzt nur noch Podcast-Dokumente, die in einem iCloud-Store von deiner Podcast abhängen.
Das ist ein schöner Traum, aber ich glaube, dass wir da noch sehr weit von entfernt sind.
Ich hoffe auch, aber ich glaube, du täuscht.
Ja, aber mal ehrlich. Du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass wir in der Zukunft nie eine Systematik haben, wo du nicht zwei Programme haben wirst, die dieselben Daten haben wollen.
Das ist einfach unvor...
So ein intelligentes Copy und Paste.
Sogar auf iOS 7 werden sie da einknicken.
Tim, das ist schon aus rechten Verwaltungsgründen nicht möglich.
Aus was für Verwaltung?
Aus rechten Verwaltungsgründen. Weil das erste Programm, das die Datei schreibt, da jetzt künftig auf alles, inklusive deines eigenen Hello World erst mal einen DRM-Stempel drauf macht, der von Hause aus verdienten wird.
Und nicht weiß, was die Linke tut.
Vor allem in der Zukunft hast du eh gar kein Filesystem mehr, weil du das alles über das Netz machst und das alles irgendwo sonst wo liegt.
Das sind alles Dokumente.
Klar, klar, klar.
Das will ich alles nicht hören.
Bleibt mir fern mit euren Dystopien. Ich will einen geilen Computer haben, der, wenn ich über die Straße gehe, mir das Gefühl und den Appeal eines Astronauten gibt.
Wahrscheinlich läuft es aber auch in so einem dicken Anzug mit so einem riesen Koffer auf dem Rücken.
Keine Schwerkraft, ja. Und alle finden mich cool.
Nee, du hast so einen dicken Anzug und so ein riesen Koffer auf dem Rücken. Und wenn der Schlauchblatt...
Aber ich merke nichts davon.
Tim, ich glaube, so gut kannst du nicht singen.
Hallo Major Tom, können Sie hören? Wenn ich auf die Raumstation gehe, dann singe ich Major Tom. Und Peter Schilling.
Nicht Major Tim?
Aber das gab es doch schon.
Wie, das gab es schon?
Hat er das gerade gemacht oder nicht?
Nee, ja, Space Oddity von David Bowie, den ersten Major Tom gesungen.
Ach, du meinst Ashes for Ashes?
Kannst du bitte noch mal einblenden? Du hattest vorhin so, dass wir sehen können, wie viele Zuhörer wir haben. Ob das jetzt schon bei Null ist.
Es gibt Dinge, die man gar nicht sehen will.
Das passt schon.
Space Oddity ist doch Major Tom.
Ja, er meint aber den Herrn Schilling.
Ja, ich rede von Major Tom von Herrn Schilling. Also können wir mal gucken, wie unsere Performance ist hier. Hörer des Einschlafen-Podcasts versus Hörer Mobamex.
Wer schläft vorher ein?
Wir sind doch deutlich vorne.
Bei uns schlafen wir ein.
Viel besser.
Passt schon. Ich hab hier, wie gesagt, diese neue Hardware hier, mal abgesehen davon, dass sie das Mac OS etwas vergurgt haben, ist es ein Retina-Macbook. Und das ist schon faszinierend. Du klickst in so einem Katalog rum, wie von Apple in so einer Werbebroschüre. Weil es ist alles so absurd scharf. Das ist so, wenn man es dann erstmal hat, will man es irgendwie nicht mehr missen.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich es bisher noch nicht gekauft habe.
Ja, nein, nein, das ist ein Strophe, wenn du wieder an den Großen gehen musst.
Und die Pixel siehst. Es gibt danach kein Zurück mehr irgendwie. Das ist ganz blöd.
Die sollen erstmal so ein Cinema-Display rausbringen. So ein 4K-Display, das wäre jetzt...
Wie kommst du so mit dem Gewicht klar?
Der ist 500 Gramm leichter als meiner. Kein Ernst. Ja, laut 400 oder so. Nach Aktenlage. Also ich hab's nicht nachgewogen. Ungefähr. Also so ein Mac-Koprom.
Du sollst was zum Innovationsgefühl sagen. Also ich meine, fühlst du dich in die Zukunft befördert?
Fühlst du dich innoviert?
Ist es sehr viel besser?
Sehr viel würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil meine alte Büchse war jetzt nicht irgendwie am Rande oder zu Ende oder so. Naja, sagen wir mal so, der Rechner hat genug Power, als dass da dieser Symantec-Direct im Hintergrund laufen kann, ohne dass man es merkt. Und das heißt schon was. Also mein Kollege wollte unbedingt eine englische Tastatur haben. Deswegen dauert es halt noch Wochen, bis er seinen Rechner hat. Und da haben sie irgendwie einen alten gegeben. Und wenn da Symantec angeht, geht er heute Kaffee trinken. Das erste, was einem auffällt...
Es wird an deiner Stelle auch Kaffee trinken gehen.
Das erste, was auffällt, ich nehme diesen Rechner in die Hand. Und da ist nicht nur ein Flash-Player drauf. Und ein Java ist da drauf. Und ein Silverlight. Nein, da ist auch ein Symantec... Wie nennt sich das? Autoprotekt? Und so?
Der Rechner ist für dich installiert worden.
Na der hat halt das Corporate Image.
Machst du das einfach neu?
Ich glaube, der größte Verkaufserfolg von Apple besteht darin, dass die Leute Windows nur bei Corporate-Maschinen kennen. Und die Möhren so dermaßen verkonfiguriert sind, dass selbst ein nackt neu installiertes Windows irgendwie angenehm zu benutzen wäre. Also ich hatte ja diesen komischen Dell, der war ja auch so, der fragt dann irgendwie alle halbe Nase lang, hallo, ich möchte jetzt ein Backup machen. Weißt du, so ein systemmodaler Dialog. Und du denkst so, was soll das, mach doch einfach. Scheiß dich doch nicht, ob du jetzt ein Backup machst oder so. Ja, gut, gleich John. Aber bitte behällige mich nicht mit dem Scheiß.
Shut up and take my performance.
Ja, genau.
Und das macht er aber immer noch manchmal. Also gerade dieses komische Vierengescanne da, also das ist das selbe.
Hat mir ein Kumpel auch gerade erzählt, da sind neue PC-Rechner für die Firma gekommen und haben uns auch unterhalten. Und das, der meinte, da ist schon Windows drauf. Und so meinte ich, ja, da ist auch lauter Shit vorinstalliert. Und so meinte der, ja, mach dir doch alle platt und mach einmal ordentlich, dann hast du den ganzen Scheiß nicht. Meinte der, nee, da muss man erst wieder die ganzen Serien irgendwann aufschreiben und danach wieder eintragen und bla und hast du nicht gesehen. Und da hat er keinen Bock, er lässt den Scheiß einfach so drauf. Also ich meine, das ist der Grund, diese Scheiß-Vorinstallierung mit den ganzen Rots irgendwie. Also ich an Microsoft würde sagen, Jungs, ihr dürft da nichts von Hand irgendwie Business beim Kunden mit drauf packen. Es ist einfach Scheiße, was ihr da macht.
Ja, aber sobald du eine IT-Abteilung hast, die irgendwie, also größere Corporation und IT-Abteilung hast und die, es ist alles böse, es ist alles unsicher und man kann den eigenen Mitarbeiter nicht trauen.
Aber um ehrlich, unsicher auf deinem Rechner ist doch Java, Flash und der Symantec-Scheiß.
Unsicher ist das, was vor dem Rechner sitzt.
Ich meine, das ist eigentlich der Flash-Player und das verinstallierte Java.
Also die würden am liebsten nur den Computer zur Arbeit schicken.
Vor allen Dingen, was du gar nicht, also wenn ich jetzt normaler User wäre, könnte ich das Java ja gar nicht updaten. Das ist das Problem noch dabei.
Das heißt, du musst ja immer den Admin callen, oder was?
Ja gut, als Developer habe ich irgendwie hier einen Admin-Zugriff und hab logisch...
Wow, du bist da schon eine gehobene Klasse, ja?
Übrigens zu deiner Frage, Michael, wie es mit so Leuten ist und dass die Gefahren hinten sitzen. Ich hab mal für einen Kunden was gemacht und war da natürlich auch länger vor Ort und hab auch mitgekriegt, wie dort sich ein neuer Technikchef vorgestellt hat. Der hat dann da so ein Team-Huddle gemacht. Ich sag jetzt auch nicht, wer das ist. Die Leute ist ein größeres deutsches Unternehmen. Die Leute, die das betroffen haben, werden sich jetzt sicherlich angesprochen fühlen auch. Jedenfalls dieser neue Technikchef hat dann da die Kantine so angemietet oder reserviert und hat dann da so feucht fröhlich mit ein paar Witzen sich vorgestellt. Und einer seiner letzten Sätze war an seine Leute von der IT, die für die Sicherheit zuständig sind. Der Tag, an dem ich unser Unternehmen im heißen News-Ticker entdecke, ist ihr letzter Arbeitstag. Ich wünsche Ihnen einen frohen Tag noch. Und dann sind natürlich in dem Moment, die haben einfach alle drunter gefahren, was da war und haben halt einfach gesagt, das sicherste System ist eins, was nicht am Netz hängt. Okay, dann kann es auch keiner benutzen, aber naja, das ist ja nicht unser Problem. Und wer unter solchen Direktiven arbeitet, der hat es dann natürlich auch entsprechend, der sieht die Gefahren halt eben an der richtigen Stelle.
Gut, wollen wir jetzt nochmal versuchen, irgendwie auch nur halbwegs zu glaskugeln, was nächste Woche denn nun kommt?
Ja, also nochmal rausgehen von, weil die Frage ja irgendwie untergegangen ist. Die neuen Retina MacBooks sind eine der besten Books, die sie seit Langem gebaut haben, ist meine Meinung. Und zwar nicht mit neu groß Feature, neu und schneller oder sonst was. Einfach so die Reduzierung auch, das ist das, was Apple am besten kann. Da steht nicht mehr MacBook Pro drauf, es ist keine kleine Taste mehr für die... Da steht nicht MacBook Pro drauf.
Zeig mal.
Steht denn da überhaupt drauf? Nichts?
Nichts. Es ist auch keine Aus-Taste mehr, mit einer Eindellung hier und die Dinge.
Und auf der Apple-Taste ist auch kein Apple mehr drauf. Was hast du denn da eigentlich gerade?
Der Auto war ein Kreuz mehr und so. Die 13er war ja von dem Retina MacBook.
Ach das ist ein... Achso, das ist auch ein 13er.
Die Aus-Taste ist nicht mehr da. Es geht um die Reduzierung und das Weglassen.
Ich hab gerade überhaupt nicht geschneit, dass du das 13er MacBook Pro hast. Ich dachte die ganze Zeit, du hast da ein R.
Ich kann es nicht mehr interessieren.
Ja, das ist ja auch schick. Bemerkenswert.
Und das ist das worauf ich zumindest hoffe, dass sie das mit den anderen Dingen auch weitergehen.
Nee, aber das stimmt schon. Sie haben halt dadurch, dass die Eject-Taste jetzt arbeitslos ist, haben sie die Eject-Taste zu einer Ausschaltetaste gemacht. Und dadurch ist aber auch diese komische, am Rand immer eine Ausschalt-Taste weggefallen und so weiter.
Die war potthässlich, die hat genervt. Okay, so können einem die Katze jetzt Stunden von Arbeit zerstören, weil sie die C-Wirkung nicht ausschalten kann.
Ich find die auch schick mit dem eingelassenen Dingsbums da. Aber stimmt schon, das ist halt noch mal...
Kann man... geht's immer noch Control-Shift rechts oben?
Nee, das geht nicht mehr.
Scheiße, das ist einer der wichtigsten Tasten. Sicher, probier aus, tippen Sie Control-Shift-Austaste. Na, geht doch.
Also.
Ich will eine Festplatten-LED haben. Nee, eine SSD-LED will ich haben.
Eine what?
Eine SSD-LED.
Die so blinkt vorne, dass der auf die SSD geschrieben wird, oder was?
Ich mag das nicht, wenn mein Rechner mich spontan anblitzt.
Kauf dir doch einen Dell. Da gibt's das serienmäßig. Die zusammen mit anderen fünf LEDs, die blinken.
Im Blau.
Hallo. Wollen wir jetzt nochmal über 10.9 sinnieren?
Es ist schwer zu sinnieren, weil...
Michael meinte ja, es gibt ja gar keine neuen Features. Dann hab ich gesagt, Datalsystem, Rules...
Ist kein Feature. Doch, ist es für dich die Grundlage?
Nein, es ist die Grundlage für Features.
Ich will mehr Sandbox-Features haben.
Ja, also dass man mehr mit der Sandbox machen kann.
Ja, und dass ich mehr verbieten kann und so. Ich will nicht, dass meine Apps an meinem Adressbuch zugreifen und alles in Scheiß.
Das kann ja schon verboten werden.
Ja, aber sie nutzen es ja noch nicht.
Also ich erlaube meinen Apps, die nicht aufs Adressbuch zugreifen müssen, auch nicht, dass sie aufs Adressbuch zugreifen.
Also das ist eigentlich ein Systemfeature, dass du immer schön gefragt hast.
Ja, das heißt, sie können nicht auf die API zugreifen, aber sie können einfach das File lesen, noch richtig? Und grundsätzlich in allen Ordnern lesen?
Nein, eben nicht.
Alle Files können in allen Ordnern lesen?
Ja, wenn du eine nicht gesendboxte ab hast, dann liest die, was sie will.
Aber Apps, die Map-Session zum Beispiel, die sind ja alle gesendboxed. Und da greifen sie mittlerweile auch regulär durch. Wenn du nicht genauestens begründen kannst, warum du jetzt die Entity offen hast, dann...
Verstehe.
Also können die Programme früher noch auf Application Support und dann in ihrem eigenen Scheiß da schreiben, sonst nicht?
Ja, gar nicht mehr. Application Support ist dann wirklich nur noch im eigenen Container. Du kriegst ja, also jedes App kriegt seinen eigenen Container und da ist dann die eigene Library, die eigenen Dokumente, da sind die eigenen Application Support drin. Und wenn deine App keine Funktion hat, die aufs Questbruch zugreifen muss, dann kommt die Rückmeldung, wieso ist da offen, dass die aufs Etasco zugreifen kann, bitte abstellen oder begründen.
So, Features in C9. Was unbedingt kommen muss, ist Maps. Ich will gerne Maps, ich will irgendwie deine Alternative zu Google haben. Ja, ich meine warum nicht?
Ja, warum nicht? Aber das ist jetzt nichts, weswegen ich jetzt aufstehen würde überhaupt nur und mich irgendwohin bewegen, um irgendwie C9 zu kaufen. Ich weiß mit der Maus.
Wenn jedes Programm in der Lage ist, geile, irgendwie geschliffene 3D-Ansichten von Orten zu präsentieren?
Von Gurkenhausen bei Berlin, meinst du? Oder wie hieß es nochmal? Schön Eiche.
Schön Eiche bei Berlin.
Ja, verstehe.
Schön Eiche ist überall.
Sind wir nicht alle ein bisschen schön Eiche?
Okay, ja Maps, aber das traut mich jetzt auch alle noch nicht vom Sockel.
Dann mach ich einen Browser auf und du ein Maps-Google-Doktor?
Was würde dich denn vom Sockel hauen?
Es wird genauso laufen wie bei den anderen.
Das ist ja gerade die Frage, die Michael auch stellt. Ich stelle mich jetzt mal, ja bin ich sowieso ein bisschen Contra heute geboostet, aber ich stelle mich jetzt mal auf Michaels Seite und sage mal, was ist denn das nun, was ein Feature ist. Und zwar ein Feature nicht, dass irgendwo irgendjemand mal ein Icon in Ordnung gebracht hat oder irgendwie selbst das fucking Networking gefixt ist deklariert jetzt mal nicht als Feature, sondern irgendwie...
Dass wir etwas machen können, was wir vorher noch nie mit dem Rechner gemacht haben.
Und wo wir uns hinterher fragen, was wir die letzten 30 Jahre ohne getan haben.
Genau.
Das wird nicht kommen. So ein Feature wird nicht kommen. Was kommen wird, ist die übliche 200 neue Features-Liste, wo du dann durchguckst und dir denkst, das soll ein Feature sein.
Ja, aber wo du dann 20 Dinger drin entdeckst, glaub ich gar nicht.
Weil ich glaube, meine Fragen jetzt ganz kleine... Also ich würde es mir zumindest wünschen, falls ihr das auch wieder nur wunschdenken. Aber ich hoffe wirklich, ich meine, wir haben jetzt nun wahrlich länger nichts gehört, was auch schon ein bisschen ungewöhnlich ist, dass die in sich gehen und sich nochmal wirklich aufs Wesentliche konzentrieren und wirklich mal vielleicht nur 50 neue Features kommen. Aber die ordentlich.
Was noch kommen wird, und Tim wird das super finden, ist Siri vor Mac.
Ja, wenn man es ausschalten kann.
Alle haben da jetzt gemerkt, dass es keiner braucht.
Ja, neues Feature, man kann es abschalten.
Also ich sag nochmal ein paar Sachen, die man einbauen könnte, die ich nicht unbedingt erwarte, aber die ich geil finde und womit definitiv mehr machbar wäre. Also so dieses Sharing von Content zwischen Apps, das ist auch etwas, was bei iOS dringlich gewünscht ist. Derzeit ist halt alles total reglementiert und hier kommen nur die Sachen rein, die Apple macht. Ja, mit irgendwie scheiß Notification-Center, mit kacke Facebook und beklopptes Twitter.
Ja, aber es hat ja auch einen Grund, warum die das tun. Und es hat ja auch einen Grund, warum es noch keinen ein... Nee, ja auch, aber es gibt noch einen viel wichtigeren Grund.
Sicherheit?
Du bist der Erste, der meckert, wenn dein iPhone und dein...
Vorgebliche Sicherheit.
Also so wie das Sharing unter iOS 6 gemacht ist, ist es technisch nicht mehr so eine große Hürde, das jetzt in größerem Rahmen anzubieten. Sag ich mal, stelle ich mich jetzt mal ganz...
Funktionalität und Sicherheit steht sich immer etwas gegenüber. Das ist natürlich ein Trade, auf den man immer machen muss. Und ich sage ja nicht, das soll jetzt deswegen alles total unsicher werden. Aber ich sehe jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ein, dass alles auf dem Betriebssystem, dass alle möglichen Verbindungen zwischen Applikationen und diesem Betriebssystem nur noch jetzt dadurch reglementiert werden, wie Apple gerade seine Business-Modelle so sieht. Und das ist mir einfach zu wenig. Ich will da auch mehr Möglichkeiten haben. Überhaupt dieser ganze Mumpitz mit Dateitypen und Dokumenttypen muss besser sichtbar werden, muss besser unterscheidbar werden. Wir haben da so viele Sachen schlummern.
Da weißt du aber, dass du da an die Wand betest, weil das ist genau der Punkt, den sie gerade versuchen loszuwerden, dass der User eben nicht mehr wissen muss. Oh, ist jetzt Punkt JPG was anderes als Punkt JPEG oder so ein Zeug? Sondern das soll der User nicht wissen. Das ist ein Dokument und ein Dokument ist ein Bild. Fertig. Peng aus.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Du sagst gerade, es soll sichtbarer oder offener werden.
Nein, nein, nein, du verstehst mich ein bisschen miss. Das Ding ist so, das Betriebssystem müsste besser wissen, wer mit einem Bild, und zwar egal ob es ein PNG oder JPG ist, in dem Moment auch wirklich was anfangen kann und auch anfangen möchte. Und dieses Durchreichen, dieses ich muss die Datei in die richtige Stelle legen, Dreck und Drop machen, in der richtigen Stelle, x, y und auf dem Bildschirm finden, wo ich es hin drücke, um es in dieses Programm reinzubekommen, das muss sich verbessern lassen.
Dass man direkt aus Programm A sagen kann, der Dokument, weil ich hier offen habe, öffne ich doch mal in den Tolldown mit den anderen Dingern, die das können.
Das ist einfach so Copy und Paste im 21. Jahrhundert.
Wo geht denn das nicht?
Copy und Paste geht doch.
Copy und Paste geht sogar mit Bildasse.
Du meinst glaube ich etwas, was wir alle nicht verstehen.
Explain yourself.
Dateisystem ohne Dateisystem.
Ich merke einfach, dass es relativ viel Aufwand erfordert, Daten immer an die richtige Stelle zu bekommen, wo du weiter arbeiten möchtest.
Gib doch mal ein Beispiel.
Naja, irgendeine Datei, die ich gerade mit Programm X erzeugt habe, möchte ich gerne in Programm Y haben.
Du kannst ja doch oben aus dem Fenster rausziehen. Das heißt nicht Rechtsklick.
Kontrollklick.
Dieser Podcast ist nazifrei.
Das ist auch kein Kontrollklick.
Nee, ist auch kein Kontrollklick.
Das ist ein Secondary-Click. Secondary.
Secondary-Button, Kontext-Click.
Egal.
Der Button, wo du das hinlegst, ist auch total schnurz.
Ja, aber das ist kompliziert.
Das ist zu kompliziert.
Du kannst doch aus jedem Fenster oben auf das Kleid einkönnen.
Was kommt denn, wenn ich Kontrollklick mache? Was kommt denn im Kontext-Menü?
Da kommt dann erstmal... Nee, ich rede gar nicht von Klick.
Ich sage aber nicht Rechtsklick.
Du ziehst das raus auf das Programm, auf das du es haben willst.
Ja, das Programm, wo ist das Programm? Das Programm ist irgendwo in irgendeinem Ordner.
Ja, aber das liegt doch an dir. Du kannst doch Ordnung halten.
Jetzt lass mich doch einfach mal erklären, was ich möchte. Es ist auch nicht so schwer zu verstehen, um das mal deutlich zu sagen. Also, derzeit ist das einfach ein Wildwuchs. Du hast da Dreck und Drop. Du hast irgendwie Copy und Paste. Du hast... Open, tralala, dann kriegst du so komplizierte Service Menüs, wo 1000 Einträge drinstehen, wo dann vielleicht auch noch jedes Programm, was potenziell diese Datei öffnen kann, fünfmal drin ist, weil sich diese Services-Datenbank wieder aus irgendwelchen Gründen zum fünften Mal angelegt hat, aber nicht die alte Version gelöscht hat. Genau, da muss man immer irgendwie... Es ist einfach nicht robust. Das liegt auch daran, weil dieses Dateisystem nicht robust ist. Das liegt auch daran, weil überhaupt dieser ganze Unterbau nicht robust ist. Und den hätte ich gerne robust.
Und dann kann man... Aber wie würdest du es denn jetzt praktisch wünschen?
Kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen, ich hätte es jetzt genau so. Aber ich kann dir sagen, was ich erzielen möchte. Ich leide zum Beispiel... Also Copy und Paste hat einfach zu viel Gedächtnisverlust. Weil das macht man so häufig. Und du verlierst irgendwie diese Information. Ich würde gerne Dinge docken können zum Beispiel. Vormerken können. So einen temporären, systemübergreifenden Workspace schaffen, wo ich sage, das ist jetzt etwas, womit ich arbeite. So wie sich ein Maler Farbe auf eine Palette nimmt. Weil er weiß, dass er die dann später irgendwann bringt. Aber du hast da eben mehrere Punkte. Ja, aber ich will nicht so in Gedanken von Clipboard arbeiten. Ich will mir so ein Working-Environment.
Also die Idee, was ins Dock zu schieben, so kurzfristig?
Mit docken meine ich mehr nur so irgendwo hinbringen. Aber sicherlich nicht das Dock.
Wieso nicht?
Weil das ein Scheißort ist.
Aber da vergeht man es nicht.
Da ist es im Gerümpel mit anderen Sachen.
Schieb es doch ein paar Sekunden später weiter.
Ja, aber dann muss es erst mal wieder finden und dann hüpfen da tausend Icons und dann weißt du nicht, ob es unten oder oben ist. Ich will das separat haben. Ich will irgendwie ein Working-Space haben. Gebe ja auch nur mal einen Einblick...
Man muss ab und zu auch mal Nein sagen können.
Nein, ich finde die Idee toll. Die Idee hätte ich auch gern. Ich habe mich schon oft daran versucht an so etwas. Ich verstehe, das Problem ist nur, dass du mehr Probleme aufwürfst, als du vermutlich lösen kannst. Wie kommen denn dir jetzt die Dokumente da rein, außer ohne mit Drag- und Drop- und Submenüs?
Es gibt ja hier so tausend Tasten, mit denen man irgendwas so draufzoomen lassen kann, mit dem bekloppten Dashboard und so weiter, wo irgendwelche Widgets rumliegen, die seit Jahren keiner benutzt. Das ist sozusagen eine Fehlentscheidung gewesen. Dieses Widget-Teil und sowas. Das wäre sehr viel besser für die permanente Arbeit genutzt. Wo ist denn dieses Clipboard, von dem immer alle reden? Wo ist denn das? Warum kann ich das nicht visualisieren? Gibt's nicht!
Doch, gibt's aber nicht von Apple.
Naja, aber das ist meiner Meinung nach Teil der Aufgabe eines Betriebssystems, dessen Sinn und Zweck es ist, Document-based Apps zu versorgen.
Du möchtest jetzt gerne einen Workspace, eine Palette haben, die du in die Hand nehmen kannst. Lightweight, die man per einer Taste aufruft, wo man sein aktuellen Dokument so drauf stapelt und...
Du hast doch die Documents! Du kannst doch dein Finder so einstellen und das zeigst du dir nach dem Datum an. Documents! Und dann zeigt er dir die Letzten Benutzten an. Das ist eine Taste.
Ja, aber die Letzten Benutzten sind nicht unbedingt die, die ich auswähle. Ich kann kein Picking vornehmen, ich kann kein Tagging vornehmen, ich kann nicht Dinge markieren, ich kann nicht Sachen zu Projekten zu ordnen. Es gibt einfach kein Management, das wirklich arbeitsorientiert ist. Es gibt ein Management, das vielleicht dateiorientiert ist oder folderbasiert ist. Aber da ist immer das Problem, dass ein Objekt nicht in zwei Foldern sein kann. Es kann nicht sowohl Teil davon sein, als auch Teil davon sein.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass du da... Das Problem ist aber, dass du deinen Arbeitsablauf haben möchtest und dein Arbeitsablauf ist garantiert nicht meiner.
Ich will nicht meinen, ich will ein System haben, was Workflows erlaubt, was Programme nutzen können, wo sie sagen können, liebes Betriebssystem, ich brauche jetzt mal ein Working Space.
Feinder Fenster, neue Ortsner, alles rein schmeißen?
Nein, nein, nein, nicht Dateien. Arbeit, nicht Dateien.
Ali, hast du?
Vorgänge.
Dinge, Aktionen, die geschehen sind. Undo-Ketten, alles soll da drin sein, soll auch speicherbar sein, soll wieder hervorholbar sein. Weil ich arbeite kontinuierlich an Sachen. Und das muss sich dieses Betriebssystem merken können und Programme müssen sich da reindocken, damit ich weiß, was dazugehört. Damit ich sagen kann, jetzt will ich nur die Programme sehen und nur die Dateien sehen, die dazugehören. Und alles andere interessiert mich jetzt gerade nicht. Es ist nur eine Vision und ich sag dir, da kann man eine Menge verbessern. Es ist nicht so, dass wir jetzt hier schon am Ende der Entwicklung sind. Es ist erst 2013. Stell dir mal vor, es wäre jetzt 2070. Da geschieht noch eine Menge.
Dann kannst du dir einen Star Trek Film angucken.
Ist nicht alles vorbei.
Dann nimmst du die Maus in die Hand, sprichst von unten rein, Computer, öffne den Workflow.
Ich glaube nicht, dass dieses Reingequatschen in den Computer irgendwie die Lösung ist. Komplexität kann man zwar immer wieder versuchen zu reduzieren, aber das machst du nur, damit du danach wieder neue Komplexitätsuniversen aufmachen kannst, in denen du überhaupt erst mal arbeiten kannst, wie du es vorher gar nicht vorgestellt hast.
Okay, wir zoomen jetzt mal wieder zurück und sagen, okay, habe ich verstanden, ist auch schön, kann man machen, ist auch jetzt nicht so wild. Ist aber jetzt auch nicht das Breaking Feature. Was ist jetzt das Breaking Feature, was wir nächste Woche sehen?
Ich weiß nicht, was wir sehen. Ich sag dir nur, was nötig wäre.
Maps und Siri.
Das ist jetzt 10.9.
Sie werden garantiert oben das Menü noch mal so umgestalten, dass du beim einen Blick auf das Menü sehen kannst, das ist jetzt nicht mehr 10.8, das ist 10.9. Das haben sie bisher jedes Mal gemacht. Egal, ob jetzt die Spotlightsuche dazukam oder ob die Spotlightsuche nicht mehr einen blauen Hintergrund hat. Als letztes ist doch dieses komische Notification Center dazugekommen. Das ist wieder ein neues Icon.
Wahrscheinlich machen sie das wieder weg. Von nicht durchsichtig nach durchsichtig.
Jaja, das wird auf jeden Fall kommen. Ich glaube, das machen sie vor allen Dingen, damit der Support aus einem Screenshot SofGod sehen kann. Der erzählt Unsinn, der ist unter 10.7, das ist gar nicht 10.8.
Ist doch alles Pille-Palle. Die wichtigste Frage ist, was kriegen wir diesmal für ein Galaxien-Nebel-Hintergrund oder nicht?
Auch wieder wahr. Und wie heißt die Mieze?
Wie heißt die Mieze-Katze? Naliga. Da haben wir uns doch schon aufgeeint.
Die Mieze-Katze heißt Sylvester.
Mit der Tweety ab. Pussy. Eigentlich gibt es nichts, was jetzt groß hier Staub aufwirbeln kann, glaube ich. Also Detailverbesserungen haben wir uns ja geeinigt. Es sind jede Menge darin drin, aber ansonsten...
Dreck und Drob von Dokumenten aufs iPad. Also in funktionierend.
Dazu hätte ich aber überhaupt gerne...
Das wäre mal featurell, dass es da unten für deinen iPad irgendeinen kleinen Ad-Icon gibt, wo ich einfach Sachen draufschieben kann.
Und der macht es mir automatisch. Musik zu Musik, Bilder zu Bilder und Dinge.
Und muss nicht iTunes starten und so ein Schmutz.
Ich will meine Spaces wieder haben.
Gut, ich hab sie nie benutzt, aber naja. Also dass sie mal iTunes zerkloppen und irgendwie sinnvolle Einzelteile draus machen.
Zerschlagen. Wir zerschlagen das Serf und Sympärium.
Da müsste man ins Kartellamt kommen und sagen, es ist zu groß geworden.
Das App-Kartellamt hat angerufen. Wir müssen iTunes zerschlagen.
Okay. Also wir glaskugeln, dass eigentlich die Glaskugel sehr klein ausfallen wird.
Die ist ein bisschen zerkratzt, also ich sehe da auch nicht so viel.
Oder, wir wollen jetzt mal auf Optimistisch halten, sie haben deswegen jetzt die letzten Wochen und Monate uns so richtig abhängen lassen, weil sie doch mal was richtig Geiles haben. Wir haben überhaupt gar keine Ahnung, was das sein könnte.
Das geht vielleicht gar nicht um Software, sondern um Hardware?
Egal, oder die Kombination aus beiden.
Naja, aber ich meine, wenn sie eine große neue Betriebssystemversion...
Nur, die einen holographischen 4K-Resolution Bildschirm projiziert vor dich und so.
Nee, also Hardware glaube ich nicht. Hardware auf der WWDC, das ist immer sehr selten.
Die üblichen Upgrades. Doch, Mac Pro. Ja, es gibt so ein paar andere Sachen, die erst laufen aus, gerade in den Shops und all so Zeugs. Also da werden diese wieder noch schneller... Nur in Europa. Ja, und auch andere Sachen. Auch ein Mini, das muss auch mal wieder noch ein Megahatt mehr kriegen und so.
Ja, trotzdem, die WWDC war immer Software.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Die war immer sehr Software...
Nein, das, was du redest, wirr.
Nein, aber es ging nicht...
Die haben da so oft neue Laptops vollgestellt.
Und zwar die richtig guten.
Und früher haben die sogar eine Maus unter den Sitz gepackt.
Das war eine All-Side-Kamera. Eine Maus auch? Ja, manchmal haben sie... Wenn irgendeine Transition anstand, dann gab es zur WWDC natürlich irgendwie die Geräte, die du dann nehmen konntest, um dann auf der neuen Prozessor-Plattform irgendwie dein Zeug zu machen.
Developer-relevante Hardware, die findet halt auf der WWDC statt.
Ja, schon, aber im Prinzip ist die WWDC immer fokussiert auf die Developer. Und die Developer, die brauchen nicht 200 MHz mehr Mac Mini, sondern die wollen wissen, was das... Ja, die brauchen vielleicht einen Mac Pro, vielleicht.
Deswegen ja.
Brauchen sie aber eigentlich auch nicht. Ich weiß, du kennst einen Developer, der hat einen Mac Pro.
Ich hab viele Developer, die einen Mac Pro haben.
Ich hab einen Mac Pro.
Ich hab ihn abgeschafft, ich hätte ihn gerne, ich hab ihn abgeschafft, weil er mir zu laut ist. Ich hätte gerne einen leisen Mac Pro mit dem Retina 27er Display hinten dran.
Das ist so was, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Spoiler Warning.
Und Camouflage. Und was zum Licken.
Das sind ja gleich drei Wünsche auf einmal.
So, 10.9, keine Ahnung, wie die Mietsekatze heißt, keine Ahnung, was das bringt. Wir lassen uns überraschen.
Auf jeden.
Also ich glaube tatsächlich an eine Verbesserung der Dateisystemsituation, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie den großen Durchbruch machen.
Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher. Sie werden vielleicht was am Dateisystem fingern, aber das wirst du definitiv nicht als Verbesserung aufnehmen. Ich würde sagen, wenn, dann verschlimmbessern solltet.
Nö, weil der Weg, den sie gehen, ist ja eigentlich ganz cool. Also sie haben ja davon abgesehen.
Mit dieser Zwischen-Ebene. Vielleicht füllen sie einfach mal...
Core Storage.
Vielleicht füllen sie ja Compression ein.
Das wäre zum Beispiel denkbar. Aber es bringt aber auch nicht wirklich was.
Du meinst Compression auf Block-Ebene unten und nicht im Dateisystem.
Genau. Ja, oder überhaupt mal Check-Zooming. Also Check-Zooming, das ist einfach absurd, dass wir mittlerweile Terabytes in diesen Computern speichern können. Und wenn da ein Bit flippt, weiß keiner Bescheid.
Was eigentlich hier aus diesem Horizontem geworden ist.
Mal ganz ehrlich, wenn Apple Check-Zooming auf Block-Ebene macht im Dateisystem und die Leute installieren sich den Scheiß, was meinst du, wie viele von den MacBooks, die plötzlich auf dem Tisch haben? Weil das Betriebssystem sagt, die Festplatte ist nicht mehr gut.
Das können die nicht sein. Damit schaffen sie sich bloß Ärger, Tim.
Das machen sie nicht an. Das Betriebssystem schreibt das dann woanders hin.
Nee, das Betriebssystem sagt erst mal, diese Datei kannst du nicht mehr öffnen, die ist korrupt. Und damit steht der Typ mit seinem Ding im Apple Store. Nein, bei den Check-Zooming? Was soll er sonst den Check-Zooming bringen? Der Check-Zoom soll den User warnen, dass seine Datei kaputt ist, damit er sich nicht auch seine Backups kaputt macht. Also würde das System jetzt viel häufiger sagen, deine Dateien sind im Arsch, und deswegen stehen die Leute viel häufiger im Apple Store. Das können sie nicht wollen.
Ach, das wollen die, dass die Leute...
Aber nicht mit Ärger am Hals an der Genius Bar.
Also ich sag dir, die kommen lieber mit, irgendwie eine Datei ist kaputt, als meine ganze Festplatte ist weg und mein ganzes Leben und heul, heul, heul und meine Studenten abmachen.
Ja, aber wenn die alle drei Wochen ankommen müssen, anstatt nur eine, fünf Jahre, wenn es wirklich passiert.
Das tun sie ja nicht.
Jetzt aus Corporate Sicht machst du das nicht.
Apple will das alles in der Cloud haben. Die wollen überhaupt gar nicht, dass irgendwelche User noch Daten auf ihrem eigenen Ding haben. Die Richtung geht in den Cloud und da haben die ein Mirror und fertig.
Da läuft das alles auf Windows-Server mit NTFS und dann passiert damit nichts. Nee, das ist nicht so.
Doch, so wollen die das.
Das kriegen die gar nicht hin.
Das kann sein, aber das ist das, was die wollen.
Das kriegen die auch in Deutschland nicht hin.
Du, wenig Kontrolle, die ganz viel Kontrolle. Das ist das, was die wollen.
Leute, immer an die Hörer denken, den blutet wahrscheinlich schon das Ohr auf eurer hektischen Argumentation.
Deswegen hören wir doch unsere Sendung.
Wie lauter Masochisten.
Du hörst doch auch keine Podcasts, oder?
Warum nicht?
Kein Bauch auf den Ohren, stimmt's? Nee, nee, nee.
Als ich dann hier eingeladen wurde, eure Podcasts mal länger als fünf Minuten gehört, das Problem ist mir, es ist mir zu langsam.
Wie zu langsam? Du kannst ja auch schneller abspielen.
Ja, aber dann kann ich ja nebenbei wieder nichts anderes machen. Dann muss ich ja immer wieder dahin und... Ein Buch kann ich in meiner Geschwindigkeit lesen, das kann ich zur Seite legen. Aber ewig irgendwo zuhören, selbst wenn es noch so interessant und lustig ist, das krieg ich nicht hin. Ich fahr keine Straßenbahn.
Du sitzt jetzt zu Hause, ein gutes Zuhause, richtig?
Ich sag ja, für den Mac programmieren ist gar nicht so schlecht. Gut, wollen wir mal ein anderes Thema aufrufen? Ich glaub, wir haben das jetzt hier durchgespielt, den Level. Ich weiß, du willst dich da ein bisschen zurückhalten, aber Clemens, wir müssen das trotzdem noch mal aufbringen. Du warst erfolgreich und hast Netz gemacht auf der Republika und alle waren total in Trance.
Auf der Republika?
Ich weiß das, weil ich war da und ich hab's mitbekommen, wie sie alle deliriert haben, weil sie das irgendwie nicht kennen.
Das klingt auch nur deswegen, weil niemand irgendwas mitgebracht hat, weil sie alle vorher gesagt haben, gibt eh kein Netz.
Aber ich hab gehört, dass da schon der ein oder andere Access Point von irgendwelchen Leuten betrieben wurde. Wenn es kein Netz gibt, dann müssen wir noch irgendwas zeigen und lalala. Sowas passiert doch auf solchen Veranstaltungen, oder nicht?
Ja, wir hatten so ein paar Access Points am Start. Ein paar Leute haben es auch benutzt. War eher verhältnismäßig mau, aber ein paar Leute haben es benutzt.
Ihre eigenen?
Keine Ahnung. Wir haben 6.800 Geräte gesehen. In den drei Tagen.
6.800 Geräte? Gab es eigentlich eine offizielle Teilnehmerzahl der Republik? Das ist eine gesagt worden.
Die Zahl liegt aber trotzdem weiter runter. Das heißt, du kannst schon mit einem ordentlichen Faktor auswählen. Jenseits, weit jenseits der eins liegt.
Ja, aber bestimmt nicht bei der zwei. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass die Ziele mit zwei die weiße sind.
Ich weiß wirklich keine offiziellen Daten von den Leuten, die da waren. Was ich dir auch sagen kann, weil der Chat freut sich gerade dafür, dass wir wieder ein bisschen über Apple jubeln, ist 70% dieser 6800 Geräte waren von Apple. 70%!
Gibt es Zahlen zueinander?
30%!
Das tut er denn jetzt, und er hat es nicht mal gesehen. Ich kann auch eine andere Zahl sagen, wir haben um die 50 Nokia-Geräte gefunden. Was? Um die 50. 50? Ja, das kann man auch noch dazu sagen. Also wir zählen, wir wissen nicht, was die Leute alle in der Tasche hatten und nicht eingeschaltet haben. Wir wissen auch nicht, was die Leute alle in der Tasche hatten und nicht eingebucht haben, weil wir haben ja dort ein offenes Netz. Und da ist ja in den Jahren, wo es mal ging, ganz früher ist ja mal richtig Schindlöder betrieben worden. Wir wurden da sehr schöne Szenen beschrieben, wo Sascha Lobo hochroten Kopf in der Ecke saß und all seine Passwörter geändert hat, weil er unverschüssete Verbindungen benutzt hat und irgendjemand das auf eine Twitter-Wall geschrieben hat, weil seine Passwörter sind. Das muss wohl mal passiert sein. Und deswegen...
Der war noch nie auf dem Kongress, was?
Da gab es ein paar Leute, die sich da entsprechend zurückgehalten haben und haben gesagt, nee, das mache ich lieber nicht. Wer weiß, wer da alles meine Daten rumstüffelt.
Der Chat fragt gerade, ob unter den 50 Nokia-User ein iPhone verlost wurde.
Ja, bei den Nokia-Dingern muss ich mir jetzt noch dazu sagen. Also, da ist ja nochmal die Hürde schwerer. Beim iPhone ist es ja so, du machst das halt auf und es sagt, schlimmstenfalls, wenn du diese Option nicht abgeschaltet hast, hier ist ein WLAN, willst du das nutzen, dann sagst du ja und dann ist der Dropsy gelutscht. Das letzte Mal, als ich ein Nokia-Gerät in der Hand hatte, musste ich dann irgendwie einen Access-Point einrichten, dem irgendwelche Namen geben und irgendwelchen Tralala, das heißt, bis ich in irgendeinem WLAN drin war, ist natürlich auch erstmal eine gewisse Schmerz-Emergen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist. Nein. Ist nicht mehr so.
Ich hatte neulich mal eine einzelne Hand zum Spielen, als das ist. Ich finde die gar nicht mal so üblich.
Aber vor ein paar Jahren, als Nokia noch Nokia war, ich hatte mal noch so eins und meinte auch so, hier, Freund. Also er wollte mir nicht glauben, dass es schwierig sei, in das WLAN zu kommen. Und ich meinte so, ich geb dir jetzt das Ding und dann stoppe ich die Zeit. Und das war so ein Belesener, seit 20 Jahren erfahrener Nerd wie wir. Also jemand mit Plan, der auch schon viel gesehen hat und Unix kennt und alles und PipaPon, genau weiß, was er tun muss. Ich glaube er hat 13 Minuten gebraucht. Bis er es geschafft hat, dieses Nokia-Telefon, ohne vorherige Kenntnisse des User Interfaces, in das Wetter anzubringen. Oder er hat nach 13 Minuten aufgegeben, das weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau. Eins von beiden.
So geht es nur unter Windos auch immer.
Das ging relativ, also das war okay, war fluffig.
Ja okay, ich meine jetzt nach 10 Jahren.
Ja gut, aber ich glaube, wer heute noch ein Nokia in der Hand hat, der hat eh da noch sowas, ist das 5110 oder so?
Ich habe übrigens gelogen, es sind 60 Geräte gewesen. Oh, 60, doch. Und was habt ihr noch unterscheiden können? Also nur mal grundsätzlich, ich habe hier so eine schöne Grafik.
Konntet ihr noch zwischen iOS und Macs unterscheiden?
Ja, habe ich aber jetzt hier nicht in der Statistik. Man kann die unterscheiden, weil die sich anders benehmen im Netz. Also wie wir das grundsätzlich feststellen, ist, wir ziehen uns halt die Statistiken raus aus den Access Points, was die Mac-Adressen angeht. Und man kann in den ersten drei Stellen der Mac-Adresse kann man einen Hersteller auslesen. Und gerade bei so Firmen, wo halt Software und Hardware aus einem Laden kommen, wie bei Apple, ist es halt sehr eindeutig. Apple mischt allerdings iOS-Geräte durcheinander in diesem Bereich. Aber man kann die teilweise unterscheiden noch. Aber die haben wir nicht als Grafik visualisiert. Ich hab jetzt gerade mal die Grafik hier nochmal gezogen. Ich kann noch sagen, wir haben Samsung war 9,8% der Anteil. Irgendwelche Intel-Dinger, wahrscheinlich Laptops oder irgendwas, 4,5%. HTC ist ja auch so ein Android-Ding mit 3,9%. Murata, keine Ahnung wer das so ist, 2,6% und danach wird es sozusagen LG haben wir noch ein bisschen danach, sind ferner liefen.
Wie viel war Samsung?
Samsung 9,8%, 600 Geräte ungefähr. Jetzt kann man natürlich auch mal versuchen daraus rauszulesen, wo sozusagen Windows Phone drauf ist. Es gibt sogar 20 Geräte, wo der Hersteller als Microsoft angegeben ist. Aber ich denke mal, dass diese auch auf anderen Geräten verbreitet sind, mit ihrem Windows Phone oder so. Sony übrigens, das ist so Sony Ericsson, sind auch so ungefähr so am Nokia großen. Ja, das kommen wir nochmal ein bisschen näher auseinanderfuzzeln. Die Analyse habe ich ja nicht gemacht, weil ich jetzt noch ein paar andere Sorgen hatte. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Merkmale, an denen man die Dinge erkennen kann. Aber wir sehen davon, die Apple-Geräte sind ja immer so nett und blöken immer rum. Und zwar permanent als Multicast. Wer sie sind, warum sie sind, was sie sind und dass Steve ein geiler Mann war.
Ja, war er auch.
Ja, das sagen sie auch. Freimütig. Alle Apple-Geräte sagen das andauernd. Das ist das Bonjour-Ding. Sie sagen dir sogar teilweise, wenn du die Bonjour-Announcements dir anhörst und es nur wirklich, da kann auch keiner sagen, wir würden hier die Packet-Inspection der Sachen machen, das drückt dir so ein Gerät auf. Da kannst du gar nicht weghören. Weil wenn du in demselben W-Laden bist, wie so ein Ding, dann kriegst du dauernd erzählt, wie toll das doch ist. Und das ist ein iPad 3,5 oder so was ist. Also diese üblichen Angaben, die müsste man jetzt mal statistisch ausländern.
Und was war so dein Eindruck? Also wurde das Netz da viel genutzt?
Viel weniger, als wir dachten. Es waren sehr viele Leute eingebucht, die casual gemacht haben, die dort vielleicht getwittert haben oder ge-emailed haben. Also du kannst, wie gesagt, nicht rein gucken, was die dort machen. Wir sehen halt nur die Nutzung, auch die Intensität der Nutzung. Das ist ein Faktor, den wir halt einfach brauchen für unsere Netzsteuerung, für das Netzmanagement dort, um zu sehen, wie viele Megabits fließen jetzt gerade irgendwo hin. Meine Vermutung ist, wir hatten jetzt wirklich den Effekt, das gab es ja auch im Vorfeld, dass viele Leute per Twitter gesagt haben, ich bringe meinen Laptop gar nicht mit, weil das hat die letzten Jahre eh nicht funktioniert. Dann müsste ich jetzt immer auf meinen Laptop aufpassen, deswegen lasse ich den gleich zu Hause. Wobei ich das allerdings dann auch wieder sage, naja mein Gott, dann hätten sie das am Tag zwei mitgebracht. Aber auf der anderen Seite glaube ich auch, dass die Nutzung deswegen, die haben das Netz nur so zu 25%, die Kapazität, die Bandbreite nur zu 25% ausgenutzt. Die Leute maximal, weil das Leute sind, die zu Hause genügend Bits haben, um sich ihre Filme und den ganzen anderen Quatsch runterzuladen. Wer da auf die Republika geht, der sitzt und twittert und e-mailt und guckt auch gerne mal das YouTube-Video an, was ihm jemand empfiehlt, aber der fängt jetzt nicht an Filme runterzuladen. Das macht er zu Hause. Was soll er das da machen? Das ist Quatsch. Also ich nehme mal schon an, dass die Verbreitung von Internet bei den Leuten, die dort auflaufen, zu Hause so gut ist, dass die das ja nicht da die Nerven haben, sich da eine halbe Stunde in die Ecke zu setzen, sich da irgendwie Sachen runterzuladen. Wir haben so den Highscore. Den Highscore hat einer errissen mit einer Intel-Karte, also wahrscheinlich ein Windows-User, der hat sich knappe 4G einmal runtergeladen. Ich schätze mal, das war irgendwie ein komplettes Windows-Update oder sonst irgendwas. Und der nächste Runner-up war auch jemand mit einer Apple-ID, der auch so in dieser Größenordnung von knapp unter 4G geladen hat. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch jemand, der zu Hause nur ISDN hat. Und er kam auf die Republika und seine Apple hat ihm gesagt, ich schätze dir mal ein Update für dich.
4G-Arbeit?
Keine Ahnung. Das sind zwei iTunes-Updates und ein paar Drucker. Also kommen die Drucker-Updates mit regelmäßig 300 Megabyte. Oder ein neues Xcode. Also Apple ist da schon gerade bei den Mac OS X-Updates oder OS X-Updates sehr freigeblich.
Dann klickst du noch alle Dokument-Sets an in Xcode. Und alle iPhone-Simulatoren für alle iOS-Versionen. Dann kommst du schon so auf 4G. Das schaffst du dann schon.
Also wie gesagt, war nicht das Problem. Wer hat einen Gigabit-Ablink dort, der hat dich ausgereicht.
Dann gab es hier noch so eine Visualisierung. Du hast ja sozusagen das Nock gemacht, das heißt sowohl das Kabelnetz, den Internet-Ablink, als auch das Wireless. War da alles mit drin.
Das hab ich nicht alleine gemacht. Das hab ich mit einem ganzen Set von Kollegen gemacht.
Nicht nur alleine, aber mit deiner Initiative. Und wie groß war das Team? Wie viele Leute braucht man so?
Wir waren so als Dauerbesetzung, die immer da waren, immer gemacht und gebastelt und getan haben. Da waren drei Leute da plus noch drei, die jetzt mal so hinzukamen. Das ist extra CPU, was auch ganz nett ist. Auch ein Kollege und Freund von mir, der aus den USA gerade dabei war, konnte sich in Ruhe mit Statistik-Sachen befassen. Wir haben versucht, da noch ein paar Sachen hinzukriegen.
Feuerwehr.
Ja, nicht nur Feuerwehr, das ist halt ein Event-Netz. Da wird sehr viel vorne weg geplant. Dann steht plötzlich einer an der Tür und sagt, wir haben da jetzt noch ein Filmteam von so und so in der Halle so und so dahinten, die wollen gerade eine Livestream irgendwo hin. Da hast du doch bestimmt ein Kabel? Nö. Aber kann man da nicht noch eins legen? So ist das halt im Event-Netz. Das heißt, du hast auch mit regulären Dingen zu tun. Dann hatte ich es auch bei dir in deinem Sendestudio erwähnt, da gab es auch einen Morgen, wo dir die Stromversorgung der gesamten Station etwas geschwächelt hat. Weil es hat ja geregnet. Und da gab es dann auch...
Haben die ihre Kabel auf dem Dach oder was?
Nee, aber die haben zu viele Fehlerstromschutzschalter.
Egal.
Fies war sehr fies zu uns, der Vieh in Halle 5. Und so Zeugs gibt es halt da. Und dann gibt es halt auch, was auch mal wieder sehr spannend ist, ich sag jetzt mal den Feind im eigenen Laden, den man sich so einlädt. Also ich sag jetzt nicht Feind, das ist jetzt falsch. Aber es gibt ja doch Aussteller. Und bei den Ausstellern läuft es halt so, da sind dann auch sehr gerne Leute, die nicht so IT-geschult sind, sondern die haben... Affin. Die sind halt Verkäufer oder Bestandpersonal. Die kriegen halt von ihrem IT-Mann zu Hause irgendwas in die Hand gedrückt. Das steckste mal da rein, das passt schon. Und dann gibt es halt eben so Leute, die stecken da ihre Fritz-Boxen rein. Auch ein relativ bekannter Podcaster tut sowas gelegentlich.
Und machen dann DHCP auf?
Ja, da haben wir was gegen vorgesehen schon. Wir kennen ja unsere Pappenheimer.
Genau, die Make-Adresse wird da nicht mehr gevorwartet.
Ich nicht.
Aber die machen dann so einen anderen Quack. Die fangen dann an, rumzubroadcasten, oder einfach Arbre-Responses zu senden, also Fragen zum Antworten, die man ihnen gar nicht gestellt hat. Das sind so Politiker-Boxen und so. Und also Zeugs. Ich hab da diverse Fritz-Boxen einkassiert, die ich am dritten Nachmittag wieder verteilt habe. Aber ich bin da echt rumgegangen, hab die eingesammelt.
Hast du sie einfach weggenommen?
Ja, höflich. Hab ich nicht erklärt, wo das Problem ist. Hab ich den Grund gelöst, warum sie sie überhaupt mitgebracht haben. Nämlich, weil sie irgendwas zeigen wollten, was ich irgendwo einbuchen wollte. Das hab ich dann brav in unser WLAN eingebucht und hab in den Fritz-Box weggenommen. Das sind so die Sachen, die man dann so macht, so on-site.
Dann gab es noch so eine schöne Auswertung zusammen mit Open Data City, der Shreelog. Besucherstrom-Analyse per Republikar.
Schmeißt du den Link mal in den Chat?
Der ist da schon. Ich schmeiß ihn auch gleich nochmal rein, damit er nicht übersehen wird. ups.opendatacity.de ist der Shreelog und das ist eine schöne Karte von dem Gelände, was ja weitgehend sich im Erdgeschoss abspielt, bis auf die eine Halle, wo es noch einen ersten Stock gibt. Und ihr habt da im Prinzip die ganzen WLAN-Bewegungen anonymisiert, ausgewertet.
Ja, wir haben halt einfach mal geguckt, wo waren welche Access Points wie stark belastet, zu welchem Zeitpunkt, weil es ja so eine Indikation dafür gibt, wo geht das Besucherinteresse hin. Also man muss jetzt für die Leute, die nicht da waren, sagen auf dieser Grafik, dieses ganze Gelände, was dort dargestellt ist, das sind so ungefähr sagen wir mal 350 bis 400 Meter breit. Das ist also schon doch noch etwas weitläufig. Und ganz links, da wo diese große Bühne auch eingezeichnet ist, da passen so 1200, 1500 Leute rein. Und da ist es halt sehr spannend. Man sieht es sehr schön am ersten Tag morgens die Eröffnung, da sind sie dann alle da und danach verteilen sich dann die Leute sehr schnell auf die einzelnen Sessions, die dann in den anderen Vortragsälen stattfinden. Die Leute von Open Data City schreiben das auch immer neben die Vortragsäle, was da gerade lief, d.h. man kann auch so ein bisschen ablesen, was da so war. Es gibt noch einen anderen Feature, ich weiß nicht, hast du das schon entdeckt, du kannst auch Dinge markieren. Du kannst zum Beispiel hingehen auf deinen Vortrag mal scrollen, der war am zweiten Tag. Scroll mal auf den zweiten Tag, der war gleich der erste um 10. Auf Stage 2 oder so, wenn ich mich richtig ente. Ja, warte mal bis der läuft und so. Jetzt machst du mal Pause. Jetzt kringelst du mal die Leute ein, die alle bei dir sind. Mit der Maus. Die da? Das sind jetzt zu viele. Mach mal ein bisschen kleiner. So, und jetzt lässt das mal weiterlaufen. Lass los, lass weiterlaufen. Und jetzt sehen wir nämlich, wo Leute, die zu dir in deinen Vortrag gegangen sind, wo die dann noch hingehen. Also es ist jetzt sehr statistisch. Nicht jeder Punkt, der dort ist, ist halt jetzt eine Nase. Und wir haben auch explizit die Daten gleich vom Stand weg anonymisiert. Das heißt, wir können jetzt nicht sagen, das war der und der. Aber man kann trotzdem sehen, dass die Leute, die über Tim waren, ist also offensichtlich so eine Multi-Interessen-Gruppe. Das heißt, die, oder jetzt rennen sie alle auf den Hof raus. Alle Draucher.
Hängen wir aber auch mal wirkschaftlich drauf.
Man kann eben auch sehr schön, also übrigens, diese Ding ganz rechts, dieser große Raum, ist kein Raum, sondern ist der Hof. Da sind leider nur zwei Access Points, die wir dort statistisch erfasst haben, weil wir da auch nicht so viele hatten auf dem Hof.
Das wäre schön, wenn man die ganzen Gesprächsgrübchen da sozusagen auch noch mal als Dermik erfassen könnte.
Aber, Marc, da kann man auch so ein bisschen das Wetter dran ablesen, ne? Und wenn es dann regnet, werden die Kuller dann gleich ganz schnell viel kleiner. Das ist, dann müssen wir die Open-Data-City-Leute am nächsten Mal bringen, dass sie da noch für den Hof noch das aktuelle Wetter einblenden, zu dem Zeitpunkt. Aber du siehst jetzt, wo sich die Leute, die bei dir...
Kannst du denen jetzt auch die Farben geben, dass man sieht, das wäre Samsung, wer Apple und wer irgendetwas ist?
Ja, theoretisch ginge das. Haben wir aber nicht gemacht. Also das ist jetzt mal ein Experiment. Wie gesagt, das ist auch so eine spontane Kooperation gewesen, auch mit den Leuten. Weil wir das auch sehr spannend fanden, wie die immer so Sachen visualisieren. Wir haben halt Daten aufbereitet, dort zur Verfügung gestellt, in die haben die halt sozusagen diese bewegte Geschichte verwandelt.
Interessant ist, wenn ich die da jetzt markiere. Er sagte, Mac-Adressen markiert 170 oder so.
Nochmal, das sagt nicht aus, wie viele Leute da waren, sondern das sind nur die Leute, deren Gerät dann auch wirklich an war, die auch eingebucht sind, die das Netz überhaupt benutzt haben.
Ein ausgeschaltetes iPhone.
Das ist ein ausgeschaltetes iPhone.
Das seht ihr nicht.
Das ist ja ausgeschaltet.
Aber es muss sozusagen nur in dem Zeitraum, den ich jetzt da zum Markieren angezeigt habe, in dem Moment muss es gerade im Betrieb sein.
Und eingebucht. Nein, eingebucht reicht schon. Auch wenn es sozusagen in diesem Standby-Modus ist, wo du oben den Schalter betätigt hast, und das Display ist Duster, also den Normalzustand. Wie nennen wir das offiziell? In Sleep Mode? Auch in diesem Modus ist es noch eingebucht auf dem Access Point. Er muss ja weiter in seine Apple-Connection aufhalten.
Ich versuch grad die Zahl so ein bisschen relationstätig. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie viele Zuschauer ich hatte. Ich mein, es war um 10 Uhr. Es war natürlich nicht mega voll. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute da reinpassen.
Stage 2, weiß ich auch nicht aus dem Kopf.
500 vielleicht?
Nee, nee, nee, Stage 2 nicht, nee. Das ist eher so ein 200, 300-Dings-Saal.
300?
Und der war auch nicht voll.
Nee, der war zu zwei Drittel gefüllt. Der wurde dann immer voller.
Und noch mal, nicht jeder hat sein Ding auch wirklich an. Ich weiß zum Beispiel nicht, wie sich andere Telefone, die jetzt nicht dauernd diesen Pushzeug darunter liegen, da verhalten.
Also am Ende des Vortrags waren es 234.
Kommt da ganz gut hin. Ihr könnt da mal nachgucken in den Hinterlagen, wie die Bestuhlung war dafür, ob da mehr Leute drin waren. Ist das hier Edge-Land? Dann muss ich hier weg. Ja, wie gesagt, da geht noch ein bisschen was. Man kann jetzt Statistik noch mal weiter erfassen, aber irgendwann wird es dann auch zu bunt. Also wenn man das jetzt noch weiter einfärbt. Also es gibt noch andere Informationen, die man da rausziehen kann. Und zwar einfach, es ist ja wie gesagt, ich betone es nochmal, es ist komplett anonymisiert. Also man kann die einzelnen Personen dort nicht so wiederfinden, aber man kann allein durch die Masse, das ist nämlich der Spaß daran, dadurch, wenn es jetzt mal mehr als 50 oder mehr als 100 sind, kannst du halt statistische Effekte nutzen und eben Aussagen treffen, wie die Leute zum Beispiel auch so eine Geschichte da nutzen.
Kann ich jetzt mal gucken, ob die Leute, die am zweiten Tag da waren, ob die auch schon am Tag vorher da waren.
Und wo die waren.
Hier am ersten Tag gibt es so einen ganz extremen Knick. Hat der was mit Internetausfall zu tun oder was?
Wir hatten internettechnisch keine Ausfälle, bis auf den Strom, da war halt einfach alles weg. Die Leute jetzt fragen, haben wir ja keine UPS? Ja, natürlich haben wir auch eine UPS, aber das nützt endlich. Wir können nicht an jeden, die weiß, was dort breit und breites mitten in den Hallen UPS haben. Und wenn der Strom weg ist, ist er weg.
Ja, aber wodurch kommt denn dieser Knick hier zustande?
Wir hatten keine Ausfälle. Keine.
Also war jetzt nicht um 16.50 Uhr irgendwas Dramatisches? Dass ganz viele sich auf einmal ausgebucht haben.
Was macht das für einen Unterschied?
2360 auf 1270. Also schon fast eine Halbierung.
Müssen mal gucken, wo die jetzt verschwinden. Aber wir hatten, wie gesagt, keine... Wir monitoren natürlich auch selber das Netz.
Vielleicht war da was außerhalb der Veranstaltung.
Apple Push-Notification gerade dauernd.
Oder keine Ahnung, irgendwo gab es Essen umsonst außerhalb des Geländes.
Das scheint mir hier in diesem Saal da links unten ganz extrem zu sein.
Aber da passen eh bloß 100 Leute rein.
Aber da geht auf jeden Fall die Zahl signifikant zurück und auch im Hof ein bisschen. Aber es ist eigentlich überall so ein bisschen. Also es ist so rapide und wird auch... Guck mal, danach...
Was durchaus mal sein könnte, es könnte was anderes sein. Es könnte sein, dass da unsere Statistikaufzeichnung mal einen Hiccup hatte, das muss ich mal gucken.
Den Eindruck macht es, weil danach... Guck mal, da ist hier eine Normalverteilung.
Die bleibt da.
Das sieht mir nicht so aus, als ob da wirklich irgendwas passiert ist, weil am zweiten Tag müsste da ja irgendwas ähnliches zu finden sein. Dem ist nicht so... Am dritten Tag gibt es noch mal so einen ähnlichen kleinen Knick hier.
Aber kleiner.
Auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Ich meine...
Du hattest ja ein kabelgebundenes Netz dort.
Ich war sogar auf einer anderen Phase, als das, was ausgefallen ist.
Du hattest auch eine eigene Domain, hast du es eigentlich gesehen?
Domain?
Ja, ich hab extra Reverse-Mapping für dich gemacht, du Pfeife und du hast es nicht mal gesehen.
Ich hab mich über IPv6 auf meinem Rechner eingeloggt auf dem Teil und fand's geil.
Ja, und du hattest so ein Reverse-Mapping für deine V6-Adresse. Sogar für deine Tempo-V6-Adresse. Hammer.
Das war totaler Netzporn, Clemens.
Wie ich extra für dich ein Reverse-Mapping gesetzt hab.
Du hast ja über V4 den Zugang von wichtigen Ports irgendwie so ein bisschen eingeschränkt wegen den bösen Chinesen oder was?
Nee, wir haben nur das... Das ist ja ein offenes Netz und wir haben dort extra nichts Großartiges geblockt. Wir waren allerdings, seitdem wir das Netz eröffnet haben, schon ein paar Tage vorher unter intensivster Beobachtung aus dem fernen Osten. Was Gerhard Schummer sagte, das ist eine neue Qualität. Früher haben die Chinesen sich irgendwo in welche Bastionen-Hosts zusammengehackt in Amiland oder sonst wo überall auf der Welt. Inzwischen haben sie das nicht mehr nötig. Die hacken jetzt einfach direkt von ihrer Uni, offiziell Uni oder von ihrem Volksarmee-Hauptquartier in Shanghai oder sonst. Hacken sie jetzt einfach völlig offen, direkt aus China. So viel zum Thema große Firewall. Jeder Kreti und Pleti kann offenbar aus China heraus SSH-Verbindungen aufmachen. Da kann es mit der großen Firewall nicht so weit her sein. Jedenfalls haben sie ganz intensiv SSH gescannt und sie haben Screensharing gescannt. Und das waren die beiden Dinge, die wir allerdings nur von außen nach innen zugemacht haben. Sonst haben wir nichts zugemacht. Weil wir dachten, okay, es gibt so viele Leute, die haben hier ihren Rechner offen mit Screensharing an. Und das kann jetzt nicht im Sinne der User sein. Da haben wir mal eine Ausnahme gemacht, weil diese Dinge wurden wirklich intensiv durchgebürstet. Da wurde jede IP-Adresse alle paar Sekunden mal gescannt, ob da Port 22 und Port 5900 offen ist.
Wie sah es denn mit der V6-Nutzung aus?
V6-Nutzung war wieder sehr gut, wie auch schon bei vorangegangenen Events, die wir gemacht haben. Wir tragen das wieder Facetube an.
Also Facebook und YouTube, weil die voll über V6 erreichbar sind.
Das ganze Google-Universum, Facebook, YouTube, die alleine machen normalerweise beim Event diese Art und Weise über 40% des Treffings aus.
Wenn Amazon nochmal V6-fähig wäre, dann würde sich da mehr ergehen.
Oder eBay oder welche Geschichten. Da geht noch was.
Amazon wäre wichtiger wegen der ganzen Start-up-Infrastruktur.
Du meinst jetzt die nicht Amazon?
Also die EC2, S3, dieser ganze Climb-In.
Aber wie gesagt, war eine schöne Nutzung, 40% teilweise drüber und so. Also schmiegt sich schön ein. Die User merken es gar nicht, so soll es ja auch sein. Die benutzen das halt einfach. Ich glaube nicht, dass jemand absichtlich draufgeklickt hat oder irgendwelche Umwege gegangen ist, um da V6 zu benutzen. Sondern die nutzen das einfach. Und sobald so ein großer Operator das anmacht, geht es einfach. Das, was ja ein gutes Zeichen ist, weil jetzt kann man aufhören, auf den Benutzern rumzuhämmern. Jetzt muss man eben ein paar wenige Infrastrukturbetreiber mal ein bisschen auf den Kopf rumkloppen. Dann wird das auch was. Das Problem ist aber, wie gesagt, für diese Anbieter, dass die Benutzer es nicht merken. Das heißt, wenn der Anbieter ihnen sagt, jetzt haben sie auch V6, dann sahen sie dasselbe, wie mein Freund Jim als der Apple Store geöffnet hat. Und so ähnlich ist es natürlich für V6, für Zivilisten, die, ja, schön, geht.
Ja, super. Also wenn man ein tolles Netz auf tollen Events braucht, dann braucht man am besten Clemens.
Ja, da geht auch noch ein bisschen was. Für nächste Publika haben wir uns noch ein paar Spätschen vorgenommen. Da versage ich aber jetzt nichts dazu. Das muss man überlegen. Das ist jetzt ein paar Jahre lang so richtig schief gegangen. Das heißt, die Leute waren auch seitens des Veranstalters sehr, sehr vorsichtig, was das angeht und so. Wir haben jetzt natürlich einen Bonus bei denen gehabt, auch bei dem Betreiber der Location dort, um jetzt zu sagen, ok, jetzt habt ihr gesehen, wir können nicht. Wir können noch ein bisschen mehr, wollen wir mal. Und die haben jetzt natürlich auch Blut geleckt. Also wir sehen, wir machen es nächstes Jahr nochmal und dann gibt es noch ein paar Features. Nächstes Jahr gibt es Features, wo du dich dann fragst, wie konnte ich die letzten 30 Jahre ohne leben. Ja, nächstes Jahr. Chapter Marker.
Chapter Marker. So, durchatmen.
Was ist eigentlich aus diesem tollen Raumschiff geworden, diesen Chapter Marker?
Ach so, ja, der kommt gerade nicht zum Einsatz. Das hat alles Gründe. Aber die erkläre ich jetzt nicht.
Früher war alles besser.
Jetzt machen wir mal mit was weiter hier mit Dennis.
Millionär?
Das war mal vor zwei, drei Folgen. Wo ist denn der Kurs?
Der Kurs ist eigentlich stabil.
Der ist stabil, der ist bei 101,8 Grad. Und diese Liberty-Resource-Sache hat, ja, das ist noch nicht so klar, ob das jetzt das Bitcoin pusht oder ob das für Bitcoins eher negativ ausfällt. Aber bisher, der Kurs ändert sich nicht. Das heißt, das interessiert anscheinend nicht.
Die Geschichte kannst du vielleicht mal kurz erwähnen. Das ist ja auch recht frisch noch, ne?
Mit dem Liberty Reserve. Ich hab das gar nicht so genau durchgelesen.
Was ist denn Liberty Reserve? Das kenn ich gar nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich bin ja nicht im Untergrund.
Na, ist das so undergroundig oder was?
Ja, scheint ja. Ich meine, wenn die da 6 Milliarden Dollar irgendwie reinwaschen, ist jetzt nicht so die kleine Summe, oder?
Ja, aber war das auch Bitcoin-basiert?
Nein, nein, überhaupt gar nicht. Es war irgendwie, keine Ahnung, etwas virtuell anderes. Irgendeine Scheine, nicht Scheine, aber irgendeine Währung anscheinend, diese über irgendein...
Irgendein Money-Transfer.
Irgendeine 50 Quadratmeter-Insel, wo sie irgendwie eine Bank haben, wo sie dann irgendwie ihre Deals machen. Keine Ahnung, ich hab's mir nicht durchgelesen. Aber fanden sie wohl nicht gut und haben sie gesagt, ist Schluss und vorbei und ist aus.
Ja, aber so Bitcoin läuft. Ich hab jetzt auch mal was verkauft.
Doch schon, ja.
Ja, nur so geringe Mengen, nur um mal was verkauft zu haben, für den Fall, dass es mal wieder einen Moment gibt, wo man vielleicht wirklich mal was verkaufen will.
Ja, also so eine Art Testballon.
Letztes Mal hätte ich sozusagen so schnell gar nicht reagieren können, bzw. hab ich ja auch nicht. Und hab jetzt einfach mal so ein paar Verkaufsoptionen für Bruchteile von Bitcoins mit irgendwie so Zielen, sowas weiß ich hier. Verkauf mal eins, wenn 120 Euro zu holen sind und sowas.
Also hast du den doch noch nicht verkauft, sondern es würde passieren, wenn der Kurs hochsteigt.
Bei dem jetzt, ja genau. Keinere andere Sachen sind schon weggegangen.
Und wo bist du bei Mt.
Gox? Ja, weil da gibt's irgendwie, da ist ja immer viel los und sie haben dieses Two-Factor Authentication mit dem schicken Tool, was Clemens neulich empfohlen hat. Hier dieses HDI, OTP, genau, also standardisierte One-Time-Password. Was ich ja total schade finde, ist, dass ja Apple hat ja jetzt Two-Factor Authentication eingeführt.
Natürlich wieder nicht standardisiert.
Natürlich mit SMS. Und wer war der andere? Wer war denn der andere, der noch SMS gemacht hat?
Ja, aber Google benutzt auch TOTP. Deswegen gibt es ja den Google Authentication, der TOTP macht.
Kein Facebook. Wer war denn der andere, der das gerade noch eingeführt hat? Nicht Apple, sondern... Ah ja, genau, Twitter war es.
Richtig.
Und die machen es auch mit SMS, was ich ein bisschen beknackt finde, weil dann kannst du es halt nur, in Anführungsstrichen, mit einem Telefon machen, was auch...
Was auch eine bestimmte SIM-Karte drin hat.
Ja, du kannst halt, wenn du kein Telefon hast, wenn du zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, hat irgendjemand auch kein Telefon, aber kann ja mal sein, dass du irgendwie keins hast oder haben willst.
Dann hast du einfach keine Two-Factor-Authentication. Das ist doch scheiße. Das ist genauso für die Leute, die keine Hände haben und das TOTP-Ding nicht benutzen können, die haben halt keine Two-Factor-Authentication. Das war jetzt zwar böse, aber das ist so. Wenn du was nicht hast, dann geht das nicht.
Ja, aber SMS find ich immer sehr fragwürdig. Ich merkte das immer beim Online-Banking, weil da hätte ich auch gerne mal dieses OTP. Dafür wär's auch super. Weil ich hab's immer mal wieder, wenn ich was überweise, und zwar es muss jetzt ganz wichtig raus, sonst Ärger. Und dann kommt dieses scheiß SMS einfach nicht. Vielleicht kommt's ja so eine halbe Stunde später oder eine Stunde oder irgendwas.
Dann hat diese Webseite dich aber schon längst wieder ausgelöst.
Ja, aber dann muss ich schon irgendwie raus aus dem Haus hinzukriegen, keine Ahnung. Und das Ticket wurde nicht rechtzeitig bezahlt, so die Nummer. Find ich einfach blöd. Und früher hab ich mich immer gegen diese blöden Dongles, die ja letztlich genau das gleiche gemacht haben, eigentlich immer gewehrt. Weil, naja, die muss ja immer dabei haben.
Phone hast du dir immer dabei.
Hier geht das Gerücht, Apple habe das wieder abgeschaltet, davon weiß ich nichts.
Doch, für deutscher Konzert hab ich auch gelesen.
Warum?
Ich glaube aber einfach nur technische Probleme, also nicht, weil jetzt mit der Grundidee irgendwas Probleme hat.
Wahrscheinlich wollte die Telekom zu viel Geld für die SMS haben.
Die denken immer noch in ernsthaften Centbeträgen. Darüber nach. Selbst wenn du Apple bist. In den USA kostet diese Texting nichts mehr. Für so einen Operator. Deswegen bietet auch Google bei jedem Scheiß an und immer. Aber hier in Deutschland kannst du immer noch, selbst wenn du die SMS hochkaufst, Ich denke mal...
Twitter war mal am Anfang über SMS. Deswegen sind es 140 Zeichen.
Aber du kannst immer noch, sind zwar einstellig Centbeträge inzwischen, aber die musst du eben auch hochrechnen. Ich weiß nicht, wenn du es so richtig grob kaufst, dann kostest du immer noch 2-3 Cent die SMS. Und dann musst du natürlich überlegen, was du da machst.
Ja, das ist albern. Die sollen mal ruhig hier alle OTP machen für die Leute, die Planen haben. Die machen das dann halt so. Und die anderen, die können halt meinetwegen...
Es wäre schön, wenn die Leute sagen, okay, das erkennen wir an als Standard und nutzen es auch wirklich, dass jetzt nicht jeder sein Süppchen kocht. Das ist die größte Gefahr, die ich sehe. Es werden in Zukunft mehr Leute auf diese Two-Factor-Authentication aufspringen. Aber viele Leute werden sich das schon aufgrund aus Marketinggründen schon nicht nehmen lassen, wieder den Usern eigene Apps dafür aufzunötigen. Nur damit ihr eine Drecksloge auf dem Bildschirm steht, während das die Zahl anzeigt. Das sage ich vorher und das finde ich sehr traurig.
Am Ende schadet es ja auch nichts, wenn sie einfach Beides anbieten. Hauptsache, das ordentliche ist dabei.
Bei World of Warcraft gab es ja so eine App mit diesem Zeitcode. Oder du konntest dir bei deren Shop, die hatten ja auch so einen Shop, für 6 Euro relativ billig so ein kleines Teil holen mit so einem Display. Du kannst den Knopf drücken und dann kam da der Code.
Ja, das ist wie gesagt der Hardware-Dongel.
Ja, ist sozusagen so richtig, den du dann auch zur Not zu Hause liegen lassen kannst und so, dass du den gar nicht mit dabei hast. Dann kann da auch nichts passieren.
Kann man mal bitte was erfinden, dass der ganze Scheiß nicht mehr nötig ist? Nee, nicht unbedingt, aber sorry, allein das mit dem SMS finde ich schon nervig. Das ist auch nervig.
Ja, aber so mit dem OTP finde ich irgendwie ganz okay.
Hier, sowas gibt es übrigens auch nochmal ganz furchtbar. Nennt sich RSA-Seekur-ID.
Ja, das ist das, was du früher als Dongel an deinem Schlüsselbund hattest. Da haben wir übrigens mal lustige Sachen für gemacht. Wir haben mal folgendes gemacht in einer Firma, weil du kriegst dann, wenn du dann so Remote-Support machst beim Kunden, dann kriegst du irgendwie diese Dinger übergeholfen und die glauben wirklich, dass jeder Supporter in so einer Firma mit 20 von diesen Dingern für jeden Kunden an seinem Schlüsselbund persönlich rumläuft. Das haben wir natürlich nicht gemacht, sondern die lagen alle schön in einer Firma auf dem Tisch mit einer Webcam davor. Damit der jeweilige Supporter der Dienst hat, diese Dinger ablesen kann. Na ja, was willst du machen?
So, Dennis, aber eigentlich wollte ich ja, versuch dich ja gerade dir dein Thema überzuhelfen.
Nämlich dein Thema ist...
Na, ich hab mich in letzter Zeit mal, ich habe erhöhten Kommunikationsbedarf.
Oh, jung, hütsch will ich.
Erhöhter Kommunikationsbedarf.
Und dachte mir ja hier, die andere Seite hat kein iPhone, also iMessages fallen schon mal aus. Fasetime auch? SMS ist zu teuer, Fasetime fällt auch aus. So WhatsApp fällt aus ideologischen Gründen aus. Und was kommt dann? Da hab ich mir das hier geguckt, alles klar, erst als ich gefunden hab, war so ein Ding, das heißt Secure Chat oder Chat Secure, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, ich muss schnell gucken.
Was ist denn mit dem guten alten Jabber?
Ja, dieses Chat Secure kann Jabber, mit OTR, mit so richtig kannst du verifinern und so, den Fingerprint, das geht alles. Und die App ist kostenlos und open source, aber schön ist sie nicht. Also es ist schade.
Und sie heißt?
Chat Secure. Genau, aber es ist halt, ja okay, man könnte sagen, ja ist ja open source, kannste ja heransetzen, kannste ein bisschen kohlen und so, ja und könnte ich auch machen. Vielleicht mach ich es ja auch eines Tages, glaub ich aber nicht mehr, weil ich hab was besseres gefunden. Und zwar gibt es eine App, die heißt, die war auch zufällig gestern, kam mir sehr gelegen, bei Heise glaube ich, oder was vorgestern, die heißt Streamer, also 3mr, also auch geschrieben, und ist von einem Programmierer aus der Schweiz, ich weiß nicht, ob er ein Mann wurde, ob er auch mehr arbeitet, irgendwie, und der hat das programmiert und das ist auch crypto-based, das ist sozusagen wie WhatsApp, nur mit ordentlich asynchronen Krypto.
Aber proprietäre Chat-Geschichte drunter? Aber proprietärer Chat-Geschichte. Das heißt, er betreibt auch seinen eigenen Server dafür?
Er betreibt seinen eigenen Server und im Falle von iPhone, ich weiß nicht, wie es für Android ist, weil jetzt gibt es auch eine andere Android-Version.
Der Service steht dann auch in der Schweiz, oder?
So sieht es aus und er supportet auch Push-Notifications. Das heißt, du musst die App auch nicht am Laufen haben, weil irgendwann gehen dir auch mal in den Hintergrund und irgendwann, wenn der Speicher leer ist, werden die auch abgeschossen, und dann würdest du ja nichts mehr mitkriegen, aber nee, er hat halt Push-Notifications, das heißt, das macht er und dann siehst du, dass dann eine Nachricht vorliegt.
Und wie finanziert er seine Geschichte?
Die App kostet 1,79 oder sowas. Zwei Apple-Einheiten halt.
Tire 2, wie es so schön heißt.
Was heißt das?
Tier. Es gibt so Preiselevel.
Ach so, Tier. Tier, genau. Hast du nicht Quake gespielt oder was? Tier 1. Da war mal dieses Anfangsvideo.
Aber noch mal.
Das war nach meiner Zeit.
Das ist proprietäre Kacke, was auf irgendeinem proprietären Server von irgendeinem proprietären Schweizer in irgendeiner proprietären Schweiz läuft.
Okay, dann nennen wir mal ein Beispiel von nicht-proprietär.
Kannst du dein eigenes Server drunter stöpseln oder auch nicht oder so?
Ja, ich bin ja noch für...
Was?
Die funktioniert nur so.
Wie gesagt, dieses Scherz-EQ kann Java mit Krypto, aber die App ist halt nicht so schick.
Ich hab die nicht gefunden, ja. Ich hab hier ganz viele von meinen Freunden schon gefunden, aber du bist nicht dabei, mein Freund.
Wobei bei Streamer? Ja, kann ich dir auch sagen, warum, weil ich hab mich da nicht gepublished, sondern ich kann dir ganz top secret, so an der Account, da irgendwie meine ID rüberschieben. Natürlich findet man mich da nicht.
Nicht.
Alter, wie lange bin ich jetzt schon in diesem Club?
Daher mit deinem Scheiß-QR-Kurs.
Ich hab das Paranoia mit deinem Babymilch aufgesogen.
Ja, ich weiß.
Und sein zweiter Vorname ist...
Ich? Ich bin nicht so paranoid.
Dennis Aluhut.
Ach so, und das Schicke ist, man muss jetzt nicht irgendwelche ID's rumreißen, sondern ich hab jetzt hier einen Schirm, da ist ein QR-Code und dann hat der Timme, weil jetzt sozusagen physikalisch sein iPhone sich mit meinem, die haben gerade eine Paarung gemacht hier. Genau. Und da wird bei ihm jetzt auch angezeigt, dass es jetzt ultra secure ist, weil er wirklich nicht nur meine ID hat, sondern auch noch den passenden Fingerprint. Und da kann sich jetzt keiner mehr dazwischen Dingsen und Men in the Middle machen. Wir können jetzt hier richtig Safer Sex machen.
Ja, und es wird sogar angezeigt.
Nee, auch nicht.
Dennis Aluhut Arendt. Woher weißt du nicht, dass dein Schweizer da nicht...
Er könnte mir natürlich, wenn das jetzt das Programm fuscht, mir eine andere Key unterschieben und dann kann er natürlich alles machen.
Er kann es auch einfach im Klartext irgendwie ansehen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, hier ist sogar eine Anleitung dabei, wie du alle Sachen, die rausgehst, die rausgehen, wie du die selber sehen kannst, dass die Verschlüsselung stimmt und bei ihm auch wieder einfliegt.
Mach das Programm selber, schreib dir hin.
Du kannst hier irgendwo klicken, wo bei Advanced war es, glaube ich. Warte mal, wo war das? Gibt es irgendwo so eine Anleitung, wo so beschrieben wird, dass du dafür den Code runterladen musst, weil er benutzt halt so eine Lapti. Das musst du dir runterladen. Dann gibt es einen Command Line Tool und deine Daten, die hier rausfallen, fütterst du so rein, was du ja auch theoretisch aus dem TCP-Dump ziehen könntest. Und dann siehst du, dass es irgendwie für Timme ist und von dir usw. Die haben das schon ein bisschen richtig gemacht. Und jetzt habe ich da noch ein kurzes Interview. Der hat nämlich unter unserem Freund von Die Wahrheit, wie heißt er? Markus Richter. Markus Richter, der hatte den nämlich mal bei seinem Podcast irgendwie in einem Interview mit dem Thorsten Schröder. Der ist ja auch bekannt, ne? Genau. Und da haben sie mal so eine 1-Stunden-Sendung mit dem gemacht und ihn ein bisschen ausgefragt und hier und da usw. Und davon haue ich jetzt mal kurz den Link in unseren Chat.
Also ich möchte trotzdem noch mal anprangern, dass das proprietär ist. Weil jetzt steht und fällt alles mit dem Betrieb von diesem Server. Nehmen wir mal an, dass der Typ jetzt nicht evil ist.
Aber du hast recht.
Aber es stehen irgendwann irgendwelche Beamten hinter ihm, nicht wahr? Und sagen, möchten sie diesen Server vielleicht einmal abschalten, bitte schön? Weil irgendjemand irgendwelche Hakenkreuze, sonst irgendwas darüber verstreut hat oder Bankgeheimnisse oder sonst irgendwas. Und dann stehst du im Ring. Deswegen finde ich solche proprietären Lösungen nicht so...
Man muss sich ja nicht gleich drauf verlassen.
Warum nimmt er nicht XMPP drunter, du darfst deinen eigenen Server benutzen.
Du hast ja recht, wenn sie sozusagen sein Ding ausmachen, dann ist es aus. Das hast du bei Jabba nicht, weil es ist ein bisschen mehr dezentral, aber da können die natürlich direkt auch zu deinem Server hinfahren.
Aber der ganze Dienst steht und fällt dadurch, dass es proprietär ist. Es kann keine Mac abgeben oder keine Android ab, wenn der Typ sie nicht macht. Und der ganze Dienst steht und fällt ausschließlich damit, dass der Typ seinen Server betreibt. Tolles Geschäftsmodell, halte ich aber jetzt für...
Jetzt spacken wir halt ein bisschen in sicher.
Hier ist der Protokoll-Standardisierer.
Du hast vielleicht recht, aber...
Ach nee, jetzt wäre hier gegenseitig promiskuitiv QR-Codes ausgetauscht. Hier findet offener QR-Sex statt.
Ja, aber sowas von...
Komm, Roddy, komm. Ah ja, super. Willst du meinen auch scannen?
So, wir scannen uns hier gerade gegenseitig. Warum muss man das in beide Richtungen?
Das ist voll doof. Weil deine Kamera nur in eine Richtung geht.
Weiter weg, weiter weg. Kontakt verbunden.
Weiter weg, Roddy.
Hier, komm, nimm mich auch noch.
So, aber das... Aber das Problem bei den Jabber-Dingern ist, dass wir ja grundsätzlich, dann ist noch dein Telefon angreifbar und deine Jabber-App passt auch nicht reverse-ingeniert oder dir audited und so. Das heißt, da musst du dich ja auch schon auf andere Leute verlassen.
Aber du kannst trotzdem deine eigene Server-Infrastruktur benutzen und sie austauschen.
Das schon, ja. Du hast nicht so den Single-Point-Of-Failure-Meinsein.
Und nebenbei, für alle die Leute, die glauben, dass Jabber auf dem iPhone schwierig ist, ist das genau das, was Apple für ihren Push-Track benutzt.
Ich hätte da noch eine grundsätzliche Frage, bitte. Über was redet ihr mit so einem Programm dann? Also was verschickt ihr dann?
Normale Nachricht.
Kommst du runter? Bist du gleich da? Wo bleibst du? Ich warte. Pizza-Württigkeit.
Und deswegen jetzt die Diskussion, wie sicher das Ganze sein muss.
Naja, wir schicken ja vielleicht auch andere Sachen.
Das war meine Frage.
Schickt ihr auch andere Sachen, die wirklich...
Ich schick da zum Beispiel, wie kriege ich meine Bitcoins irgendwie ohne Steuer in meinen Portemonnaie? Zum Beispiel.
Das hat er gerade geschrieben. Die gerade mit den USA ein Abkommen geschlossen haben, dass sie ihre ganzen Daten auflegen. Das macht Sinn. Alles klar.
Also ich muss sagen, jetzt ein kurzer Test dieser Software. Ich sollte vielleicht auch mal eine Nachricht verschicken.
Und wenn du halt schon nur Verschlüsselung machst, damit ich deinen Tisch nachbeim Club oder auf der Republika damit du nicht mit hochrotem Kopf wie der Sascha Lobo in der Ecke sitzt und alle deine Passwörter neu machen musst. Es geht ja nur darum, dass du dir das Embarrassment erspaarst.
Auch. Ja, also vernünftig ist es auch einer der Gründe einer meiner Kollegen. Wir haben ja natürlich im Vorfeld dort intensiv Diskussionen darüber gesprochen, ob mit dem Veranstalter verschlüsseln wir das oder nicht. Und der sagte aber, nee, wir wollen hier auch einen gewissen Erziehungseffekt machen. Wer das immer noch macht, auf einem offenen WLAN, und wir sind ja damit nur, weiß Gott, nicht die Einzigen, irgendwie unverschlüsselte Pop3 zu benutzen oder so weit, der soll halt damit leben, dass sein Passwort drei Sekunden später an der Twitter-Wall steht.
Zumindest gibt es jetzt auch mal Avatarer und man sieht mal richtig, warum macht iMessage das nicht?
Und vor allem sieht es einfach schick aus, weil dieses Chat-Secure ist einfach nicht schick.
Ja, man kann sogar cheesy Hintergründe machen, wie bei WhatsApp.
Du musst dein Nickname noch setzen, sonst heißt er hier so, wie du heißt, nämlich so.
Ich hab mein Nickname gesetzt.
Und noch ein Chatprogramm, ich hab eh schon zu viele davon. Sonst würde ich jetzt einfach mal klicken, aber das geht jetzt nicht.
Ich hab jetzt mit meinem Kontakt auf deine Dix.
Nee, guck mal, du kannst doch hier irgendwo bei My ID ganz unten hier, guck da, Public Nickname, den musst du mal setzen.
Was ist eigentlich aus Glassboard geworden?
Das gibt's glaub ich noch.
Benutzt das irgendjemand?
Ich hab den geändert.
Deswegen frag ich ja, was ist eigentlich aus Glassboard geworden?
Das Problem mit Glassboard war, dass es glaub ich kostenlos war, ne?
Nee.
Glassboard war doch kostenlos oder nicht?
Das Programm?
Ich glaube schon.
Hier steht es als kostenlos.
Ja, echt?
Ich meine, das war schon immer kostenlos. Ich glaub, das war das Problem. Oder behaupte ich jetzt mal.
Ja, das ist ein Problem, wenn sie nicht... Bitte warten sie 30 Minuten auf die SMS.
Sagt wer?
Achso, die haben ja irgendwie noch so eine SMS bestätigt und dann kannst du deinen Account mit deiner Telefonnummer linken oder irgendwie so. Aber ich will das ja gar nicht. Ich will ja nur mit ID und so. Warum hab ich dich jetzt hier bei mir nicht drin? Hast du mir noch nichts gesendet oder was?
Ich hab dir noch nichts gesendet, nein.
Na dann sende ich dir jetzt mal was. Kann ich das überhaupt? Ich hab dich gar nicht hier irgendwie. Wozu haben wir denn uns ausgetauscht, bitte?
So, jetzt alles verknüpft.
Also den Roddy hab ich hier irgendwie bei mir nicht. Doch, da ist jetzt was.
Voll unterhaltsamer Podcast hier.
So ja, genau. Nächstes Thema.
Ja, finde ich gut. Was ich noch sagen wollte zu der App, die ist ordentlich gemacht, die sieht gut aus, die verhält sich wie eine iOS-App, da gibt es nichts dran zu meckern. Also finde ich mal eine echt gute Idee und vor allem gut umgesetzt.
Aber es ist noch rot, Roddy, wir sind noch nicht so richtig safer sexier. Das ist irgendwie noch nicht konfirmt. Wir müssen noch mal... Das heißt, ich muss dich noch mal kurz abdenken. Ja, aber warum bist du denn rot? Lowest certification level. There is no guarantee that this person is who they claim they are. Also wir reden von dir sogar in einer Mehrzahl.
Also ihr wisst nicht, ich weiß nicht, dass ihr seid, wer ihr seid.
Eure Majestät. Eure Majestät.
Wo kann ich das jetzt mal hinten anheben?
Wir müssen auch über uptown.net reden. Ich sag euch doch warum. Und zwar müssen wir über uptown.net reden, weil wir sowieso immer über uptown.net reden müssen. Und ich mach das auch deshalb, weil du Michael nämlich auch einen Client geschrieben hast für den Mac. Zumindest hast du damit angefangen, aber irgendwie hast du nicht weitergemacht, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Oder gibt es das irgendwo verboren? Ich hatte, doof wie ich war oder nein, wie auch immer, ich hatte verkündet, wenn er sein Geld zusammenkriegt, dass ich eine App schreibe für den Mac. Weil ich von ausgegangen bin, dass alle sich nur auf iOS stürzen und keiner was für den Mac schreibt. Das hab ich dann auch gemacht und dann haben ganz viele was für den Mac geschrieben und dann kamen die Tabbots. Und ich bin von ausgegangen, dass die dann auch irgendwann, eigentlich ist es ja relativ einfach, ihr Mac-App auch dann für app.net umzuwandeln. Das ist, glaub ich, eine Sache von zwei Wochen. So weit, wie wir das haben. Oder lass es drei Wochen sein.
So, oder wir haben es schon mindestens...
Haben sie nicht gemacht. Das war die eine Sache, wo ich es dann erstmal auf Halt gestellt hab. Das war fertig, es funktionierte. Für den Teil, was für der API da war, als ich dann aufgehört hab, dran zu arbeiten. Die haben mittlerweile ihre API umgestellt, es sind neue Dinge hinzugekommen. Und gibt's eigentlich neue App.net-User?
Neue?
Ja.
Wie neue?
Naja, sind's mehr als 30.000 mittlerweile?
Ja, über 100.
Sind's mittlerweile über 100. Also, die lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, im Moment muss ich erst mal Rechnung zahlen können und ich werde irgendwann auch wieder weiter dran bauen. Wenn ich's nur für mich selber benutze.
Ja, es ist halt interessanterweise, gibt's ja da wirklich, äh, eigentlich, ey, da nimmt man Restbier mit. Ich will ein neues, aber deswegen muss ja das alte nicht gleich weggießen.
Wie man trinkt Bodensatz?
Ich guck grad mal, wie viele User wir gerade haben. Ja, 109.773. Also registrierte User ist einschließlich der free User. Wie viel davon bezahlen, keine Ahnung. Aber es gibt immer noch so einen konstanten Flow. 30.000 schon eine Weile her.
Ja, das war so mein letzter Stand.
Aber du benutzt es, ne? Du bist ja da auch ansprechbar.
Ja, im Moment leider nur über das doof Web-Interface, weil mein Programm halt nicht funktioniert.
Achso, und du benutzt aus Prinzip nur deine eigenen?
Also wer noch auf der Suche sein sollte, von allen, die ich mir angeguckt hab, ist Kiwi, glaube ich, noch das, was momentan am besten zu benutzen ist. Also ich hab's auch schon empfohlen auf meiner Webseite.
Ja, Kiwi, also es ist nicht ohne Mangel. Es bedarf wirklich der Weiterarbeit. Aber ich glaube, der Autor hatte auch irgendwie ein paar Probleme, war krank oder irgendwas. Keine Ahnung. Ich benutze es auch, aber es taugt halt nur für ein Ding. Es gibt auch eine App für Multi-User, die ich allerdings etwas skurril finde. Also die ist so ein bisschen, hm, arbeitet so ein bisschen mehr wie so Tweet-Deck. Die heißt cauldron. C-A-U-L-Dron. Und hat aber eigentlich dieses recht zukunftsweisende Konzept der, wie nennt man denn das?
Multiplen Teilleins.
Ja, also erstmal ist es Multi-User. Also du kannst da sozusagen alle Accounts unterbringen. Und umschalten. Vom User-Interface finde ich das so ein bisschen so, hm, ist mir ein bisschen zu schwarz alles und ein bisschen zu viel Platz verschwendet für Sachen, die immer wiederkommen. Was weiß ich hier, so Reply und Starry-Post und so weiter. Das muss nicht überall nochmal stehen. Das kann man auch einblenden, wenn man da hingeht. Aber auf jeden Fall hat man hier überhaupt erstmal die Möglichkeit für einen Account mehrere Timelines sich anzuschauen. Also der normale Stream, die normale Timeline, die Mentions, private Nachrichten, private Channels, also irgendwelche Diskurse mit Leuten. Oder eben auch nur die Liste der Follower, die man gerade hat.
Oder eben auch diese kleine Null da oben. Die Sachen, die du jetzt gerade nicht gesehen hast.
Wie viele da jetzt gerade neu sind.
Das heißt, man sieht auch die neuen Follower scrollen. Ich hab jetzt mit ADN längst meine Twitter-Anzahl gerissen. Das magst du ja immer gerne hören. Ich bin jetzt sozusagen bei ADN weit vor Twitter.
Du hast jetzt mehr Follower auf ADN als auf Twitter. Soweit bin ich jetzt noch nicht. Aber, ähm, ja. Also Caldron ist dann ganz gut, wenn man jetzt wirklich mal die Aktivität mehrerer Accounts so übersehen kann.
Der Typ mit dem britischen Pass sagt Caldron, das gefällt mir. Lies mal Harry Potter, da guck dir mal Harry Potter an.
Ja, ich hab's jetzt so ausgesprochen, damit Deutsche das verstehen.
Ist klar.
Wie spricht man es denn aus?
Hexenkessel.
Wenn's Englisch ist, Caldron. Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwie mal wirklich mich bemühe, in einen englischen Slang zu verfallen, das ist auch nicht geil. Gelingt mir aber auch mittlerweile nicht mehr. Ich hatte wirklich mal einen schönen Englisch-Sprech drauf, aber das ist mir leider komplett versaut worden. Mit der Zeit. Aber...
Hier in Schwäbisch-Berlin, ja.
Noch mal zurück zu dem Programm oder generell. Gibt es Menschen mit mehreren App.net-Accounts?
Ich hab eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht.
Ich formuliere die Frage um. Gibt es normale Menschen, die mehr als einen App.net-Account haben?
Podcaster, die dann für ihr Projekt auch noch einen Account haben.
Oder Leute, die für ihre Firma da immer wieder einen mitbetreuen.
Ja, da gibt es schon viele Gründe.
Ich hätte es mir gern gespart, wenn ich jetzt weiter arbeite. Gespart?
Ich finde gerade auf Mac ist Multi-User absolut das Muss. Also gerade auf Mac will man in der Lage sein, volle Verwaltungen vorzunehmen und nicht nur eine Timeline zu lesen wie auf iOS. Das ist das, was mich an diesen Mac-Clients, auch für Twitter, total stört, dass die eigentlich völlig auf die persönliche Timeline fokussiert sind, aber dieses ganze Administrative, was eigentlich mit so einem Social Media-Interaktion verbunden ist, komplett außen vor lassen.
Das sind ja alles bemische Dörfer für mich, ich bin ja so unsozial.
Gut, daran kann ich natürlich wenig ändern, aber für mich ist das natürlich schon nicht ganz unerheblich.
Also jetzt nur für mich zu mitnehmen, also mehrere Benutzer auf web.net.
Wo gab's jetzt das hier, diese Courten, ist das App Store oder wo kommt das her?
Na du findest ja alles unter alpha. directory.app.net. cauldronapp.net suchst du, findest du. Das ist irgendein komisches Domain, das ich gerade nicht ausfindig weiß. Ja, du kannst hier auch so Workspaces machen.
Also bis auf die Oberfläche finde ich das gar nicht mal schlecht.
Ja, die Oberfläche ist so ein bisschen so hmmm. Und ja, doch so Picture-Preview. Also es ist jetzt nicht blöd. Ich stelle gerade fest, dass es in weiß deutlich besser funktioniert als in schwarz.
Da erkennt man wenigstens was.
Ja, so.
Aber ich meine, jetzt könnte ich hier zum Beispiel das so mitlaufen lassen hier für den Mobamex-Account. Und dann hätten wir halt hier irgendwie das Feedback. Globale Stream kann mich mal.
Und Performance sieht auch mal ein Multiplattform-Ding, was ich ja mal ganz erstaunlich finde.
Dass es dann trotzdem noch halbwegs aussieht? Hier auch Interactions werden aufgelistet, also was ist passiert, jemand hat...
Das finde ich ja bei Appdeutmit immer noch am sinnigsten. Also ich würde das ja zum Startbildschirm machen. Also ich habe mir überlegt, das zum Startding zu machen.
Was?
Interactions, da funktioniert es wirklich.
Weil man die Daten kriegt, meinst du, vom Netzwerk. Ja, also das ist schon alles irgendwie ganz fancy. Trotzdem, Kiwi ist auf dem Mac so für das normale Working noch ein bisschen eleganter, aber an sich, da gibt es noch eine Menge zu holen. Da ist der letzte Drops noch nicht gelutscht und auch dieses Tweetbot, also wenn das als Netbot für Mac kommt, das wird mich auch nicht zacken. Also das benutze ich irgendwie nicht, solange es noch Echo-Phones gibt.
Mir war das Tweetbot ja auch einfach viel zu teuer. Ich habe zwar die ganzen Betas mitgenommen, aber irgendwie dann, was wollen die, 30 Euro oder so? 20 Dollar.
Das haben wir vor zwei Jahren noch, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, für Programm abgezahlt. Mittlerweile, Michael war dran.
Aber dafür, dass ich Twitter eigentlich fast nicht mehr benutze.
Ja, das war mein Problem. Mein Problem, genau das ist es. Das Problem war nicht, das war das erste, was ich gesagt habe, ich habe kein Problem damit, den Tapbots 20 Dollar zu geben. Aber 20 Dollar für Twitter? Da war die Überlegung.
Naja, es gibt so andere Programme wie One Password. Das hatten wir ja vorhin. Da würde ich dann nicht mit der Wimper zucken. Mit der Zimper wucken. Wenn ich jetzt höre, dass One Password 4 draußen ist, dann bezahle ich das einfach, ohne es überhaupt ausprobiert zu haben. Dann wird nicht mit der Zimper gewuppt. Und andere, bei Alfred war das ja das gleiche irgendwie. Einfach zack, gib mir Update.
Ja klar, da gibt es eine Menge Ups bei denen das so ist.
Shut up and take my money.
Genau.
Ja, ich bin aber heutzutage schon immer so ein bisschen enttäuscht. So neue Arpen, sowas wie, die ist kostenlos. Kann man nicht mit rechten Dingen zugehen. Da bin ich irgendwie ganz anders als das, was so häufig beklagt wird, was wir auch hier eingangs schon versucht haben zu diskutieren.
Ja, aber wenn man die ersten 200 kostenlosen Apps durchprobiert hat, dann merkt man irgendwann, ja.
Ja, das sind auch so Sachen, die fehlen mir noch irgendwie. Such bitte in diesem Store, aber nichts, was kostenlos ist und so.
Das Problem ist ja, Apple wird es ja nicht zulassen. Ich würde ja so gerne eine gescheite App bauen, in der man Dinge ordentlich finden kann.
Ne, ne, das geht ja nicht.
Das geht ja nicht.
Und die außerhalb bringt wieder, weil sie dann wieder keiner findet.
Ja, also entgegen der Vermutung einiger, ab.net gibt es noch und bleibt auch nach wie vor interessant. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall total spannend. Wo wir gerade so bei Apps sind, Instacast ist jetzt irgendwie released worden in Version 1.0 und kann jetzt gekauft werden. Und wer Podcasts auf seinem Mac hört und iTunes schon immer gehasst hat, könnte hier durchaus glücklich werden, finde ich. Haben wir ja letztes Mal schon ein bisschen drüber gesprochen. Müssen wir jetzt gar nicht viel weiter zu sagen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall auch so eine Software, wo man mal Geld fallen lassen kann. Und ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig sehe, gab es ja nicht gerade so eine Early Bird Offer. Ich glaube, wenn man da jetzt gerade mal zuschlägt, dann ist irgendwie billiger.
Wo stimmt denn das?
Find ich grad nicht. Find ich nicht.
Hab irgendwas mit irgendwie bis zum 31.05. billiger oder täusche ich mich gerade?
Ja, ja doch, da war was irgendwie.
Da war was, aber ich find's grad nicht. Vielleicht wird's der Chat irgendwie noch ein bisschen erfolgreicher.
Teamwechsel.
Sprich.
Ja, bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei Mac. Abster hat sich was getan und zwar, auch wenn ich gerade...
Ja, also momentan für 14,99 Dollar.
Genau, 15 statt 20. Sowas war's, okay. Ja, wer auch noch nachgelegt hat, ist die Omni Group. Ich hoffe, dass irgendjemand von euch das auch noch mitbekommen hat, weil ich bin noch etwas verwirrt von dem neuen Angebot. Ja, Cloud kann man nicht so richtig sagen. Also sie haben jetzt ein Produkt rausgebracht, was einfach geil benannt ist. Das heißt einfach Omnipresence.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es eher so eine Art Dropbox für ihre Ups, was das Syncing der Ups ermöglicht. Man installiert sich da was auf dem Mac. Ich hab's noch nicht getestet, weil sie es testen wollte. Wollte ich es auf dem Rechner testen, der noch 10.7 hat und es sitzt leider 10.8 voraus. Und deswegen hab ich es dann nicht getestet. Aber sie versprechen damit auch Syncing für Omni-Outliner, was natürlich sehr interessant ist. Ein Outliner mit Desktop-Software, die synkt. Aber eben auch ihren ganzen anderen Sachen. Also einen Omni-Fokus hat sie das glaube ich schon drin.
Das Schöne ist ja, du kannst es auf deinen eigenen Server laden, Thorsten.
Genau, das ist nämlich schon da auch immer ihr Prinzip gewesen. Also sie haben ja auch ihren eigenen Syncing-Dienst, dieses Omni-Sync, was dazu quasi kompatibel ist. Und Omni-Presence ist dann eben dieses, installierst du die auf deinem eigenen Rechner-Syncing, kannst du auch deinen eigenen Server noch dahinter klatschen?
Mit anderen Omni-Sachen habe ich einfach so einen Web-DAF-Share.
Genau, das basiert auch genau auf Web-DAF, also das ist so ihr Ansatz.
Und jeder Entwickler kann seine eigenen Apps auch mit einbauen. Also ich könnte meine Apps auch mit einbauen.
Das ist ein offener Dienst sozusagen. Hast du dir das mal angeschaut?
Ich habe es gebuckt, Mark, um zu gucken, ich bin noch nicht zugekommen, ob sich das eine Lösung sein kann.
Aber ich finde es sehr interessant, dass jetzt so viele Companies sich echt auf sowas stürzen.
Ich gucke mir gerade eine andere Lösung an. Ich habe mir in den letzten Monaten vier verschiedene Lösungen angeguckt, wie man denn ohne die iCloud klarkommen könnte.
Kannst du da irgendwas nennen?
Bis jetzt, wie üblich. Man wünscht sich eine Kombination aus allen.
Ja, natürlich.
Also was hast du dir angeschaut? Simple Note?
Ja, die Lösung von Simple Note, diese eine Open-Source-Lösung, die so ähnlich arbeitet. Dann jetzt eine Erweiterung von jemanden, die klingt ganz viel, versprechen, die zumindest den Pain, die Schmerzen aus dem iCloud-Sync rausholt und viele der Fehler behebt und nochmal Backups für sich anlegt. Ich hab den Namen vergessen. Also es funktioniert mit iCloud und Core Data an sich, aber es ist nochmal so eine Art dazwischengeschaltet. Wir nehmen dir den Ärger weg und wir informieren dich und wir sichern selber und sollte irgendwas aus dem Ruder laufen, haben wir ein Backup für dich. Ungefähr sowas in die Richtung. Ich hab den Namen vergessen.
Das war doch von irgendeiner etablierten Mac-Bude auch, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, das war glaube ich auch so einer ohne Unterhose zuhause in seinem kleinen Schlafzimmer. Ganz indi.
Mit oder ohne Katze?
Ich glaube ohne Katze.
Das war aber nicht Objective Cloud oder sowas.
Ich hab's auf einem anderen Rechnen. Ich kann's nicht sagen, ich kann's gerne nachliefern.
Objective Sea in the Cloud ist das sozusagen. Das hatte ich auch gesehen.
Ja, das ist so eine Art Up Engine für Objective Sea Anwendungen.
Also es benutzt auch Core Data und die iCloud, aber das sieht sehr vielversprechend aus. Die ersten waren, versuche ich damit, waren gar nicht so schlecht. Und das war jetzt das nächste, was ich gebuckt hat. Also ich mag persönlich die Programme von der Omni Group nicht, aber die Qualität, die sie abliefern, ist eigentlich immer okay.
Was magst du nicht dran?
Das ist jetzt wieder, das ist jetzt Mimimi. Also das ist mehr auch schon visuelle Dinge und so. Als jetzt wirklich Funktionen. Ja, in dem Sinne ist es jetzt mehr visuell.
Dieses Objective-C in the Cloud ist ja interessant. Dann seh ich das richtig, dass man da sozusagen Objective-C benutzen soll, um Web-Apps zu machen?
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie Google App Engine oder so. Du hast Push da irgendwelche. Also du hast so ein Object, das hat so URL-Händler die URL-Händler die bekommen halt die Daten, die, wenn deine URL aufgerufen wird, bekommen die halt den Request und du sendest einen Response zurück. Also wie eigentlich all diese ganzen Cloud-Lösungen funktionieren. So genau hab ich es mir nicht angeguckt. Das läuft nur auf OSX, aber die hosten das halt für dich. Also du schreibst da deine Server-App und hostest das dann bei denen.
Also sein können, dass sie ein bisschen noch mehr Plattformen unterstützen oder so.
Also ich hab das so genau hab ich es mir auch nicht angeguckt, muss ich sagen. Aber es ist für jemand, der gut Objective-C kann und nichts anderes lernen will und schnelle Cloud-Lösungen braucht, das ist sicherlich super.
Interessant.
Ob das performt und ob das überhaupt problemlos funktioniert und so weiter. Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ja, aus deiner Ansicht ist es ja wieder so die Sache. Deswegen könnte Apple bitte endlich das mit der iCloud in den Griff kriegen. Wären alle glücklich und zufrieden. Du musst dir wieder irgendeine Drittlösung nehmen und wieder auf irgendeinen anderen Server und wieder auf irgendwas anderes. Oder du fängst von vorne und schreibst dein eigenes. Aber dann hast du eigentlich auch wieder nur eine Drittlösung mit deinem eigenen Server.
Ach, ehrlich gesagt, ich bin gar nicht so unglücklich darüber, dass Apple da fehlt.
Ja, aber aus Benutzer-Sicht und die Zivilisten da draußen.
Manchmal müssen auch Zivilisten dran laufen.
Also das, was sich bei der alten Firma, was wir da gemacht haben, dieses Syncing über Google App Engine, das geht zwar irgendwann ein bisschen ins Geld, wenn man nicht aufpasst, aber das hat einfach bisher wirklich robust und zuverlässig funktioniert. Also das war zwar auch ein bisschen Aufwand, aber das war einfach der richtige Weg an der Stelle. Weil alles, was wir machen, ist quasi einfach die Zugangsdaten dafür über den Ubiquiti Store da, diesen Key Value Store sharen. Und die werden halt auf einem Device angelegt und das weitere Device sagt, ah ja, iCloud anmachen, dann holt er sich die Zugangsdaten und der Rest läuft schon über die Google App Engine. Das ist irgendwie, das hat wirklich gut und schnell funktioniert, das kann ich echt empfehlen.
Und dürfte für Nutzer ja eigentlich auch überhaupt gar nicht sichtbar sein, oder?
Ich glaube, dass auch sehr viele Firmen, die ein funktionierendes iCloud-Sync haben, so eine Lösung in dieser Art machen. Das klingt zwar nach iCloud, aber im Hintergrund ist es dann was ganz anderes. Wenn wir schon bei Mac-Apps sind, da hab ich auch noch was vorzuschlagen und zwar Dash heißt das Ding. Das ist... Das hat vor Unzeiten Max, als er noch dabei war, Rest in Peace Max, äh... Ja, der hat es mal vorgeschlagen. Der hat es mal vorgeschlagen und das hat sich also durch diverse, äh, äh, Versionen gemausert und ist so zu so einem, äh, all inclusive documentation Browser geworden. Äh, da kann man wirklich irgendwie Dokumentation zu allem runterladen. Äh, von Go über Erlang bis hin zu, ich weiß es nicht.
Ach so, das ist sozusagen ein Programm für alle Dokus von allen.
Du kannst sie in sämtliche Entwicklungsumgebung, die du da benutzen möchtest, auch ganz fein einbinden.
Also da gibt es halt, die haben halt irgendwie Module geschrieben, weiß ich nicht, der lädt halt den Kram runter und dann hast du halt wirklich für alles und seinen Hund hast du halt irgendwie die Dokumentation.
Also das ich, das fand ich doch schon sehr spannend. Gut, ob man jetzt die...
Nein, in der App musst du es dann kaufen, um es ordentlich zu benutzen, für 20 Dollar oder sowas.
Obwohl Dokumentation schreiben, ich weiß nicht.
Du sollst ja nicht schreiben, du sollst ja lesen.
Also für mich ersetzt das in Xcode, ich mache es meist immer in Xcode, ersetzt das die interne Dokumentation, es wird für mich nur noch Dash geöffnet. Und die Kombination besser aufgereitet, du kannst es direkt kopieren und solche Dinge. Der sucht für dich direkt in Google und so.
Naja, ich fand den ganz gut. Die ersten Versionen, die ich so gesehen habe, waren nicht so doll, aber inzwischen ist es echt ein schickes Tool.
Ich benutze das auch erst seit ein paar Wochen und ich möchte nicht mehr ohne.
Ja, selbst, was für dich ist, was dabei war? Für den Opa.
Ja, du kannst dir auch deine eigenen Dinge hinzufügen, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Bestimmt, wenn du es in der richtigen… Aber weißt du, wenn du deine Dokumentation erst mal selbst geschrieben hast, dann brauchst du, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr lesen.
Obwohl, manchen Leuten würde das ganz gut tun, wenn sie den Scheiß, den sie geschrieben haben, selber lesen müssten.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich einen Grund, warum sie es nicht tun.
So, aus der Abteilung. Wenn man Clemens zu lange zuhört, dann kauft man sich Dinge, die man vielleicht nicht unmittelbar braucht, aber sie sind trotzdem cool. Wollte ich euch mal hier kurz in die Runde tragen, wovon Clemens letztes Mal schon berichtet hat und ich habe das mal so ein bisschen getestet.
Jetzt steckt doch mal einer an und publiziert den All, dass die Leute hier sehen können, was auf der Straße passiert. Natürlich nicht die Metaebene von innen.
Dann war es das aber mit dem Stream.
Du kannst ja der Kamera sagen, sie soll bis drei davon machen oder so.
Es gibt keine Kamerabilder aus der Metaebene.
Nein, aus der Metaebene raus.
Zumindest keine kostenlosen.
Obwohl, mein Auto steht in der Pfanne.
Das wird dann hier unser In-App-Purchase hier. Der In-Podcast-Purchase. Sie wollen den Nacktpodcaster live bei Podcasts sehen. Dann klicken Sie hier. Nur 15 Euro pro Minute.
Die sind schön, ne? Also so viel Geld für den Honey, was so eine einzelne Kamera kostet, das geht recht zu Lide.
Also es geht um die Kamera, die den Namen trägt. Wie hieß sie noch gleich?
R-Cam.
R-Cam, richtig, genau.
Von Ubiquiti.
Von Ubiquiti Networks. Und was ich sehr erstaunlich fand und was du so in deiner Schilderung gar nicht so gebracht hast, ist, das ist so vom Formfaktor her, da ist irgendwie alles richtig dran. Also das ist zwar nur ein Plastikgehäuse in etwas, wo man sich so denkt, oh ja, das in Alu wäre mal so richtig Deluxe, aber das kostet ja dann auch gleich Deluxe. Und das Teil geht ja nun mal für 100 Euro über den Tisch.
Und ist Outdoor.
Und ist schon Outdoor-fähig. Wie Outdoor-fähig ist denn das? Sehr.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du dir zum Tauchen schicken kannst in deinen Goldfischsteig, aber du kannst da draußen hinhängen und da draufregen und draufschneiden und dann geht das immer noch.
Und ich war, also was mich wirklich so überzeugt hat, war wie pfiffig, jetzt hab ich schon wieder pfiffig gesagt, raffiniert, durchdacht, dass dieses Gehäuse angelegt ist. Also da ist irgendwie alles am richtigen Platz. Hinten machst du so das Kabel rein, dann hast du da so eine Lampe, die zeigt dir an, dass da Strom ist, da laden drauf, weil ja PoE und so. Strom hier über diesen PoE-Injektor und diese kleine Plastikkappe, die dann da hinten dran ist, die erlaubt dir dann auch noch im geschlossenen Zustand nochmal so ein kleines Türchen hier aufzuschrauben, sodass du eben diese ganze Konstruktion nicht unbedingt wieder vollständig öffnen musst und du kannst zumindest nochmal so weit reinschauen, dass du siehst, brennen die Lampen noch oder mit dem Schraubenzieher nochmal auf den Reset-Button zu klicken. Also das ist alles sehr durchdacht, insbesondere auch mit dem beigefügten Ständer oder Aufhänger, oder wie man das Ding nennen soll.
Wall Mount.
Der Wall Mount. Und kann man hier so richtig fancy reinschieben. Ich kann das mal kurz hier...
Jetzt klicken.
Katschack. Das hält auch.
Wie gesagt, für ein Hulli.
Und auch der Kabelweg des Ethernet-Kabels ist hier also auch gut mit durchdacht und funktioniert auch so vom Software-Setup her. Wie versprochen, also ich kann das nochmal unterstreichen. Was Clementeer gesagt hat.
Es gibt einen minimalen technischen Wermutstropfen, der aber auch durchaus begründet ist. Das PoE, was Ubiquiti benutzt, ist proprietär. Das ist so genannte Passive PoE. Allerdings bietet Ubiquiti selber auch einen Adapter, an dem man sich noch an das Kabel reinhängen kann. Wo man von einem standardisierten PoE alle 800, 2.3 AF oder AT oder UPoE oder so auf diese passive 24V PoE von Ubiquiti runtertransformieren kann. Dann gibt es, wie gesagt, so ein Adapterkabel, da ist nochmal so ein Kästchen dabei. Der Switch, den du hier gekauft hast, auch auf meinen Geräten hin, der ist ja die nicht PoE Variante. Stimmt, du wolltest ja einen Hameln still. Genau, weil in dem Moment, wo so ein Switch PoE hat, fängt er an zum Düsenjäger zu mutieren. Deswegen tut man als Podcaster daran, eher nicht PoE-fähige Switches zu kaufen.
Na gut, ich meine, mit dem Adapter ist das ja schon okay.
Nicht in die Meta-Ebene schauen.
Nicht in die Meta-Ebene installieren.
Aber er hat ja noch zwei Kinder, die man dort...
Ich hab da einen Einsatz, aber der ist gerade nicht im Einsatz. Ich hab's mir jetzt vor allem auch aus Interesse mal gekauft und dann existierende Lösungen ersetzt.
Muss mal wieder mal ein Toy.
Ja, und funktioniert auch so mit Direkt-RTSP drauf machen und so. Und macht auch ein richtiges Bild, finde ich. Ich find's noch nicht so richtig so super-mega-superscharf, aber ich hab jetzt auch noch nicht so richtig... Man muss wahrscheinlich ein bisschen dran drehen. Ich hab jetzt auch nicht so richtig testen können.
Für die Naivlinge unter uns, ich kann's mir also von überall auf der Welt auch ohne Unfall aus dem iPhone anschauen. Wenn ich mein All rum überwachen wollte.
Genau.
Das ist auch so ein Ding. So wird in der Art. Die Röntgen gibt's zumindest auch netterweise. Das ganze Ubiquiti-Spielzeug, was so Spaß macht, gibt's auch immer in nett gepreisten Dreierpacks. Woll ich nur sagen. Also so ein Ding kostet einzeln irgendwie 100 und drei von den Dingern kosten irgendwie 260 oder wie so was.
Um mit dem iPhone drauf zuzugreifen?
Du kannst mit dem iPhone auf den normalen Browser vorne drauf gehen und der kann wohl Mobile-Browser. Ich glaub, es geht.
Na gut, das muss ja nicht mehr wirklich in der Webseite hängen.
Klar, aber es muss ja auch an der Stelle dann Streaming-kompatibel sein mit dem iPhone.
Ja, also wie gesagt. Genau.
Ja, und... Genau. So, und das bringt uns dann noch auf den voraussichtlich... voraussichtlich letzten Punkt hier, nämlich ein weiterer Beitrag aus der Abteilung Heimautomation. Ja, da hatte ich ja neulich eine kleine Führung von dir bekommen, Clemens. Fand ich ja ganz beeindruckend. Wir hatten ja hier schon mal diese ganzen anderen Systeme, die so im Markt sind, hier auch schon mal besprochen vor einiger Zeit. Bei den Nobilex? Ich hab da noch nicht bei uns. Das waren diese ganzen Konrad-Sachen, die teilweise eben schon darunter leiden, dass sie dann nicht bidirektional sind.
Aber dafür günstig.
Dafür sehr günstig und auch vielfältig.
Ich kann ja mal erzählen, was ich so mache.
Genau, du hast ja da natürlich auch noch andere Lösen.
Ich schicke mal den Disclaimer vorbei, dass ich jetzt nicht wieder in den Kommentaren lesen will, warum ich jetzt gerade DIT nehme und nicht das tolle Open Source FHEM oder das System, das der jeweilige Hörer zu Hause hat, sondern ich erzähl jetzt einfach, was ich habe und möchte das auch gerne wertfrei diskutiert wissen. Ich benutze nach ein bisschen Auswahl das System HOMATIC. Warum kann ich auch gleich sagen? HOMATIC. HOMATIC. Wie HOM und dann ATIC hinten dran. Das gibt es übrigens auch bei Konrad und bei ELV und so. Das kommt auch aus dieser selben Bude. Es gibt so eine Bude, die sitzt da oben auch im ostfriesischen E3Q, EQ3, EQ3 heißt das nicht, glaube ich, wo so ein paar Ingenieure da vor sich hin basteln und das dann in China basteln lassen. Man sieht es auch, dass ein paar von diesen Gehäusen, die wir benutzen, sind diesem FS-20-System, was Konrad ja auch hat, sehr ähnlich. Der Grund, warum ich Hommatik genommen habe, ist, es hat für mich den guten Balance zwischen, ja du hast jetzt die Webseite von denen, die ist eher, naja, okay, das hat eine gute Balance zwischen genug Nerdness-Faktor, das heißt, man kann sehr viel, sehr schön drin rumbasteln, aber man kann das auch so bauen und einsetzen, dass der Waff noch ausreichend hoch ist, dass also auch normale Menschen sich noch in diesem Haushalt wagen aufzuhalten. Ja, doch, das geht. Also ich will mal ein paar Sachen sagen. Erstmal was sehr Schönes ist, die Funk-Komponenten oder hauptsächlich alle Wire. Man kann Hommatik mit Funk und mit Draht betreiben. Ich mache beides. Und die Komponenten sind dort grundsätzlich erstmal bidirektional miteinander verbunden. Das heißt im Gegensatz zu so einem System wie FS20 oder so was, wo denn der Taster nur sendet und nicht weiß, ob ihm irgendjemand zuhört. Dementsprechend auch keine Retrace oder irgendwas macht, ist es bei Hommatik immer so, dass die Komponenten immer alle miteinander reden. Also auch die Aktoren, vielleicht soll ich gleich noch mal sagen, was das ist. Die Aktoren sagen also auch, ob sie auch agiert haben. Also auch das sind nicht nur reine Empfänger, sondern die geben auch immer Rückmeldungen. Bei so Hausstellungssystemen kann man mal grundsätzlich immer sagen, es gibt immer so zweierlei Komponenten, nämlich Sensoren und Aktoren. Sensoren sind immer Sachen, die Dinge messen oder Informationen aufnehmen oder einen Taster oder irgendwie sowas. Da gibt es wirklich einen ganz irren Zoo von diesen Dingern. Und Aktoren sind Dinge, die irgendwas machen, meistens und welche Sachen, die Strom anschalten, Motoren, die sich bewegen, Dimmer, die irgendwelche Lichtdinger da bedienen oder so. Und die Idee bei dieser Heumautomation ist, dass man diese Dinge miteinander verknüpft mit mehr oder weniger Logik. Das schöne bei Homatik ist, da kommen wir wieder zum hohen Buff, du kannst simple Sensoren mit simplen Aktoren verknüpfen. Du kannst z.B. deinem Lichtschalter einfach der passende Lampe sagen, ihr gehört jetzt mal zusammen. Und dann schaltet der Lichtschalter diese Lampe ein, ohne dass du dafür eine Zentrale brauchst. Auch dann, wenn deine Zentrale kaputt ist oder das Internet gestört ist, weil jemand Google in Google eingegeben hat. Dann geht das Licht immer noch an. Peer to Peer. Das heißt aber, die Zentrale kann trotzdem mitspielen. Außerdem, was ich sehr schön finde, die Homatik-Leute haben ihr System leitlich, aber ausreichend dokumentiert. Das heißt, es gibt sehr viele Leute, die haben Erweiterungen dafür geschrieben. Das ist ein System, wo man Plugins reinmachen kann, was auch viele Leute getan haben. Auf welcher Plattform dann? Ach so, man muss jetzt sagen, du kannst diese Komponenten einzeln benutzen. Von Homatik selber gibt es verschiedene Adapter für Funk und jetzt auch für Kabel demnächst. Wo du dann auch, was ich direkt Open Source wie FHEM oder solche Geschichten andocken kannst, und damit sozusagen deine Aktoren ansprechen oder deine Sensoren abfragen kannst.
FHEM war diese Softwarelösung, die auch auf der Fritzbox läuft?
Genau, das ist einfach ein riesengroßer Zoo von Pearl. Quatsch, der irgendwie zusammengeheimert ist. Mit einer Oberfläche, da willst du wirklich nicht dran lecken. Aber damit kann man halt eben auch Sachen verknüpfen und steuern und so weiter. Homatik selber bietet aber auch eine Zentrale an. Ein Design, an dem willst du nicht lecken. Das sieht ganz fürchterlich aus. Das sieht so aus wie dieses Hotel in Dubai oder so. Da unten, da links, da diese Protokolle. Homatik CCU 1.4. Das ist die Zentrale. Das ist eine Linux-Kiste mit einer Web-Oberfläche im Wesentlichen, die sowohl ein Radio drin hat, als auch diese kabelgebundene Schnittstelle. Da kannst du aber wie gesagt eigenen Kram auf diese Linux-Kiste draufladen. Das ist auch offiziell supported. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man die jetzt erst aufhacken oder jailbreaken muss oder so. Dann kannst du eigenes Zeug draufladen. Und da gibt es jetzt sehr schöne Sachen. Nämlich gerade für den Bastler und den Nerd. Da gibt es nämlich jemand, der hat ein Plug-In darauf geschrieben, dass man mit dieser Zentrale auch Fremdkomponenten ansteuern kann. Und das unterstützt deren Software-Modell auch. Weil das Software-Modell kennt nur grundsätzlich Sensoren, Aktoren, also irgendwelche Devices. Und die haben auch durchaus nichts dagegen, dass man, wenn man dafür ein Interface schreibt, eben auch Fremddinger einbaut und das hat halt jemand getan. Da gibt es den sogenannten Cooks-D, das ist ein Stück Open Source Software, da lädst du auf das Ding drauf. Dann steckst du dir noch, diese Zentrale hat auch zwei USB-Ports, da steckst du dir noch einen kleinen, separaten Receiver rein, den man sich auch zusammenklicken kann im Netz, der kostet so 30, 40 Euro und dann kannst du mit all möglichen anderen Zeug auch reden. Also auch mit diesen ganzen FS-20-Komponenten. Das ist so, dass diese HOMATIC-Sachen, die sind zwar sehr lustig, aber es gibt halt nicht alle Sensoren dafür. Es gibt zum Beispiel keinen Regensensor. Es gibt zwar eine Wetterstation, die sagt, ob es regnet oder ob es geregnet hat oder wie viel es geregnet hat, aber es gibt zum Beispiel auf der FS-20-Seite, wer da klickt, da gibt es wirklich Dutzende von Sensoren für jeden Scheiß. Und da gibt es so richtig so bodenfeuchte Sensor für einen Garten oder Regensensoren oder sowas. Und wenn man sowas auch mit nutzen will, dann steckt man sich wie gesagt da noch diesen Transzival in die CCU mit rein und lädt diese Cooksy oben mit drauf und dann hat man sozusagen auch noch Zugriff auf diese FS20 und viele viele andere Dinge auch. Da gibt es auch noch so eine Firma N Ocean heißt, die baut auch noch Sensoren und Taster und macht was weiß ich nicht alles. Und deswegen habe ich das... Die Firma EN Ocean. Wie Ozean? Die machen wohl so Sachen, die auch batterielos betrieben werden. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht durch PE-Zoo, wenn du draufdrückst, entsteht genug Strom, das Ding rumsenden kann oder wie auch immer. Auch diese Komponenten kann man dann damit einbinden. Und das war eigentlich für mich der Grund, warum ich gesagt habe, ich mach das mal. Außerdem, weil es wie gesagt sehr lustige dokumentierte Apis hat. Das heißt, ich hab auch selber meine Cloud, also das, was ich selber wusste, hab ich ja meine Mac-Minis, weil die ich schon mal ein paar mal gerichtet habe. Da wir Komponenten, die auf diese Haussteuerung zugreifen und entweder selber Sachen auslösen oder sich registrieren. Du kannst dich dort als Applikation registrieren, sagen, wenn dieser und jener Sensor auslöst oder neue Daten übermittelt, dann schickt mir das doch mal. Und damit kann man sehr viele lustige Sachen machen. Kann man sein Haus steuern, bis der Arzt kommt. Ich mach damit die üblichen Sachen, also so ein bisschen Lichtsteuerung, Heizungssteuerung. Was ich auch damit mache, ist, ich mach sogar Zutrittssteuerung. Also es gibt so Schlösser, die du ansteuern kannst, darüber die dann sozusagen auf und zu gehen und Türen auf und zu machen.
Also eigentlich mehr so Schlüssel, die man quasi...
Ja, das Ding, in der Tat, das Ding sitzt auf dem Schloss oben drauf und dreht einfach an Schlüssel. Du brauchst ein Schloss, wo man den Schlüssel auf der Einsatz stecken lassen kann. Und dann schraubst du einfach oben auf den Zylinder drauf und das dreht an dem Schlüssel. Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen cool, das funktioniert aber sehr stabil.
Naive Frage, was passiert, wenn die Batterie alle ist?
Erstens, dadurch, dass die Dinge halt bidirektional sind, sagt es dir lange vorher Bescheid. Okay, wenn du das Ding jetzt ein dreiviertel Jahr ignorierst, dann hast du halt einfach ins Klo gegriffen. Auf der anderen Seite willst du, wie gesagt, deswegen ja ein Schloss haben, wo der Schlüssel auf beiden Seiten stecken kann. Das heißt, dass du von der anderen Seite immer noch Schlüssel reinstecken kannst. Kannst du natürlich ignorieren und ein normales Schloss nehmen, aber dann hast du natürlich wirklich ins Klo gegriffen. Du kannst aber die Dinger, übrigens mechanisch von innen sowieso, da ist so ein Rad dran, da kannst du also immer mit der Hand an dem Ding drehen, das ist nicht das Problem. Es sind auch immer Tasten auch drauf. Wenn du jetzt mit der Haussteuerung das Ding nicht steuern willst, kannst du einfach an dem Gerät auch eine Taste drücken oder siehst dort, auf dem Bild gibt es diese netten kleinen Schlüsselanhänger. Auch das ist wieder sozusagen ein Sensor. Den kannst du direkt peeren mit dem Schloss, dann geht der Schloss auch noch damit auf, selbst wenn deine Zentrale gerade in den Toti-Storben ist oder irgendwas da kaputt ist.
Wie brauchbar ist das alles so verschlüsselt, was da so überall ist?
Du kannst für alles, was Security-relevant ist, kannst du so eine AIS-Verschlüsselung anmachen. Ich hab die jetzt nicht gescreened. Also sie behaupten selber, sie benutzen AIS 256. Ob und wie gut die Implementation ist und wie gut der Zufallszahl-Generatoren sind, möchte ich den Spezialisten vom CCC überlasten. Aber immerhin, wenn man da so drauf hört, mit diesem anderen Dongle, den ich erwähnt habe, wo man einfach so roh auf dem Radio rumhören kann, kommt genügend, für mich als Hex-Dom, sieht es genügend gibberish aus. Wie gut die Krypto ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Weißes Grau.
Es sieht einigermaßen grau aus, ja. Du kannst Sachen nachrüsten. Du kannst solche Sensoren zum Beispiel auch hinter vorhandene Stecker machen. Das heißt, du nimmst einfach so einen Schalter aus der Wand und machst so ein kleines Scheibchen dahinter, das ist, keine Ahnung, ein paar Millimeter dick. Schließt da deinen Schalter wieder an, versenkst es ganz wie deine Wand, das kann man auch damit machen. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut gemacht. Wie alles, was mit Software basiert ist, hatte Zeuss natürlich auch Wanzen. Zum Beispiel diese CCU ist, was zum Beispiel beim Booten angeht oder wenn man die Sachen programmieren will, unglaublich langsam. Diese Oberfläche versucht ihr gesamtes Wissen, was deine gesamte Hausstellung angeht, per JavaScript in deinen Browser reinzuladen. Und das heißt, wenn du in den Programmiermodus gehst, dann holst du dir vorher erstmal ein Bier. Ich jedenfalls. Also ich hab so viele Komponenten, dass allein das Laden dieser ganzen Objekte und das lädt er alles in den Browser rein. Also das ist ein ziemlich krankes Objekt, ziemlich krankes Konzept. Aber auch da wieder, es gibt wieder Alternativen dazu. Es gibt kommerzielle und Open Source Software, die sozusagen dasselbe macht, die selbe Programmierumgebung oder eine ähnliche Programmierumgebung bietet, wie das, was der Originalhersteller dort macht, wo Leute versuchen, das besser zu machen. Also das ist wie gesagt einer der Punkte, wo ich sagte, okay, das ist hinreichend gut dokumentiert. Wenn man versucht, was zu implementieren, dann stellt man natürlich fest, okay, haben sie doch vergessen, was zu dokumentieren. Aber sie geben sich halt Mühe. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die sagen, nee, das ist alles uns, ein Proprietär, und macht doch reverse engineering, wir sagen ja dazu nichts. Sondern die lassen es durchaus zu, dass man da sein eigenes Zeug da einspielt. Du kannst halt irgendwie billigen und die teuren Komponenten benutzen.
Was gibt es denn hier Feindes? Also es gibt hier Bewegungsmelder, für drinnen und draußen, Rauchmelder.
Die kannst du auch miteinander verlinken. Ich habe zum Beispiel mehrere Gebäude und mehrere Räumlichkeiten, die miteinander verbunden sind. Das heißt, wenn einer schreit, schreien alle. Du siehst den Dinger nicht an, aber du wachst zumindest erst mal auf. Also wenn im Keller ein Feuer ausbricht, dann schreit er doch oben, da wo man schläft. Und das ist ja immerhin schon mal was. Du kannst, wenn es dann, achso, muss man noch dazu sagen, es gibt sehr viele Plug-Ins, befassen sich mit Messaging und E-Mail. Da habe ich auch drin. Das heißt, wenn also bestimmte Events dort auftreten, was sich Wasser austritt im Keller oder sonst irgendwas, schickt mir der Ding auch Messages und ich benutze auch diese Prowl, was ja auch so ein Pushdienst ist für iPhones oder sowas, das kann man auch schön einbinden. Und mein iPhone blinkt mich dennoch an. Okay, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein Brandfall. Wenn ich da bin, werde ich es auch so merken, dass es brennt, aber wenn ich eben nicht da bin, das betreibe ich ja auf meinem Landsitz.
Merke auch, dass es brennt.
Merke ich auch, dass es brennt und rufe dann einen Freund im Dorf an und frage ihn, ob er mal Lust hat, hochzugehen mit einer Flasche Wasser oder so. Und ich hatte auch schon durchaus Fälle, die waren jetzt nicht kritisch. Also ich benutze das dafür, dass ich sozusagen meinen Landsitz dort, ich sag mal, selber beschütze, jetzt nicht gegen Einbruch oder sonst, weil ich hab da jetzt keine Selbstschussanlagen dran, aber ich hatte zum Beispiel mal den Fall, dass ein Handwerker bei mir mal sich gedacht hat, ach, geht mal ne Runde für kleine Handwerker auf meinem Klo, und was macht man denn danach? Man macht das Fenster auf. Und dann handwerkt man weiter. Auch wenn es Februar ist. Und dann sagte meine Haussteuerung so, der Thermostat im Bad sagte dann so, oh, muss ich mal gegenheizen. Ganz schön kalt. Und dann hab ich die Software so gemacht, dass wenn die Heizung angeht, aber die Temperaturkurve trotzdem weiter abfällt, sozusagen die Heizung nichts bringt, dass er mir dann gerade in Frostzeit, dass er dann in Frostzeit schmeißt er halt einen Alarm. Dann hat mich mein Prole, mein iPhone angepinkt und ich hab ne App auf meinem iPhone, wo ich meine ganzen Sensoren abfragen kann und angucken kann und hab den gesehen so wie Bad 12 Grad. Gucked, oh, Fenster auf. Und dann haben wir gewusst, dass der Anker da ist. Ja, ich hab ein Sensor an dem Fenster.
Warum hat der nicht schon das geöffnete Fenster?
Das ist ja durchaus legitim, auf dem Klo mal ein Fenster aufzumachen.
Aber in der Zeit könnte die Heizung ausgehen.
Ja, dafür ist der Sensor ja da.
Aber warum brauchst du dann allein? Dann könnte die Heizung gleich alleine ausgehen.
Ja, aber nein. Der Taus sagt, das ist in einem Schutzmodus. Das versucht sich vor Frost zu beschützen. Ich hatte nämlich in früheren Jahren immer extreme Frostschäden dort. Deswegen versuche ich auf Teufel, komm raus, wo irgendwelche Rohre langgehen oder so was über den Frost zu halten. Also schlimmstenfalls, wenn das Fenster offen ist und es wird zu kalt, mache ich trotzdem die Heizung an. In der Hoffnung, dass ich versuche, noch irgendetwas zu retten von dem Haus. Hat aber nicht geklappt. Das Haus hat festgestellt, da komme ich nicht gegen an. Hat mich angeplinkt, dann habe ich den Zimmermann angerufen und gesagt, hey André, du warst bei mir? Machst du mal Fenster zu? Ja, warst du kacken? Ich so, ja weißt du, das Fenster ist immer noch offen. Fährst du mal bitte wieder hin, machst du das Fenster wieder zu. Dann hat er geknotet, musste wieder in seinen Autostein wieder hinfahren, das Fenster zu machen. Aber das geht, das kann man damit machen. Ich hab auch noch was anderes. Es gibt zum Beispiel eine sehr lustige Komponente, mit der kann man einfach Spaß haben. Und zwar gibt es einen MP3-Funk-Gong, nennen die den. Da schiebst du eine MicroSD-Karte rein, so FAT formatiert, die hat irgendwie bis zu 256 Dateien drauf, oder 255 Dateien, die heißen, nennen wir es sich 001.mp3 bis 255.mp3. Die kann ich dann auch abrufen, aus der Steuerung heraus. Da kann man natürlich lustige Sachen hinterlegen, weil es sind in Spielteilen MP3s, da kannst du irgendeinen Quatsch reinmachen. Ich hab zum Beispiel eine Sache für die Waschmaschine, ich hab eine Waschmaschine im Keller, und so ein Ding rödelt ja immer eine ganze Weile, und da ich nerd bin und dann in meinem Rechner versunken bin, in dem was ich gerade tue, vergess ich die gerne mal. Deswegen hab ich unten einen Stromsensor dran, und wenn eine Waschmaschine fertig ist, hört sie auf Strom zu versorgen und Strom zu benötigen, und dann löst dieser Sensor aus, und der MP3-Funk-Gong oben sagt, die Waschmaschine ist fertig. Dazu benutze ich übrigens, zum Generieren dieser Dinge, benutze ich übrigens wieder diesen Sound, diesen Text-to-Speech von Apple. Da kann man jede Menge anderen...
Kann man das dann auch an die Klingeln, an die Tür bauen?
Du kannst alle Möche damit machen. Das ist ja das Schöne, du kannst beliebig Tasten dralalala verknüpfen, machen, tun. Ich hab zum Beispiel eine GNJB-Taste, oben am Bett und auch unten und so. Das ist die Gute Nacht John-Boy-Taste. Ihr erinnert euch alle noch an die Waltons, die Schlussszene der Waltons. Gute Nacht John-Boy. Zum Schluss macht das Licht aus, dann gibt's noch mal so einen Mundharmonika-Sound am Ende.
Der Original-Waltons-Sound?
Ja, und wenn du diese Gute Nacht John-Boy-Taste drückst, sagt das Haus Gute Nacht John-Boy, macht die Lichter alle aus, Türen zu und so weiter. Wenn du damit fertig bist, spielst du diesen Mundharmonika-Sound. Das finde ich sehr schön. Du liegst oben im Bett und machst Gute Nacht John-Boy. Ist jetzt ein bisschen sehr nerdisch, aber kann man damit basteln.
Gar nicht.
Gar nicht nerdisch.
Das kann überhaupt nicht.
Gute Nacht, Everyone.
Gute Nacht, Elizabeth. Gute Nacht, John-Boy. Gute Nacht, Jim-Bob. Gute Nacht, Jim-Bob. Gute Nacht, Jim-Bob. Ich war schlafen.
Gute Nacht, Jim-Bob.
Genau aus diesem YouTube-Video habe ich daraus geschnitten, die Teile, die ich brauchte und spiele wie gesagt vorne ein, mach dann alle möglichen Lichter aus und all so Zeugs.
Das wär für mich der einzige Grund, mit so was anzufangen.
Dimmer natürlich, also zum Beispiel die Sachen, wo ich einen Dimmer dran hab, die mach ich nicht einfach aus, sondern die werden natürlich soft runtergedimmt und dann zum Schluss spielt er noch mal diesen Sound da und dann ist gut. Also ist jetzt nur so ein Spielchen, aber sowas kann man machen. Ich benutze den auch ernsthaft gerade mit der iPhone-App zusammen, da gibts verschiedene, gibts Kosten, wie ein kleines Geld, also 10 Euro oder so was, oder 19 Euro. Und damit hab ich zum Beispiel häufig, da ich auch mal Freunde draußen habe, die mal in meiner Hütte benutzen, hatte ich das schon, zum Beispiel war Weihnachten Neujahr, war ich irgendwo in Schweden und die rief mich an und sagten, ach, hier ist grad schön, können wir deine Hütte benutzen? Ich, ja klar, fährst du hin, wenn du vor der Tür stehst, rufst du mich an.
Dann geht sie automatisch auf.
Nee, dann rufen die mich an, starte meine ab und sag, mach mal die Vordertür auf, mach die Vordertür auf, dann gehen die da rein.
Und wenn er gerade keinen Empfang hat, dann kommt die da nie wieder raus, oder was?
Nee, da ist ja ein Schlüssel oder dieser Key dann innen drin. Aber wie gesagt, man kann auch sehr viele andere Sachen machen. Ich momentan richtig gerade wieder die Beregnungsanlage da ein.
Was kosten solche Türöffnungsaktoren?
Die Dithomatic-Zeugs sind nicht ganz billig. Deswegen tut man gut daran, diesen Cook-Stay drauf zu machen. Da man für seine Spielchen auch Dith-Faktor-2- oder 3-billige FS-20-Zeugs einsetzen kann. Für die Sachen, die jetzt nicht mission-critical sind.
Aber viel teurer dürfte doch die CCU sein, die du da drauf verwendet hast.
Aber gib mal so ein Beispiel. Die CCU, also die Zentrale, kostet 200 Euro. Die Türdinger, weiß ich gar nicht, die kosten auch über 100. Die braucht man gar nicht unbedingt. Die CCU? Du kannst das auch ohne spielen. Was zum Beispiel im Verhältnis zu dem anderen, was relativ billig ist, ist dieser LAN-Adapter. Es gibt so einen LAN-Adapter, das hängst du dir halt irgendwo rein in dein Netz. Du holst dich per DLCP in eine Adresse. Dann kannst du mit Software wie FHEM oder mit selbstgeschriebener Software mit den Geräten reden und da irgendwelche Sachen hin und her schicken. Da gibt es genügend Open Source für und auch Dokumentationen, wie man das macht. Es gibt auch Software dafür. Allerdings die Hauptsache für einen PC. Also wer sowas macht, gibt es ja noch mal.
Und jetzt diese Klassiker, also Türschloss öffnen, wäre zum Beispiel schon mal eine ganz coole...
Also alles, was so Mechanik ist, das lassen sich immer relativ gut bezahlen. Was simpel ist, also zum Beispiel so ein Sensor-Array für Taster oder sowas, wo so vier Tastersensoren drin sind, kostet so um die 20-25 Euro. Auch Türkontakte und sowas, die liegen so in diesem Range. Diese Schlossdinger lassen sich relativ gut bezahlen, weil das ist auch eine aufwendige Mechanik. Die kosten, ich weiß nicht, wie 100, 119, 120 Euro. Kommt auf an, wie viele Türen du damit jetzt ausstatten willst. Was so richtig, richtig, richtig teuer ist, das hab ich auch nicht. Irgendwann sind die Dinger zu hässlich. Die haben auch einen Motor, mit dem du deine üblichen Fenster auch so ankippen kannst und so was. Die üblichen modernen Plastikfenster. Das ist so richtig, so ein Motor, tra la la da drin, kostet über 200 Euro das Ding. Mit auswechselbaren Akkus und was weiß ich nicht alles. Weil da sagen sie, das bewegst du so häufig und da brauchen wir so viel Energie für, dass wir da dir einen auswechselbaren Akku mit dranbauen. Den du externen lädst und so. Also das Preis-Ranging von diesem Zeug ist mir nicht ganz klar. Manche Komponenten sind erstaunlich günstig, andere sind erstaunlich teuer. Zum Beispiel haben sie auch eine Komponent, die ist so richtig scheiße. Sie haben einen CO2-Sensor, den man vielleicht sich anbringen möchte, wenn man da in welcher offenen Brennstellen oder so was in seinem Haus hat oder sonst irgendwas. Der sagt immer nur Ja oder Nein und kostet 160 Euro.
Sind es vielleicht die Patente, die drinsteckt?
Ich weiß es nicht. Der sagt nur Gefahr oder keine Gefahr. Der gibt ja keine ordentlichen Messwerte aus oder so was. Das ist halt einfach richtig teuer. Das ist Quatsch. Ich habe, wie gesagt, über diese FS20-Anbindung oder über das Cookstay-Zeugs habe ich diverse Sachen dran gemacht. Ich mache noch einen Anwendungsfall dafür. In meinem Landsitz gibt es dort keine Kanalisation. Das Abwasser landet in einem Tank und dieser Tank muss abgefahren werden. Das passiert on demand. Da kann man also beim Zweck- und Abwasserverband anrufen und sagen, ihr mal Scheiße abfahren bitte. Ich habe aber auch eine E-Mail-Adresse rausgenötigt, wo man das hinschreiben kann. Dann habe ich versucht herauszufinden, wie viel Gülle in meinem Tank ist. Das ist übrigens für Nerds ein echt interessantes Thema. Das ist nämlich nicht so einfach herauszufinden. Jetzt, wir haben mal Vorschläge. Du hast jetzt einen Tank draußen vor der Tür, wo leckere Sachen drin rumschwimmen und du möchtest jetzt gerne wissen, wie voll dieser Tank ist. Wie würdest du das anstellen?
Gewicht?
Schwimmer?
Da müsste man jetzt ausrechnen, wie viele Menschen wohnen in diesem Haushalt, wie viel scheißen die durchschnittlich, was für eine Masse hat diese Scheiße?
Ja, aber Moment, Moment, das heißt du willst jetzt, dass ich diesen dreieinhalb Kubikmeter Tank ausbuddel, um eine Waage drunter zu bauen? Hast du noch eine Idee?
Ultraschall.
Die Idee ist gar nicht schlecht, ich sag dir auch warum, aber sie geht trotzdem nicht. Was hast du noch für einen Vorschlag?
Na, dir dein Schwimmer wie bei so einem Tank oder du machst das über deinen Wasserverbrauch und rechnest hoch.
Oder du machst es...
Die erste Idee, jetzt erklär ich euch mal, warum die erste Idee nicht geht. Die zweite Idee ist super, die erste Idee geht deswegen nicht, weil der Typ, der mit seinem Güllenlaster kommt, der hat einen derartig geilen Staubsauger, der saugt ja alles weg. Wenn der diesen Tank leer saugt, saugt der mir auch regelmäßig das Wasser aus den Siphons im Haus, sogar aus dem Klo raus. Du kommst aus dem Klo, dein Klo ist trocken wie nichts und du denkst so, hä? Weil der so einen Unterdruck erzeugt und der ist auch gnadenlos, der steckt nämlich seinen Rüssel da rein und saugt dort alles weg. Das heißt, wenn da ein Schwimmer drin ist, ist der danach weg. Deswegen sind also alle Sachen, die in der Suppe schwimmen, schonmal verboten. Ultraschall, die Idee ist gar nicht schlecht, war ich auch da, hab ich mich, gibt so Bastler, mit denen hab ich mich auseinandersetzt. Auch jemand, der sowas verkauft, der sagt, ja, das ist ganz toll, kannst du gerne machen für Regenwasser, nicht für Gülle. Oder für so Hauswasserabfälle, weil die zerstören dir diese Sensoren. Ernsthaft. Die Dämpfe, die da rauskommen durch die Waschmittel und sonst irgendwas, killen dir die Ultraschall-Sensoren innerhalb von wenigen Wochen. Es gibt noch was. Aber Dennis hat recht. Die Methode, die ich mache, ist, ich hab mir eine Wasseruhr gekauft, die einen sogenannten S0-Ausgang hat. Das hat jetzt nichts mit dem ESDN S0 zu tun, das ist einfach ein Kontakt, der pro Liter, was da durchfließt, einmal piepsacht. Dafür gibt es dann eine Zähler-Komponente, die dann per Funk an meine Haussteuerung meldet, wie der Zählerstand gerade ist. Und ich weiß, das passen halt drei Kubikmeter rein in den Tank und in dem Moment, wo ich sozusagen drei Kubikmeter Frischwasser gebraucht habe, plus jetzt plus minus ein bisschen Hardwashmittel und Scheiße und sowas, weiß ich, dann ist der Tank mal wieder fällig. Dann löse ich eine E-Mail aus, die an den Zwecke und Abwasserverband geht und der dann sagt, bitte, kommt noch frei.
Es gibt noch eine Methode. Radioaktivität. Ja, das benutzt man irgendwie bei Öltanks, so Schweröl und so ein Zeug, dadurch, dass du, also du hast eine radioaktive Quelle und du hast Geigerzähler. Und wenn voll ist, dann piept er nicht mehr. Und wenn voll ist, dann schirmt der Inhalt des Tankes die radioaktive Quelle so stark ab, dass du hinterher feststeigen kannst, der Pegel ist jetzt über einem bestimmten Level.
Also erstens halte ich das für fragwürdig so umwelttechnisch. Zweitens hätte ich auch da wieder Sorge, dass der Typ mir den Ding von der Wand saugt.
Nee, das bringt es ja außen an.
Ach außen, außerhalb des Tankes. Okay, wie gesagt, momentan mache ich es über das Zählen des Zuwassers. Hast du auch sowas für die Mülltonnen? Für die Mülltonnen habe ich folgendes. Da hat er die Waage. Nochmal, das ist dort auf dem Land. Da gibt es einen festgelegten Zeitpunkt, wo ich die Mülltonnen an die nächste Straße stellen muss, was durchaus ein Stückchen weit weg ist. Nehm mal einen Großband. Die haben aber einen relativ gut festgelegten Kalender, wo sie dir vorher sagen, schon im alten Jahr, wann sie das neue Jahr machen, das kann man einhaken. Und was ich dir vorhin gesagt habe, der Müll wird nicht automatisch abgeholt, aber ich hab ein kleines Kästchen an der Tür, was auch über die Haussteuerung gesteuert wird. Ist übrigens ziemlich billig wieder, unverständlicherweise. Das ist ein Kästchen, das kennt ihr vielleicht aus Hotels, oder was so an Konferenzräumen dran hängt. Weißt du, wo so einfach nur so ein Schild vom Prinzip, was sich umdreht. Mechanisches Schild. Was, was, was, was? Pass auf, erstens kann die Haussteuerung diese Schild setzen, das heißt, sie kann das umklappen oder wieder zurückklappen. Das hat jetzt nur einen Zustand.
Was macht das normalerweise im Konferenzraum?
Jetzt sagt ihr, ob der belegt ist oder nicht. Normalerweise ist es so ein Schild, das du hin und her schiebst, so irgendwie besetzt oder nicht. Wie auf dem Klo sozusagen. Das Interessante ist, dass es eine Anzeige ist, die dadurch, dass sie mechanisch ist, keinen Strom verbraucht, in dem Moment, wo sie was anzeigt. Das ist halt ein Schild, das umklappt. Aber davon ist es doch einfach nett. Es ist einfach schön, um mal was Mechanisches wieder da zu haben. Das macht dann halt Klack und dann dreht sich das um.
So eine Art Riesen-E-Paper.
Das kostet auch nur 20, 29 oder 25 Euro. Kann ich dir gleich mal schicken. Das kann die Haussteuerung sowohl setzen als auch abfragen. Du kannst das Schild auch umdrehen, manuell. Dann weiß die Haussteuerung das auch. Was ich jetzt mache, ist, auf diesem Schild steht daran, Müll an die Straße zu bringen. Wenn die Haussteuerung der Meinung ist, dass jetzt nächsten Tag so was ansteht, weil der Kalender sagt mir, dass der Wagen kommt, das abholt, dann dreht es dieses Schild um.
Wenn du dann da hinkommst?
Nee, ich gehe dann, wenn ich durch die Tür gehe, das sitzt direkt auf Augenhöhe an der Tür innen. Wenn ich dann sozusagen rausgehe, sagt das Schild geht natürlich einen Tag vorher oder zwei Tage vorher an. Zusätzlich passiert noch folgendes, wenn man die Eingangstür öffnet, während dieses Schild auf Müll rausbringt, sagt der MP3-Funkkong, bitte Müll an die Straße bringen. So, wenn du das gemacht hast, dann sollte man wirklich mal schauen. Und wenn man das gemacht hat, dann dreht man dieses Schild einfach wieder um. Wo hast du die Frage, wie das machen mit dem Öl?
Okay, was hast du im Kühlschrank?
Im Kühlschrank habe ich einen HMS-Temperatursensor, der einfach nur für einen Alarm sorgt, wenn der Kühlschrank zu warm wird, wenn man zum Beispiel die Tür öffnet. Nee, das brauch ich aber dringend. Ich brauch ganz dringend einen und zwar, weil ich hab festgestellt, bzw. eine Freundin hat festgestellt, dass wenn ich da, ich bin zu groß für den Kühlschrank. Das ist halt so ein kleiner Kühlschrank, wie hier auch, der sozusagen auf dem Boden steht. Und ich sehe immer nie, was ganz hinten drin ist. Ich hab zum Beispiel neulich die dritte Packung Butter mitgebracht, weil die anderen hat irgendjemand nach hinten geschoben mit der Mateflasche.
Du wahrscheinlich?
Vermutlich. Und irgendwann stand neulich die Frage an, was ich mit drei Packungen Butter in dem Kühlschrank mache. Ich dachte, ich hätte keine mehr. Aber deswegen, da muss ich nochmal was dran machen. Also da muss man noch dran arbeiten. Da ist noch Ruhm vor dem Provement.
Irgendwann kommt der Klemerz nach Hause und dann ist da so ein Schild, Klemerz ist heute fertig, du kommst jetzt ins Bett.
Ich mache sehr viel Sachen eben aus Spaß, ein paar Sachen Notwendigkeit. Also diese ganze Frostschutzgeschichte ist mir wirklich sehr, sehr wichtig, weil mir ist die Küche und das Bad dort mehrfach eingefroren. Und das macht einfach nach dem vierten Komplettabbau der Küche oben an der Drohre, was natürlich in der Ecke hinten platzt.
Aber haben die die Heizung, wieso so eine Frosteinstellung?
Ja, hab ich jetzt auch. Ich hab jetzt sogar noch Kabelheizung extra noch. Es gibt Kabelheizung, die kannst du um deine Rohre rumwickeln und so. Und die bemühe ich notfalls auch. Weil nochmal, wenn du die Küche viermal abgebaut hast, hast du irgendwann keinen Bock mehr. Und auch jetzt ist schon der dritte Boiler drin, weil zwei Jahre aufgefroren sind und so weiter im Winter. Inzwischen betreibe ich wie gesagt diese Hütte auch so, da ich auch im Winter jetzt häufiger da bin, dass sie eben auch durchläuft. Aber so eine Sache, da mach ich wirklich ernsthafte Sachen mit. Ebenso was ich jetzt mit Bewässerung für den Garten oder so weil das ist halt schon noch ein Stückchen weg von Berlin. Und da wird sie nicht mal zum Rasenmähen zwei Stunden rausfahren. Das ist irgendwie blöd.
Also wenn du das alles komplett durchautomatisiert hast, brauchst du vielleicht auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr hinfahren.
Das ist durchaus...
Jetzt pack mal so einen Link zu diesem Schild.
Zu diesem Schild, ja exorgetarisch. Also übrigens nur so nebenbei, wer jetzt so richtig für den Nerdfaktor ist, gibt die meisten dieser Sachen dort sowohl fertig als auch als Bausatz. Und ich hab mir halt viele Sachen, zum Beispiel dieses Schild, auch einfach als Bausatz schicken lassen. Dann bastelst du das halt eben selber zusammen in einer halben Stunde oder löst du das Zeug da drauf. Und so, dann spart man dadurch nochmal ein bisschen Geld. Aber das ist jetzt eher so für den Spaß. Und zwar ist die Status-Anzeige mit Batteriebetrieb und Klapp-Anzeige komplett Bausatz. Kostet 25 Euro das Ding. Da ist es wie gesagt mal so zum Spielen. Der Tomatikzeug ist wie gesagt nicht ganz billig für die Sachen zum Spielen. Da nehme ich eben auch sehr viel FS20-Komponenten oder sowas. Für das, was betriebswichtig ist oder wo mir das drauf ankommt, dass es auch wirklich funktioniert. Wegen Feedback eben auch nehme ich gerne Tomatik. Weil FS20 ist ja eine Unidirektional. Da sendet der Sender halt keine Ahnung, ob die mir mal zuhören.
Das geht gar nicht für sowas. Ich meine, man muss schon irgendwie wissen. Und ich finde auch gerade diese bidirektionale Rückmeldung, wie Schild wurde gedreht, das ist einfach mal geil. Also ich finde überhaupt so mechanische Rückmeldungen, finde ich überhaupt klasse. Du könntest auch so einen Familienbenutzer auf den Tisch stellen, der so bidirektional zurückmeldet, ob er gerade benutzt wurde.
Familienbenutzer?
Ja, der Familienbenutzer.
Was ist denn ein Familienbenutzer? Ihr wisst nicht, was der Familienbenutzer ist? Achso, bei dem ELV-Link siehst du auch schön, wie das Ding sozusagen innen aussieht. So ein bisschen Onig drin und dann ist da halt eben so ein Schild, was halt hoch und runter fährt, also ein Stück Plastik, was hoch und runter fährt, da kannst du halt lustige Schilder draufkleben und irgendwas drauf machen. Das Ding ist ungefähr so groß, ist nicht ganz so breit wie ein iPhone, dafür ein bisschen dicker und ein bisschen länger und das pappst du halt einfach mit doppselten Klebeband oder ein paar Schrauben an die Türen oder irgendwo hin und dann ist gut. Und ja liebe Zuhörer, natürlich habe ich überall da Akkus drin. Klar. Aber die verbrauchen gar nicht so viel. Diese Zeugse ist relativ gut ingeniert. Man muss sich ein paar Sachen, muss man zum Beispiel mal verstehen, auch das ist wirklich dafür gebaut, dass zum Beispiel diese batteriebetriebenen Sensoren, also die mehrere Jahre überstehen. Die Hütte braucht keinen Namen. Die hat n-64-IP-Subnet. Nein, die hat n-56-Subnet, weil ich hab noch einen Gastladen damit, weil ich auch noch mit abspalte. Aber die, was wollte ich sagen, diese Funkkomponenten sind zum Beispiel sehr interessant ingeniert, dass sie zum Beispiel nicht dauernd immer hinhören. Also zum Beispiel so ein Taster sendet nur was und horcht dann, ob er empfangen wurde und geht dann eigentlich relativ häufig wieder offline. Das merkt man bei so Sachen wie zum Beispiel diesen Thermostaten. Ich hab sehr viele von diesen Thermostaten dort in den Räumen auch. Und wenn ich da die Solltemperatur, die ja auch dargestellt wird auf dem Display, dort von der Anlage aussetze, das dauert regelmäßig immer mehrere Sekunden bis auch mal eine Minute oder zwei, bis das da ankommt, weil der halt nicht dauernd immer hinhört. Aber deswegen gesagt, dass man kann halt mit den, auch mit den batteriebetriebenen Dingern relativ lange dort leben. Die geben sogar an für den eine Tastending, das sie zehn Jahre halten soll. Sehe ich jetzt noch nicht, aber... Und da geht, wie gesagt, man könnte sich irgendwann noch mal hingehen. Irgendwann noch mal hingehen und ja, da unten siehst du so ein bisschen die Mechanik. Klick mal auf die dritte von links. Ne, höher, ditter. Da siehst du das, da wird also sozusagen dieses Ding, wird sozusagen hin und her geschoben. Cool, was es für Genete gibt. Es gibt auch so Bastelkomponenten, das heißt, es gibt auch diese Sender und Empfänger einzeln, das heißt, du kannst ja auch selber ohne damit basteln, die dann irgendwelche lustigen Dinge tun. Das wird dich geil. Und wie gesagt, die Idee, wenn man jetzt über diesen Cooks-D Fremdkomponenten mit zunimmt, dann hast du wirklich einen unglaublichen Zoo von Sensoren und Aktoren. Ich sag mal, noch einen lustigen Aktor, den FS-20-Aktor, der so richtig billig ist, auch, nämlich eine lernende Infrarot-Fernbedienung, die du ansteuerst mit dem Haussteuersystem. Das heißt, du hältst dem einmal, was ich zum Beispiel, deine Fernbedienung von deinem Beamer vor oder sowas und lässt die das lernen. Dann hast du so 16 Code Points oder sowas, die du dann irgendwie anlernen kannst und dann hast du halt einen Code Point mit Beamer an. dann kannst du per Haussteuerung deinen Beamer an- und ausmachen. Das ist ein Kostenfaktor von keine Ahnung, keine 30 Euro oder sowas und dann kannst du da halt auch so eine Sachen mit einbinden. Der einzige Nachteil ist, dass die meisten......
den Beamer anmachen, wenn man nicht zu Hause ist? Wenn man nicht zu Hause ist, den Beamer anmachen?
Ja, ne, aber du kannst den halt mit ausmachen. Dabei fiel mir übrigens auf, dass die meisten Hi-Fi- oder Audio- Videokomponenten, die wir haben, gar keinen Ein- und Ausschalter haben. Die haben nicht nur einen solchen. Und da du nicht weißt, wie der State ist, ist das natürlich auch so ein Thema. Das heißt, du...
Ja, aber dann könnte man ja wieder messen, was sie gerade für Strom verbrauchen.
Das kannst du machen. Oder eine Panzenzo.
Hast du so Sachen, dass der über dein iPhone misst? Alles klar, Clemens ist in Berlin, bis der zu Hause ist, ist eine Stunde. Ich mache jetzt hier mal Volltemperatur runter und alles aus, weil, wenn ich merke, er nähert sich auf 50 Kilometer an, dann fange ich langsam an, wieder ein bisschen hochzuheizen.
Du wirst lachen. Es gibt andere Komponenten, oder andere Mechanismen, die man machen kann, zum Beispiel im Zusammenhang mit einer Fritzbox. Oder mit anderen Sachen. Über diesen Cookstick kann man auch so ein paar IP-Spielchen machen. Du kannst zum Beispiel hingehen, eine IP-Adresse pingen. Und wenn der Zustand sich von pingable auf nicht pingable ändert, oder andersrum, kannst du damit was machen. Jetzt kannst du das so einstellen, dass du in deiner Fritzbox, steht jetzt hier für generischen Heimrouter, dass du deinem eigenen iPhone, oder dem iPhone einer beliebigen Person eine feste IP-Adresse gibst, die von dem Ding pingen lässt. Zum Beispiel nimmst du das iPhone deiner Freundin, deiner jeweiligen. Oder beider. Oder verknüpfen drauf machen. Und sagst, wenn dieses iPhone in der Hütte ist, dann nimmst du die vorgegebene Heiztemperatur um zwei Grad höher. Ich sag jetzt mal ein Simplet-Beispiel. Darüber kannst du zum Beispiel feststellen, wie man gerade da ist.
Location-based. Dass man richtig merkt, alles klar, Clemens ist jetzt Freitagabend. Normalerweise programmiert man, du musst bis 18 Uhr arbeiten und die Heizung fängt schon um 17 Uhr an. Damit, wenn du dann irgendwann zu Hause bist, das warm ist. Aber deine Automation zu Hause, dann merkt man, alles klar, Clemens arbeitet heute eine Stunde länger. Weil er ist ja immer noch dort. Weil dein Zuhause-Automation, das du ja sehen kannst, dass du immer noch in Berlin bist und nicht zu Hause. Und dass du dann später anfängst zu heizen. Oder merkt, Clemens geht ins Kino heute, kommt er ganz später, ich muss noch viel später warm machen.
Das mach ich theoretisch. Ich wohn ja da draußen nicht. Aber ich mach das per Hand. Ich hab eine Statusvariable, dass die Hütte weiß, ob sie jetzt sozusagen bewohnt ist.
Per Hand ist klar, mehr automatisiert.
Also was es auch noch geht, muss man dazu sagen. Was ich sehr schick finde, ich hab ja vorhin diesen LAN-Adapter erwähnt. Das heißt, dass an deinen LAN nochmal so eine separate Sendestation stecken kann. Sieht aus wie so ein Kleinet UFO, so Handteller groß. Kostet irgendwie 50 Euro. Und das interessante ist, diese Ding muss nicht im selben LAN sitzen. Das heißt, du kannst sozusagen so ein Ding auch zu Hause anbringen oder in deiner Hütte oder in einem Studio und wie auch immer. Und kannst das trotzdem anbinden an deine Anlage. Das heißt, du kannst eine Haussteuerung machen oder eine Steuerungstechnik machen, die sich über mehr als einen Ort bezieht.
Über mehrere Netze verbinden kannst.
Über IP musst du halt irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass das entsprechend freigeschaltet ist oder mit VPN oder wie auch immer. Aber wenn die CCU das Ding per IP erreichen kann und es muss explizit nicht im lokalen Laden sein, solange es per IP dran kommt, leider nur IPv4. Da muss man ein bisschen dran rumkritisieren. Aber solange es per IPv4 an dieses Ding dran kann, kannst du eben auch deine ganzen Sensoren, Akkoren, Komponenten anzeigen, wie auch immer, woanders hin tun. Du kannst also zum Beispiel auch zu Hause irgendwie eine Lampe oder einen MP3-Funk-Gong anbringen, der dir sagt, in deiner Hütte, wie die Tür aufgeht oder so. Oder jemand da klingelt. Kann man machen.
Ganz neue Optionen für Blink-Lights.
Also da könnte man noch stundenlang drüber rumnerden, was es da noch so gibt. Aber das war jetzt mal so ein bisschen ein Aufriss. Wir können ja mal schauen, was wir da noch so finden. Ich suche mir jede Woche mal einen neuen lustigen Sensor aus, den irgendjemand gemacht hat. Der Sensor des Monats. Und dann schauen wir mal, was es da so für spaßige Sachen gibt.
So, ich muss los.
Ah ja, ich muss dann mithelfen.
Ich hätte noch ein ganz abseitiges, aber doch auch irgendwie nerdiges Thema.
Du willst jetzt noch ein Thema aufmachen? Ich dachte, wir fahren jetzt hier die Saison langsam runter.
Das muss sein. Und zwar, was für Leute, die gerne singen. Das ist mir. Es gibt einen zeitgenössischen Komponisten namens Eric Whitaker. Und der hat vor ein paar Jahren angefangen, einen YouTube-Chor zu machen. Der hat ein Video gemacht, wo man sieht, wie er dirigiert. Und du kannst dann dazu singen. Also er hat einen Klavier-Track eingespielt. Es gibt ein Video, wo er singt und den entsprechenden Stimmgruppen Einsätze gibt. Und dann kann er dirigiert. Er dirigiert, genau. Und du kannst dann dazu singen in deiner jeweiligen Stimmgruppe. Kannst da Noten runterladen und alles machen. Und dann haben die das zum Schluss aus den ganzen Einsendungen, was die Leute auf YouTube hochgestellt haben, haben die das wieder zusammengeschnitten zu einem Chor. Und es gibt jetzt...
Ein ordentlicher Musikproduzent kann das.
Und es gibt jetzt wieder ein Virtual Choir. Nummer 4 nennt er sich das. Ich glaube bis zum... Oh Gott, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wann der Abgabetermin ist. Also, wenn das interessiert, ich schmeiß den Link einfach. In den Chat. Der kann dann da beim 4. Eric Whittaker Virtual Choir mitmachen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es davon schon... Davon gibt es natürlich noch keine Aufnahme von dem Stück. Ich hab zwei der Stücke, die in anderen Virtual Choirs von ihm gemacht wurden, selber mit dem Chor schon mal gesungen. Die Musik muss man halt mögen. Also ich find's sehr schön. Und also hier dieses Sleep und das Luxe Arum Choir, das hab ich beides schon mal gesungen.
Was soll man denn jetzt hier mal anklicken?
Ich glaub Luxe Arum Choir ist der erste, den er überhaupt gemacht hat.
Wollen wir den mal kurz anhören?
Den kannst du mal kurz anhören.
Aber nicht die ganze Zeit. Mach mal.
Singen die irgendwann los?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob hier schon Sound sein sollte. Wieso hören wir nichts?
Nee, ich glaube es ist noch nicht.
Skip, skip, skip.
Eigentlich müsste was zu hören sein. Aber ich höre gerade nichts.
Ja, das Video selber ist ein bisschen kitschig.
Das sieht ja Gott sei Dank jetzt keiner. Aber im Prinzip ist alles aus einzelnen YouTube-Klips oder aus Videoklips zusammengesetzt. Und sind die dann noch die einzelnen Beiträge noch mal irgendwie gesynkt worden?
Wie die das gemacht haben und wie viel Arbeit das war, keine Ahnung. Also in dem Video sieht man halt jetzt die ganzen einzelnen Videos von den Leuten. Also wenn man sich die unterschiedlichen Dinge anhört, da sind dann schon deutliche Qualitätsunterschiede.
Du kannst die einzelnen Dinge auch hören, ne? Also die muss ja eh jeder auf YouTube einstellen.
Die einzelnen Choir-Dinger, die zusammengemischten. Nett. Aber es ist schon witzig, dass...
Schmeiß mal den link noch mal irgendwo rein bitte.
Ja, hab ich in den Chat.
Liegt im Chat, da ist er.
Auch der hier?
Nee, der nicht.
Den schmeiß ich gleich nochmal hinterher. Die Show notes hier auch complete sind.
Wie gesagt, und da entsteht halt gerade ein neues Stück und ich glaub bis zum 10. Juni oder so ist Abgabetermin, da müsste ich nochmal... Mal mal hier reingucken, wer sowas überhaupt mal machen wollte. Der hat jetzt die einmalige Chance, mit dabei zu sein.
Gut, mit diesem Aufruf beenden wir dann auch die Sendung. Ich darf das mal so sagen.
Ist auch mal ein schönes Ende.
Ich hab auch noch einen Termin. Nee, next muss noch eine Staffelübergabe organisieren. Aber ist ja auch sehr schön hier für alle Beteiligten.
Schöner Abschluss mit Musik im Ende. Keep it on.
Genau.
Also sagen wir Tschüss. Tschüss. Michael, vielen Dank für deinen lüblichen Gastauftritt. moab.de Und ja, Tschüss. Das war's mit Obamex dieses Mal. Und nächstes Mal melden wir uns zurück mit den ersten nennenswerten Apple News.
Well that's what we have for you today.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.